Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Na, wie ist der neue James Bond?
Den hab ich ja noch gar nicht.
Hast du auch James Bond noch nicht gesehen?
Nein, ich wollte nicht in die Pressevorführung gehen. Die wäre am Dienstag um 21 Uhr gewesen. Und das sind dann nur noch wenige Stunden, bis man den Film regulär sehen kann. Und dann mache ich das heute nach der Podcastaufnahme. Um 20 Uhr werde ich im Kino sitzen.
Und ich habe im SWF als Verfohrung gehört, du gehst dann einmal alleine, Date mit James Bond und dann nochmal im Freundeskreis, um zu überprüfen, ob dein Urteil stimmt.
Na eigentlich nicht, sondern das ist dann die Spaßveranstaltung. Aber erst muss ich mich ja ganz konzentrieren auf den Film. Und da bin ich eigentlich ganz gern allein.
Sehr gut, sehr gut. Ich war auch allein im Kino in Dune. Ich fand ihn spektakulär gut. Ich musste mir allerdings ein bisschen vorstellen, wie der Director sich das eigentlich gedacht hat. Wieso? Denn ich habe einfach gebucht, bin hin und dann saßen plötzlich alles schon in 3D-Brillen. Ich dachte, brauche ich eine 3D-Brille? Dann bin ich noch mal vor zur Kasse. Das Kinoerlebnis war irgendwie so, ich war am Mittwoch vor dem Kino Donnerstag, wo Dune ins Kino kam und komme, während schon die Werbung läuft ins Kino und da sitzen 15 Leute oder so. Ach ja. Und ich habe gedacht, warte mal, ist es nicht Dune? Warten hier nicht 1000 Leute seit 5 Jahren drauf, dass dieser Film fertig wird? Und es war sehr traurig. Und dann gehe ich durch den Gang alleine, niemand irgendwo zurück zur Kasse, wo genau einer saß, werksfremd, das hat man gemerkt. Wo kriege ich denn eine Brille? Und dann meinte er da drüben. Und dann habe ich gesagt, wie war da drüben? Ja, da sind die Toiletten. Ich wollte keine Toilette, ich brauche eine Brille. Ach so, ja und so. Also ich glaube, Kino ist tot.
Also Dune ist ziemlich erfolgreich. Und das ist gar nicht so leicht für so einen Film, der ja doch das normale Blockbuster-Publikum überfordern könnte, also auch ästhetisch überfordern, ich würde sagen überwältigen könnte. Und da ist jetzt die große Hoffnung, dass Bonn daran anknüpfen kann, dass das auch nochmal ein großer Run wird. Also mein Verhältnis zum Kino ist ja ein erotisches Beinahe. Deswegen möchte ich ja nicht auf das Kino verzichten. Aber ich denke auch, dass jetzt sehr viele Leute das Kino zu schätzen wissen. Aber ich bemerke das auch, was du jetzt sagst, dass es natürlich an vielen Tagen immer noch sehr leer ist. Und dann, glaube ich, ist durch diese ganzen Sachen wie Vorreservierung, die man machen muss, oder was darf ich jetzt gerade, wo es jetzt 2G, wo es 3G, also ist das alles etwas, was natürlich die Lust ins Kino zu gehen, etwas hemmt.
Ja, und dann habe ich den großen Fehler gemacht. Wie gesagt, 3D. Ich habe jetzt nochmal Avatar gesehen. Die Tage, da ist ja auch schon zehn Jahre alt und sieht aber echt noch super top modern aus so oder ist er noch älter? Nee, wann war Avatar?
Ja, noch ein bisschen älter sogar, noch ein Jahr älter.
So krass. Naja, bei Avatar habe ich jedenfalls nochmal festgestellt, das macht Sinn, weil man sitzt so aus der Ego-Perspektive der Avatare zwischen diesen leuchtenden Dingern und die fliegen so um einen rum. Alles schön und gut, nur Dune ist ja ganz anders aufgebaut. In Dune hast du ja eben diese großen breiten Bilder und so, die du ja auch beschrieben hast und es geht total verloren. Es gibt diese eine Szene, den letzten Film, den ich in 3D gesehen habe, ist Jurassic World irgendwas, wo man mit der Brille im Kino sitzt und dann geht plötzlich dieses Tor auf und man sieht die ganze Jurassic World auf einmal im Zentrum dieser gigantische Berg. So und das sieht aber in 3D aus, als würde man in so ein kleines Puppenhaus reingucken.
Ja genau.
Weil ab drei Meter braucht man ja die tiefen Effekte nicht mehr, sondern da will man das Panorama und das kriegt man aber nicht. Und so war das in Dune die ganze Zeit. Also es hat mich wahnsinnig geärgert, dass die Pompö-Sität der Bilder überhaupt nicht transportiert wird durch 3D. Man guckt die ganze Zeit durch so ein Schlüsselloch irgendwie und kriegt eigentlich vom Film so richtig nichts mit. Es werden so die Figuren einfach überbetont. Fand ich auch wieder nicht ganz so schlimm, weil das Casting war spektakulär. Ich glaube selten einen Film einfach so gerne den Schauspielern zugeguckt. Ich weiß nicht, wie es dir da ging. Es ist ja nicht so dein Fall Schauspieler, aber hier habe ich das schon sehr genossen.
Das ist so hervorragend, was diese Leute können, welche Präsenz sie haben und dann auch was Denis Villeneuve mit ihnen macht. Das ist sehr beeindruckend und ich würde dir da Recht geben, es ist bei 3D eigentlich etwas, was man subtil einsetzen müsste. Also man kann natürlich so eine Zauberwelt da erschaffen und da hat aber auch alles schon seine Funktion ausgerichtet auf diesen 3D-Effekt. Das ist ja hier nicht der Fall. Da hat man einfach noch mal so 3D drüber und dann denkt man, wozu eigentlich? Das ist bei Avatar anders, aber ich glaube auch, dass man 3D subtiler einsetzen könnte. Bim Wenders hat das ja ein bisschen getan mit seiner Doku oder seinem Film über Pina Bausch oder Werner Herzog hat das auch getan mit seinem Film über die Chauvet-Höhlen. Auch da hatte er gesagt, ich mach mal diese Höhlenmalerei in einer 3D-Darstellung, wo sie dann eine Tiefe gewinnen. Oder es gab auch diesen anderen Bim Wenders-Film Everything Is Alright oder so heißt er etwa mit James Franco. Und da geht es einfach darum, dass eine Trauer verarbeitet wird innerhalb einer Familie. Und da werden die Gegenstände plötzlich irgendwie ein bisschen lebendig oder die haben so eine besondere Präsenz im Raum durch diesen 3D-Effekt. Aber man muss nicht glauben, dass man nur, wenn man eine 3D-Brille aufsetzt und hat eine weite Landschaft, dass sich da eine neue Welt eröffnet. Im Gegenteil, das ist dann eher das Puppenhaus.
Genau. Es macht super Sinn, 3D-Brillen da aufzusetzen, wo man auch Masken aufsetzt, indoor, wenn die Filme indoor spielen. Aber wenn irgendwelche Raumschiffe fliegen, macht das keinen Sinn. Es zerstört einfach und es ist auch sehr viel dunkler. Ich finde auch die 3D-Technik funktioniert weiterhin nicht. Ich sehe weiterhin auf dem linken Auge noch so ein bisschen, was das rechte Auge sehen soll. Also ich sehe den Film irgendwie so doppelt. Es ist nicht ganz grün und rot, so wie früher, aber es ist trotzdem störend und war deswegen blöd. Jetzt muss ich mir den Film noch mal angucken. Ich überlege, ob ich noch mal ins Kino gehe.
Ja, die Kinobetreiber können es brauchen. Und jetzt beginnen wir einen Podcast nach der Bundestagswahl und sprechen erst mal über einen Kinofilm und nicht über die Bundestagswahl. Wie wichtig ist die Bundestagswahl denn?
Na, sie ist natürlich super wichtig für Europa, für die Welt und für uns Deutsche natürlich auch. Aber das wurde ja schon überbetont im Fernsehen. Sie zählt ja im Grunde nur für uns Deutsche. Dass noch jemand auf die Bundestagswahl guckt, wurde ja ausgeblendet. Ich würde aber sagen, es ist alles wie erwartet passiert. Es gibt jetzt keine Überraschungen oder Sonstiges.
Ziemlicher Stillstand, wie wir das gedacht haben.
Mir fehlt noch ein bisschen das CDU-Spektakel. Ich finde, der Zerlegungsprozess darf ruhig ein bisschen schneller gehen. Warum die jetzt noch eine Woche warten, keine Ahnung. Und in deren Sicht würde ich sagen, gibt es gar nicht viel zu sagen. Eine Pointe wollte ich allerdings doch setzen. Ich weiß nicht, ansonsten, wenn du noch irgendwas zur Bundestagswahl kommentieren möchtest.
Mach du mal deine Pointe erst.
Okay, also Robert Havik hat natürlich seine Standard-Pressekonferenz gegeben. Wir kennen sie schon. Sein Zitat lautet, Deutschland, es kann was Neues passieren. Wacht doch mal auf jetzt und so. Programmatisch ist da jetzt mal was möglich. Das stimmt ja auch. Keine CDU in der Regierung ist auf jeden Fall immer gut. Egal, was dann tatsächlich rauskommt. Da kann man ja abwarten. Und zu diesen Vorabgesprächen mit der FDP, sagte Robert Habeck Folgendes.
In der Tat gab es für mich schon mal eine Art ähnliche Situation 2017. Nur etwas andere Vorzeichen. Damals war ja schon eine Regierung mit Grün und SPD im Amte und die hat die Mehrheit verloren. Also man kann es nicht genau gleich parallelisieren. Aber in der Tat wurden Ampel und Jamaika parallel sondiert und auf einmal mussten Grün und FDP miteinander reden. Und das hatte da vielleicht eine eher geübte Tradition, dass man schon mal ein paar Kanäle gelegt hat. Insofern ist das alles nicht exakt gleich vergleichbar. Aber eine Idee, wie so ein Bündnis Leben bekommen kann und aus einem Gewürge und Gestolperer heraus vielleicht eine eigene Identität finden kann, die gibt es schon. Und das hat nur was mit professionellem Umgang zu tun, denke ich. Dass man jetzt versteht, dass der Wahlkampf vorbei ist und die Verhältnisse nun so sind, wie sie sind. Und da muss man eben das Beste draus machen. Und das Beste draus machen kann, das zeigen ja sowohl die Ampelregierung in Rheinland-Pfalz wie auch die Jamaika-Regierung in Schleswig-Holstein bei all den jeweiligen Problemen, die es gibt, eben auch zu einer guten Regierung führen. Und die muss jetzt gebaut werden.
So, eine gute Regierung muss jetzt gebaut werden. Wäre es Ergebnis rot-grün, hätte sich alles sparen können, weil dann hätten die Leute gewusst, ja gut, rot-grün halt, macht mal einen Koalitionsvertrag und fertig. Jetzt muss er die FDP irgendwie ins Boot holen und kommt hier so mit Worten wie Gehänge und Gewürge. Und das will man ausschließen. Das haben sie ja ihren coolen Stunt gemacht mit dem Instagram-Bild. Hast du auch Medienanfragen bekommen, ob du noch mal als Bildkritiker oder so dieses Foto einschätzt?
Zum Glück nicht, nein.
Wirklich im Deutschlandfunk hoch und runter. Aber dann immer am Ende noch mal, so wichtig ist das Bild ja jetzt auch nicht, nachdem wir eine halbe Stunde drüber gesprochen haben. Naja, das können wir ja alles ausblenden. Man muss jetzt irgendwie mit der FDP in Umgang finden. Wir haben ja oder du hast ja uns schon dargestellt, wie der Lifestyle so ist, der auch bei Jungenwählern zur FDP-Stimme führt. Und sie haben ja die Grünen tatsächlich geschlagen.
Erstwähler 23 Prozent. Und das sind ja nicht alles Kinder aus Millionärsfamilien.
Richtig, richtig. Ein Prozent noch mehr als die Grünen da abgesandt. Und wenn man jetzt eine Analyse macht, auf die ich noch warte, die man eigentlich mal machen müsste, dass man sagt, okay, wir blenden jetzt mal die Stimmen über 70 aus. Weil da wissen wir, das sind Traditionswähler, die denken da wirklich mal, also das ist ganz dispektierlich, aber so ist es überwiegend. Die Jungen denken noch drüber nach, wen sie wählen. Umso jünger, umso mehr denken wir drüber nach. Gleich bei der ersten Stimme. Und man muss dann schon sagen, ja, FDP und die Grünen sind zwar die kleineren Koalitionspartner neben der SPD am Ende, aber sie sind dann trotzdem von erheblichem ideellen Gewicht irgendwie für Deutschland. Ja, also da ist so ein bisschen was los. Dass sie jetzt zuerst miteinander sprechen, hat ja Scholz auch schon gewusst und hat dann gesagt, hier, die sollen mal erst miteinander, dann können sie zu mir kommen. Also hat das sozusagen abgesegnet vorab, weil er wusste, okay, da braut sich was zusammen. Und dann müssen wir auch mal gucken, wo wir bleiben. Gerade weil Scholz ja auch wieder 48 Jusos, also unter 35-jähriger Bundestagsabgeordnete hat. Und 48 ist ja genau die Zahl, mit der sie über dem Durst der Mehrheit wären. Also Scholz kann man ganz schön einklammern zwischen Juso, FDP und Grün. So, und ich hätte jetzt einen Vorschlag für die Grünen, wie man dieses Problem hier einfach löst, aus einem Gehänge und Gewürge rauszukommen. Und zwar sollte Robert Habeck, und das meine ich jetzt gar nicht so unernst, sagen, die FDP hat Recht. Als Einzige hat die FDP ein Programm vorgelegt, das das 1, 5 Grad Ziel einhalten kann. Habeck hat ja selbst zugestanden, unser Programm schafft das Ziel nicht ganz, aber es ist sozusagen ein Einstieg in ein Programm und am Ende beschleunigt sich ja auch der Prozess und so weiter und so fort. Also er hat ja für sich selbst eingestanden, wir schaffen es nicht, die 1, 5 Grad Ziel zu erhalten. Die FDP behauptet aber von sich, sie macht das und ich finde, und wir hören uns jetzt mal an, Mendy hat uns das, glaube ich, auch im richtigen Ton vorgelesen, wie die FDP das meinte. Das Kapitel ist nicht sehr lang, drei Seiten. Und auf der ersten Seite, wir lesen den allerersten Einstieg ins Klimakapitel der FDP. Und ich finde, Robert Habeck sollte jetzt das Zugeständnis machen an die FDP und sagen, so machen wir es. Wir haben keinen anderen Anspruch an die Zielsetzung und an die Programmatik. Wir machen es, wie die FDP es will, und die FDP will es im Wortlaut so.
Die Politik gibt vor, wie viel CO2 im Jahr ausgestoßen werden darf. Für den Ausstoß müssen Zertifikate erworben werden, die von Jahr zu Jahr weniger und damit teurer werden. Wer hingegen besonders viel CO2 spart, muss weniger Zertifikate kaufen und spart Geld. Und wer CO2 speichert, muss dafür Geld erhalten. So schaffen wir Anreize für Investitionen in klimafreundliche Technologien. Wir bekennen uns ausdrücklich zu dem Ziel aus dem Pariser Abkommen, die Erderwärmung auf 1, 5 Grad Celsius zu begrenzen. Deutschland und Europa haben sich zur Klimaneutralität bis zum Jahr 2050 verpflichtet. Dieses Ziel können wir durch ein striktes und jährlich sinkendes CO2-Limit in einem umfassenden Emissionshandelssystem zuverlässig erreichen.
So, man rechnet das CO2-Budget durch, klebt an jede Tonne, die man errechnet hat, ein Preisschild und sagt, der Markt soll mal den Preis jetzt finden. Wir haben nur das Preisschild dran gehangen, der Markt muss jetzt den Preis draufschreiben. Und quarks.de hat ja mal hier nachgerechnet, Experten schätzen mindestens 150 Euro pro Tonne CO2, um eine Lenkungswirkung zu verursachen. Und die müsste ja kommen, um zu sagen, das CO2-Budget ist gedeckelt. Sie sprechen von klaren Limits, 1, 5 Grad Ziel usw. Sie gehen ja da all in. Das Umweltbundesamt rechnet schon mit 200 Euro. Und eine Untersuchung des Deutschen Instituts für Wirtschaftsforschung geht sogar von noch höheren Preisen aus.
220, 230 habe ich auch gelesen.
Und Energiezukunft.eu ist eine Seite, die sich auch um sowas kümmert. Da hat man auch noch mal die verursachergerechten Umverteilung der Energiewendekosten durchkalkuliert. Da kommt z.B. der Verband der kommunalen Unternehmer in einer Studie auf deutlich über 300 Euro pro Tonne CO2. Also 300 Euro, wir sind jetzt irgendwo bei 50. Wenn man sich im Handelsblatt die aktuelle Nachrichtenlage und das ist auch interessant, wie das Handelsblatt darüber schreibt, seit 2018 steigt der CO2-Preis endlich. Also man erwartet sich auch im Handelsblatt endlich hier mal ein bisschen Lenkungswirkung. Lager im März 2020 bei unter 16 Euro, ist er mittlerweile bei rund 50 Euro je Tonne angekommen. Aber dieser, wie sie auch in Anführungszeichen schreiben, Ablasshandel hat eben noch so ein kleines Schönheitsproblemchen. Und zwar haben sich sehr viele Unternehmen wie RW z.B. relativ früh zu relativ billigen Preisen überbordend viel CO2-Zertifikate gekauft. Das heißt, der Markt ist schon verknappt. Wir müssten also zu den 300 Euro, die jetzt die kommunalen Unternehmer erwarten, eigentlich nochmal die schon durchgeführte Verknappung hinzurechnen und wären hier locker bei 600, 700, wenn nicht 1000 Euro pro Tonne CO2. Und da würde ich sagen, sollten die Grünen einfach sagen, wir machen uns mal genauso. Die FDP hat einen guten Vorschlag gemacht, das machen wir jetzt. Nur damit Journalisten das mal durchrechnen, was das eigentlich bedeutet. Und diesen Schaden, und das ist ein Schaden, der da entsteht, weil das wäre zu haurig, den einfach der FDP in die Schuhe zu schieben.
Ja, ganz richtig. Und die Grünen haben es ja auch in ihrem Wahlprogramm mal so, dann beziffert ich glaube auf 260, 280 Euro pro Tonne. Und dann haben sie dann auch gesagt, aber was der CO2-Preis momentan ist. Und das bedeutet ja im Umkehrschluss, wir alle subventionieren, dass die Energie so billig ist. Das heißt, die müssen nur 50 zahlen, aber müssten eigentlich 250 zahlen. Also 200 Euro oder nach deiner Rechnung zahlen sie 50 und müssten eigentlich 600 zahlen. Und dafür kommen wir auf. Also wir kommen dafür auf, dass die Profite möglichst hoch bleiben. Und da kann man das wunderbar dann verdrehen. Und da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, wie dann die FDP darauf reagiert. Weil die weiß natürlich, wenn sie von Zertifikaten und so weiter spricht, dass das eine Lenkungswirkung hat. Aber man wird lange genug Schlupflöcher bieten, wird lange genug zögern, damit man jetzt ja nicht kurzfristig Unternehmer gegen sich aufbringt.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, also Schlupflöcher, die FDP lässt hier keinen Spielraum. Das ist nur dieser eine Absatz. Hier steht Klimaneutralität bis 2050 ist für uns verpflichtend. Wir brauchen ein striktes und jährlich sinkendes CO2-Limit. Damit ist der Satz zu Ende hier. Da kommt kein weiteres Schlupfloch. Und wir erkennen das 1, 5-Grad-Ziel an. Aus dem Pariser Abkommen steht ausdrücklich so drin. Also eigentlich ist hier gar kein Schlupfloch mehr da. Jetzt hat RWE und so die Hälfte weggekauft. Also wir haben es mit einer extremen Verknappung jetzt schon zu tun. Man müsste jetzt einfach nur das restliche CO2-Budget einmal durchkalkulieren, auf CO2-Tonnen runterrechnen und dann dem Markt einfach sagen, ja, die Sachlage jetzt schlagt mal zu. Und dann wird einfach eine Auktion statt. Und es würde mich wundern, wenn wir nicht innerhalb eines Jahres hier bei vierstelligen Beträgen wären. Ich meine, es wundert mich, dass es bisher noch nicht so durchkalkuliert wurde.
Ja, sowas müsste man ja auch verklickern können. Also das kriegt man ja relativ gut in der Öffentlichkeit präsentiert.
Ich finde, genau, das ist ja sehr übersichtlich.
Das ist eine recht simple Rechnung. Aber das ist offenbar dann nicht der Fall. Also wenn die Leute simpel rechnen würden und das auch vorgerechnet bekämen, dann würden sie wahrscheinlich auch ins Rüben kommen, ob die FDP so die richtige Partei ist. Ja, das ist ja doch eine interessante Sache. Also ich glaube auch, das hängt mit dem zusammen, was ich hier schon mal beschrieben habe, dass die die sozialen Medien sehr gut bedienen, dass das auch genau diese Influencer-Logik ist. Jetzt sich selbstständig machen, den amerikanischen Traum leben, hier, du kannst alles sein. Das ist ja eigentlich etwas, was man ad acta legen könnte in einer Abstiegsgesellschaft oder in einer Gesellschaft, wo die Mieten so teuer sind, dass man sich kaum noch das Leben in der Stadt leisten kann. Und doch sind dann Einzelne, die es geschafft haben. Und die erzählen dann bei Insta und sonst wo. Du kannst das auch. Es ist alles ganz einfach. Und sonst investier doch mal in Kryptowährung. Ich glaube auch, dass die FDP etwas davon profitiert hat, dass sie eine kritische Haltung zu den Corona-Maßnahmen eingenommen hat, ohne ins Querdenkermilieu oder so abzudriften. Sondern man hat gesagt, na ja, aber es gibt auch junge Leute und das gehört auch zum Leben dazu und und. Man ist da mit Unterbrachial vorgegangen. Und ich bin da jetzt auch nicht für alles, was die gesagt haben. Aber ich würde gerade so Twitter-Linksliberalen mal sagen, ich glaube nicht, dass junge Leute sich stark mit Karl Lauterbach identifizieren können. Der hat zwar jetzt guter Ergebnis an seinem Wahlkreis bekommen, aber junge Leute überlegen, wer ist jetzt potenziell mein Vater. Und jetzt stellt man sich vor, will man einen Vater wie Karl Lauterbach haben, der eigentlich bei allem, was man tut, und ich gehe heute Abend noch mal länger raus, sei aber vorsichtig, da gibt es noch das und das, will man sich das alles anhören? Nein, eher nicht. Und dann findet man so dieses bisschen hemmsärmelige Auftreten von FDP-Leuten, wahrscheinlich als Jugendlicher, vor allem auch als Mann, attraktiver. Und damit kann man, glaube ich, auch ganz gut Stimmen gewinnen. Ansonsten ist es natürlich ein großes Desaster, wenn wir da ein Finanzministerium haben.
Aber vielleicht hat er genau die Karte verspielt. Dass er nämlich zu früh die Ansage machte, unter der Voraussetzung, dass Laschet darüber befindet am Ende. Und jetzt sollte man hinten sagen, na hör mal zu, wir machen diese Koalition, aber dieses Zugeständnis können wir nicht machen, weil dann sehen wir alle wie Loser aus. Wenn wir hier so ein Laschet-Zugeständnis dir jetzt plötzlich geben. Und noch mal zu dem Alter. Also ich glaube, Alter ist ganz prägend. Wir können uns ja überlegen, wie diese Selfie-Aussehe mit den Pendants aus CDU und SPD. Mützenich, Olaf Scholz. Das ist dann schon die Opa-Generation, Laschet. Während wir bei FDP und Grünen die Väter- und Mütter-Generation gesehen haben. Das ist glaube ich ein großer Unterschied. Denn mit Vater und Mutter hat man heute ein sehr freundschaftliches Verhältnis, während Oma und Opa dann doch mehr so alte Schule sind. Also der OK-Boomer-Zuruf ist eigentlich auf die Großeltern gemünzt heutzutage. Und die FDP sollte sich nochmal genau anschauen, ihr Wahlergebnis und da wo sie besonders mobilisiert haben, ob da der Lifestyle prägend war oder doch so harte Argumente wie Schuldenbremse muss sein. Weil es gibt eine Schuldenbremsenfraktion in den CDU-Wählern. Also Ralph Brinkhaus sagt das nicht ohne Grund. Ich kenne auch selber so um die 50-Jährige, die dann mich groß angucken und dann immer mit diesen Standardargumenten die künftigen Generationen und ach du behauptest ja immer, es gäbe so eine unendliche Geldquelle, wo ich dann immer nur noch trotzig sage, ja die gibt es ja auch. Keine weitere Argumentation an der Stelle. Aber es gibt eine harte Schuldenbremsenfraktion. Ich sehe die aber bei der Wählerschaft jetzt nicht bei der FDP.
Nein, ich glaube auch, dass ein 80-Jähriger und auch ein 25-Jähriger sich nicht Gedanken über die Schuldenbremse macht. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Ja genau, die sollten jetzt auf Lifestyle und sowas lachen.
Man wird vielleicht das auch noch so mit abnicken, weil man mal gehört hat, Schulden sind ja nicht gut und ich selbst will ja auch keine haben. Aber sonst gibt es da ja nicht diesen ideologischen Ansatz, den jetzt über 50-Jährige da verfolgen, weil sie den auch immer eingehämmert bekommen haben. Also ich glaube, das ist ganz stark mit Lifestyle und so verknüpft. Und ich glaube, auch wenn man davon abrücken würde, würde man nicht viele FDP-Wähler verkraulen.
Genau, und deswegen würde ich sagen, Bundestagswahl fand statt. Man kann das jetzt locker sehen. Alle werden ein bisschen von ihren Lebenspositionen abrücken.
Aber es wäre ja auch mal rot-rot-grün denkbar gewesen. Und dass das dann auch nicht, dass die Linke da 4, 9 Prozent hat. Es ist wirklich dramatisch, dass dieses Land auch dann immer noch nicht die CDU satt genug hat. Also sie hat ja dann doch noch viele Stimmen bekommen. Also dass dann Laschet auch noch mal aufgeholt hat, der ja auch der denkbar schlechteste Kandidat überhaupt war. Das ist schon sehr traurig. Und dann fahre ich aber im ICE aus Berlin am Wahlsonntag zurücksitze. Also um 18 Uhr im Zug im Abteil mit zwei Menschen dort. Ein Herr mir gegenüber, eine Dame nebenan. Und um 18 Uhr packe ich natürlich dann auch mal den Laptop aus und will mal gucken, wie es dann aussieht.
War das nicht durchgesagt wie Fußballergebnisse?
Nein, das nicht. Und dann dachte ich, natürlich werden jetzt die Mitfahrer das ebenso tun. Aber nein, der Herr da gegenüber mir füllte irgendwelche Unterlagen aus. Und die Dame neben mir las ein Krimi. Und um 18.30 Uhr sagte sie, oh jetzt muss ich aber doch mal meine Freundin anrufen. Und ich dachte, jetzt kommt Bundestagswahl. Und sie sagte, denn wir haben einen Tisch reserviert im Restaurant. Und kommen ja jetzt etwas später an. Also das fand ich interessant. Also die Bundestagswahl fand in diesem Abteil, auch wenn es nicht so repräsentativ ist, aber es fand einfach dort nicht statt. Und dann habe ich mich gefragt, was ist das eigentlich? Oder was ist das, dass es nicht stattfindet? Beziehungsweise es fand vielleicht statt, dass sie gewählt haben. Aber jetzt, ach ja, kann man ja mal morgen sehen. Und die haben wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht besonders progressiv gewählt, würde ich mir unterstellen. Weil Leute, die jetzt eher progressiv wählen, interessieren sich vielleicht ein bisschen mehr. Und vielleicht haben die verlässlich ihr Kreuz beilachtet gemacht. Ich weiß es nicht.
Es ist CDU-Fatigue. Long Lockdown, Schwarze Republik.
So, und dann habe ich aber was gesehen. Und zwar gab es ja noch ein anderes großes Ereignis. Vielleicht hast du es aber gar nicht mitbekommen in diesem Monat in Zwickau.
Habe ich nicht mitbekommen.
Ich auch nur durch Zufall. Mir hat es jemand zugeschickt. Und zwar gab es in Zwickau einen Weltrekord. Anfang des Monats. Und wir hören uns jetzt diesen Beitrag an. Dieser Beitrag stammt aus TV West Sachsen. Ich bin ja ein großer Fan des Regionalferns. Ich kann mich da köstlich amüsieren. Und jetzt versuchen wir mal, wie wir das damals gemacht haben, bei der Show Bares für Rares, versuchen wir jetzt auch mal hier diese Mentalität zu bekommen. Nehmen auch nochmal alles so aus den vergangenen Folgen mit in den Blick. Urbanisierung, neue Städte, grüne Städte. Wie kann eigentlich neues Zusammenleben stattfinden? Und jetzt treffen wir auf die Realität. Wir hören uns an, was da in Zwickau ist. Und das wird jetzt erstmal von der Nachrichtensprecherin eingeleitet, was da Großes bevorstand.
Ich bin gespannt.
In der DDR-Fernsehsendung Außenseiter Spitzenreiter wurde im Jahr 1976 der Beweis angetreten, dass 17 Personen in den Trabi passen. Der Rekord wurde damals in Zwickau aufgestellt. Getoppt wurde das 2019 von 18 jungen Frauen eines Tanzvereins aus dem brandenburgischen Atlanzberg. Das wollten die Zwickauer nicht auf sich sitzen lassen und wollten den Titel zurück.
Ja, warte mal, 17 Leute waren schon in einem Trabi und die da sagten, sie können das toppen.
Genau, das waren 17 Leute damals in dieser DDR-Sendung. Also man geht nochmal in die Historie zurück und dann gab es aus Brandenburg einen weiteren Rekordversuch, der geglückt ist, da hat man dann 18 Leute reingebracht. Und jetzt sagen die Zwickau, aber jetzt haben wir ja unseren Weltrekord verloren, den wir ja damals 79 im DDR-Fernsehen aufgestellt haben. Das lassen wir nicht auf uns sitzen.
Ich bin ja Ossi, du bist ja ein Wessi. Bist du schon mal Trabi gefahren?
Nein.
Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, dass der Trabi selbst für mich als 8-jährigen, 7-jährigen zu klein war. Hinten reinklettern, immer so ein Sitz vorklappen und so. Und dann habe ich hier in Frankfurt mal wieder so einen Trabi, der nur noch so aus Showgründen irgendwie so auf der Straße rumsteht, gesehen. Und habe gedacht, jedes Auto neben diesem Trabi ist ein SUV. Und 18 Leute ist einfach unvorstellbar. Also ich bin sehr gespannt, ob es geklappt.
Also es sind junge Frauen und sie dürfen nicht kleiner als 1, 54 sein. Das ist offenbar wichtig für diesen Rekord. Und wir haben aber jetzt schon gehört, da ist eine gewisse Ernsthaftigkeit dabei. Und jetzt sehen wir hier Ideologie auf dem Marktplatz. Und wir hören jetzt mal in dieses geschäftige Treiben rein.
Der Initiator war in diesem Fall der Verein Interdrapp. Gestern Nachmittag war es dann so weit. Bereits ab 14 Uhr herrschte geschäftiges Treiben auf dem Zwickauer Hauptmarkt. Der MDR übertrug das Spektakel live. Dicht gedrängt standen die Schaulustigen, um zu verfolgen, ob die Mädels des BSV Sachsens Zwickau gemeinsam mit den Turnerinnen des Turn- und Sportvereins Fliegende Sachsen den Rekord knacken würden.
Große Liturgie eigentlich sonst in der Stadt, aber jetzt sind noch mal alle da und gucken sich an, was wird da passieren? Kriegen die da 19 junge Frauen in diesen Trabi?
Ja, also es gibt ja unter Polizeisportlern auch diesen Sport, wie viel Männer kriegt man auf ein Motorrad? Da baut man so Pyramiden und so. Das ist so äquivalent dazu, wobei man glaube ich das Spektakuläre ein bisschen unterschätzt, wenn die da nur reinkrappeln, aber ich glaube, das erfordert genauso viel Planung und Übung, wie eine Pyramide auf so ein Motorrad zu machen.
Ich will den Damen da gar keine Talente absprechen. Ich stelle nur in Frage, was da eigentlich passiert. Also siehst du dich auf diesem Marktplatz stehen? Also ich frage wirklich dich nicht, dass jetzt deine Kinder sagen, wir wollen mal gucken, ob die da an den Trabi passen.
Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht. Aber ich sehe mich den Instagram Real oder den YouTube Short dazu ansehen. Das glaube ich schon.
Du guckst dann nicht mehr TV West Sachsen. So, jetzt Rekordversuch.
Dann ging es los, nach und nach kletterten die Mädels ins Fahrzeug. Eigentlich hätten sie zehn Minuten Zeit gehabt. In kürzester Zeit war es dann vollbracht. Bei laufendem Motor wurde dann auch noch die Hupe betätigt. Das Publikum zählte mit, als nach und nach die Mädels den Trabi verließen. Groß war dann natürlich die Überraschung, als nicht wie geplant 19, sondern sogar 20 junge Frauen aus dem Fahrzeug kletterten.
Was macht das mit dir als Systemtheoretiker? Was passiert da?
Vielleicht kennst du die tolle Dessertation von Osretzky, vor allem aber weiß ich gerade nicht. Ah nee, das war noch eine andere. Es gibt jedenfalls einen schönen Text über Faltungen. Wir reden ja immer von Entfaltung. Aber was ist eigentlich das Gegenteil von Faltung? Irgendwann muss ja auch mal wieder Komplexität reduziert werden und dann wird halt gefaltet. Und hier haben wir es, glaube ich, mit einer ganz interessanten Faltung zu tun. Das wäre mein System.
Was sagt das dann eigentlich über unsere Bundesrepublik? Oder ich will es noch anders einladen. Ich war ja in Berlin zum Wahlwochenende und die Berliner waren ja idiotisch genug, auch noch gleichzeitig einen Berlin-Marathon abzuhalten, sodass man nicht mehr wegkam bzw. nicht zum Wahllokal kam. Also wirklich die dümmste Idee der Welt. Und ich sah aber dann auch im Frühstückssaal des Hotels diese ganzen Marathonläufer aus England, Amerika und sonst wo sitzen. Und ich hatte nicht mehr den Eindruck, dass da noch irgendwie politische Subjekte sitzen, sondern ich hatte eigentlich nur noch so Menschen vor mir, die so ganz auf das Basale konzentriert waren. Was kippt man oben rein? Was kommt unten wieder raus? Wie kann man sich dann bewegen? Was zeigt die Uhr mir gerade an? Wie viele Kalorien noch? Und was weiß ich? Also ich bin doch über diese entpolitisierten Bürger immer wieder verwundert, das so zu sehen. Genauso auch dann in Zwickau zu stehen und den Nachmittag damit zuzubringen, ob junge Frauen in einen Trappi passen, was ja auch eine völlig unerhebliche Frage ist.
Aber ist das nicht... Ich glaube, es gibt da irgendwo so ein Sweetspot an Interesse und Desinteresse. Klar, wir haben eine Grundgesamtheit, die wählt. Und wir haben sehr viele Arme und so weiter, die dann so sind. Also es ist nicht weder mit die Milieu als Problem, haben wir ja beschrieben. Aber so ein allgemeines Desinteresse, also im Zug zu sitzen und den Abend gar nicht, wirklich auch an einem Wahlabend auf Ingo Zamparuni 22.30 Uhr zu warten.
Habe ich ja auch nicht gemacht. Also ich bin ja ins Kino dann um 20 Uhr.
Genau, aber so diesen 18 Uhr-Termin einfach zu übersehen. Man betonte ja immer wieder in Deutschland, dass es ja doch toll ist, dass eigentlich egal ist, wer Kanzler wird. Irgendwie denkt man, auf der einen Seite könnte man in diesen Richard-David-Brecht-Zynismus abdriften, ja es ist eigentlich egal, wer Kanzler wird. Oder man denkt sich, ja es ist eigentlich wirklich egal, wer Kanzler wird. Am Ende werden wir halt irgendwie gut regiert, weil genug aufmerksame Leute dann doch wählen gehen. Und so eine Stichprobe von der Hälfte der Bevölkerung dann eigentlich reicht und die anderen blasen das Ergebnis noch ein bisschen auf. Aber es ist im Grunde wie es ist, die Extremisten sind irgendwie eingefangen. Am Ende ist es halt so, wie es ist. Und man kann dann auch an so einem Wahlwochenende seinem Hobby nachgehen und muss sich da eben nicht groß drum kümmern. Also hat er auch einen Vorzug, denn diese Hyper-Politisierung, alle interessieren sich für Politik, weil sie nicht aus eigenem Interesse, sondern weil sie die ganze Zeit von außen geliefert bekommen. Was weiß ich, in Österreich treten drei Parteien an und klären das aber in 50 TV-Gesprächen vorher, wo die Kandidaten zugegen sind. Das ist ja auch nicht die Lösung.
Das wäre für mich auch keine sinnvolle Politisierung. Aber angesichts der drängenden Fragen, die sich erstellen und die sich vermutlich nicht auch mit Zertifikaten nur lösen lassen bzw. nicht so wie die FDP das Wort, angesichts der Ungleichheit, angesichts all dieser vielen Probleme, ist es doch sehr erstaunlich, dass es gar nicht besonders ziel bzw. ist, selbst dann, wenn all das da ist und dann auch noch eine Ära Merkel endet, es keinen wirklichen Umschwung gibt. Also dass dann nicht jetzt anders nachgedacht wird über Politik, sondern dass man eigentlich jetzt in diesem Modus ist, dass ich ja auch sage, ja irgendwas werden die wohl jetzt da ausbaldowern. Es geht am Ende ja darum, wer bekommt welches Ministerium und wer kann da noch ein paar Angestellte unterbringen und sonst was. Also es ist ja für mich auch nicht so, dass ich noch da sitze und jetzt Großes erwarte, sondern hoffe, dass es nicht ganz so schlimm wird. Der Mindestlohn 12 Euro wird dann mit einer Jamaika-Koalition nicht kommen. Ich weiß ja, kommt mit einer Ampel-Koalition wahrscheinlich. Wird dann aber bei 11 Euro starten, weil man jetzt dann noch mal zugestellt ist, an die FDP macht. Das ist halt einfach scheiße, aber das kann ich dann relativ gut noch für mich ausbilden, weil ich jetzt direkt nicht davon betroffen bin. Aber es ist sehr deprimierend eigentlich. Und dann sehe ich halt, dass Menschen sich mehr dafür interessieren, ob 19 Frauen, die nicht kleiner als 1, 54 sind, in einen Trabi passen.
Ich mache ein Aber daraus und dann widerspreche ich dir. Also das Aber ist, wenn du einen Frühstücksbefehl mit lauter Sportlern hast, die einen Marathon laufen wollen, dann ist klar, jeder von denen hat sich seit Monaten darauf vorbereitet. Und genau diese Vorbereitung könnte man ja auch, und die sieht man ja an diesem Moment nicht, sondern da frühstücken sie einfach nur. Ja, das Training vorher ist nicht zu sehen. Und so könnte man ja auch wählen, dass man einfach eine Planung hat. Okay, ich informiere mich jetzt im laufenden Betrieb abends. Ich gucke brav die Nachrichten. Und weil ich den Wahltag zu tun habe mit einer sportlichen Herausforderung, mache ich vor, eine Briefwahl. Und dafür ist es mir dann aber am Wahlabend egal. Und jetzt könnte man ja sagen, vielleicht ist das wirklich auch gerade ein Vorzug. Denn wenn es anders wäre, wenn man in Hab-8-Stellung am Wahltag aufpassen müsste, was in Berlin passiert, weil das eigene Schicksal in, was weiß ich, wo elementar davon abhängt, ob jetzt irgendwelche Milizen auf der Straße rumrennen und hier versuchen irgendwelche Sachen, dann wäre es sozusagen sichtbar, dass es nicht funktioniert. Aber ich finde, du hast eine sehr funktionierende Gesellschaft gesehen, die nämlich Arbeitsteilung, funktionale Lieferatierung hinbekommt.
Also da hat nicht mal die Organisation geklappt und ich weiß auch nicht, warum man das macht. Aber diese Zwickau-Geschichte war jetzt auch nicht am Wahltag. Ich glaube, dass es ein Desinteresse dann um 18 Uhr bei einigen Leuten gibt. Andererseits gab es ja auch hohe Quoten. Über 30 Millionen haben Fernseh geguckt, dann manchmal zur gleichen Zeit, wenn diese Hochrechnungen kommen. Nur glaube ich, dass wir generell nicht eine politisierte Gesellschaft haben, in dem Sinne, dass sie wirklich auch veränderungsbereit sind. Sondern das ist dann wirklich die Rentnerrepublik. Also das ist ja natürlich auch die Rentnerrepublik, die du in einem solchen Beitrag erleben kannst. Und zwar braucht man dann ein paar junge Leute, die in diesen Trabi steigen, weil das wahrscheinlich 70-Jährige nicht mehr können. Wie viele Rentner bekommt man eigentlich seinen Trabi? Das wäre auch wieder eine Frage, die man stellen könnte. Aber es ist eigentlich sehr deprimierend. Und das Interessante ist eigentlich bei diesem Beitrag, dass so ein ideologischer Überbau ist. Also es ist nicht einfach, guten Tag, wir sind ein bisschen doof und deswegen haben wir eine Quatschveranstaltung gemacht. Wie man irgendwie sagt, so jetzt mache ich mal noch irgendwas Bescheuertes, mach was weiß ich. Sondern man will jetzt auch noch so einen ideologischen Überbau schaffen von so funktioniert unsere Stadt, das ist unsere Gemeinschaft.
Aber da kannst du es halt wirklich übertreiben und sagen, der Trabi als Symbol für, weißt du noch, als wir jung waren. Und dann siehst du da aber auch nur junge Menschen. Und zwar umso mehr, desto besser. Umso mehr junge Menschen, umso toller ist das, was du erlebst. Also da kann man natürlich all in gehen.
Es ist frustrierend. Also ich kann ja auch nie verstehen, dass Leute so auf Stadtfeste oder so gehen. Aber jetzt hören wir uns das mal hier an. Also ganz kurz.
Aber schön, dass in Zwickau wieder was passiert. Aber wir haben für Zwickau auch mal wieder ein Highlight geschaffen.
Ja, das auf jeden Fall.
Ja, das ist traurig.
Das ist eigentlich das Traumwächste überhaupt. Und es geht aber noch weiter, denn auch die Wirtschaft kommt jetzt noch mit ins Spiel. Es hat auch noch eine wirtschaftliche Komponente, denn es wurden auch zwei Fässer Bier gespendet. Und da hören wir jetzt auch mal, wie gut das funktioniert hat.
Ganz tolle Sache.
Also für Zwickau ist das toll.
Und man sieht auch, dass die Firmen in Zwickau zusammenhalten. Also wir sind begeistert.
Das war eine ganz tolle Idee. Und das ist eine Brauerei, wo auch ihr mitgespielt habt.
Und ich muss sagen, den Platz haben wir da. Der Platz ist voll hier.
Was will man eigentlich mehr?
Das ist eine Veranstaltung von Zwickau für Zwickau.
Zwickau für Zwickau. Was will man eigentlich mehr als 19, nein, 20 junge Frauen zu sehen, wie sie in einen Trabi steigen? Und jetzt kommt dann noch diese Frage, die am Ende so aufgemacht wird. Wird das noch mal irgendwann getoppt werden? Und dann sagt tatsächlich die Moderatorin, man weiß es nicht, denn Wunder gibt es immer wieder. Und die Abmoderation jetzt wie folgt.
Es war eine tolle Aktion am gestrigen Nachmittag, die gezeigt hat, was es hier für tolle Menschen gibt, die zusammenstehen.
Die zusammenstehen. Also die stehen natürlich nicht zusammen gegen Rassismus auf. Die stehen nicht zusammen, wenn es darum geht, jetzt eine grüne autofreie Stadt zu machen. Die stehen überhaupt nicht zusammen, sondern sie versammeln sich da irgendwie, weil sie nicht wissen, was sie machen sollen. Und das Fernsehprogramm ist sonntagnachmittag eher schlecht. Und gucken, ob diese Damen in den Trabi passen. Es ist schlimm.
Also...
Das ist Ideologie.
Das ist nicht mehr... Es ist ein bisschen so, und da muss ich immer aufpassen, aber ich sage es jetzt trotzdem genau, wie ich es denke, weil ich weiß, da gibt es auch Widersprüche und Widerstände. Und die müsste man dann auch ausdiskutieren. Aber wir haben ja häufiger hier auf Rentenrepublik Bezug genommen. Wir haben über Migration gesprochen und haben festgestellt, die Binnenmigration in den Ländern ist noch viel wichtiger als diese internationale Flüchtlinge usw. Und wir haben in Deutschland dieses Phänomen der Urbanisierung. So sehr, dass Olaf Scholz bei seiner letzten Rede als Finanzminister wissend, er wird jetzt Kanzler im Bundestag, steht und sagt, und seht ihr, die Renten sind sicher. Die Demografen haben sich schon in den 90ern geirrt, als in Berlin alle Häuser verkauft wurden, privatisiert für ein Apfel und ein Ei usw. Und sie sollten sich mal jetzt entschuldigen, weil jetzt liegen sie auch wieder falsch. Und ich denke mir so, ne, die liegen nicht falsch. Es sind ganz klare Tendenzen. Wir haben jetzt seit 2014 ein zurückgehender Lebenserwartung. Wir haben seit 40 Jahren ein Ausbleiben von Geburten überhalb des Wachstums, fadest von 2, 1 Kindern pro Frau in Deutschland. Wir liegen bei 1, 4, 1, 6 in guten Jahren. Und das Einzige, was Olaf Scholz dazu hätte bringen können und er wusste als Arbeitsminister und Finanzminister, wie die Zahlen eigentlich sind, das war reiner medialer Wahlkampf, wir haben halt die Urbanisierung, die alles übertüncht. Also wir haben ein Wachstum in den Städten, das nur durch Corona, nach 30 Jahren Aufstieg, so eine kurze Delle, und wir sehen jetzt schon wieder, dass es nach oben geht. Und diese Entmenschung der Fläche, die wir jetzt im Wahlergebnis immer wieder sehen in Sachsen. Selbst in Sachsen sind ja in Leipzig und Dresden noch schwarze und grüne Direktmandate und rote gewonnen worden. Nur in der Fläche hast du halt flächendeckend AfD, die da mit 25, 30 Prozent drin ist. Und dann habe ich mir das Wahlergebnis hier in Frankfurt angeguckt. In meinem Wahlkreis liegen die Grünen in den Zweitstimmen bei 25 Prozent und in den Erststimmen bei 29 Prozent. Das als bundesweiter Trend würde noch CDU und SPD überflügeln. Dann hast du Wahlkreise in der Fläche, wo die Grünen mal so 2 Prozent, 2, 3 Prozent, mal 3, irgendwas Prozent, aber nie über die 5 Prozent hörte. Und hier hat man jetzt auch wieder so einen alten Menschen-Schauen zu, was junge Menschen machen. Und ich würde wirklich sagen, mittlerweile haben wir Deutschland aufgeteilt nicht nur in Stadt und Land, sondern in Zukunft und Vergangenheit. Die urbanen Zentren leben einfach ein bisschen in der Zukunft. Diese ganze Klima-Thematisierung, diese Idee, wir sollten uns nicht das Auto abschaffen. Es hängt natürlich sehr viel mit kurzen Wegen. Was ist das Angebot in den Restaurants? Ja, in Frankfurt kriegt man natürlich sein Döner mit Vollkornbrot. Das wäre überhaupt nicht möglich, ja, irgendwo anders. Da kriegst du halt dein normales Fladenbrot, wie es halt so ist. Und das, was man in Frankfurt, in Stuttgart, in Nürnberg, selbst in Dresden, in Berlin lebt, ist einfach das Leben der Zukunft. Und in der Fläche lebt man das Leben der Vergangenheit. Und es sieht man an solchen Zwicker-Clips, dass da glaube ich nochmal viele auch aus den Dörfern reinfahren, um sich so ein Spektakel anzugucken. Dann mal wieder mehr als 100 Menschen bei einem Ereignis, also die für ein Ereignis da sind, die nicht nur aneinander vorbeilaufen, weil sie im Alltag nachgehen und so weiter. Und das sind einfach krasse, krasse demografische Unterschiede, die sich mittlerweile so manifestieren.
Obwohl ich mir manchmal nicht sicher bin, inwieweit unsere Stadtbetrachtung stimmt. Denn wenn ich mich an Städten aufhalte, dann ist das an kulturellen Orten oder an Orten, wo man sich geschäftlich trifft. Aber ich sehe ja nicht so dieses normale Berlin in der Regel. Das habe ich aber vor ein paar Wochen mal gehabt, als ich dort war. Und dann ist was ausgefallen. Und ich bin sonntags den Kuhdamm entlang gegangen. Und dann war da auch so ein Straßenfest irgendwas. Da wurde auch ein bisschen Tango getanzt oder was. Und da habe ich eigentlich die, die da in Zwickau standen, auch alle gesehen. Also es gibt natürlich auch in den Großstädten Leute, die zur Alten Republik gehören oder die total etagesch sind. Und die auch eigentlich nur die Tage da in irgendeiner drittklassigen Shopping-Mall vor der Tür, vor dem Eduscho-Café oder so verbringen. Also es ist ja keineswegs so, dass das alles Leute sind, die mit Tageszeitungen bewaffnet durch die Straßen spazieren und am politischen oder kulturellen Diskurs teilnehmen. Sondern ich glaube, dass das nur nicht so auffällt in der Großstadt, dass wir die aber auch so haben. Die gehen ja auch dann nicht ins Programmkino und die gehen auch nicht ins Konzert, sondern die sitzen auch einfach da und lesen die Bildzeitung oder sagen, ach, da ist aber wieder was Schönes, da wird eine Hüpfburg aufgeblasen.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher. Denn vergleich das nochmal mit wirklich Dorfleben in der Sächsischen Schweiz, wo du keine Infrastruktur mehr hast im 10 km Umkreis. Wo du immer irgendwo hin immer planen musst, Arztbesuche, monatelang muss das alles geplant werden. Wo ein Bankautomat auf Rädern vorbeigefahren kommt einmal die Woche. Selbst als ärmste Maus in Berlin hast du Zugriffe auf andere Infrastruktur und anderes erleben, einfach wenn du die Straßen langläufst, weil da einfach was anderes los ist. Ich habe das jetzt erst wieder in Gesprächen aufgefallen. Selbst aus Leipzig fährt man abends gegen 20 Uhr im Grunde einer toten Stadt ab. Da kommt dann noch einmal pro Stunde in ICE reingefahren, auf Gleis 2, die anderen Gleise sind verwaist. Der Bahnhof hat zu, alle Läden haben geschlossen. Man fährt dann vier Stunden nach Frankfurt am Main und steigt dann nach Mitternacht hier aus. Weil gerade irgendwer irgendwas feiert, wird halt ein Spanferkel in der Haupthalle gemacht des Bahnhofs. Da fällt es einfach auseinander. Berlin ist immer noch eine arme Stadt, aber sehr viele arme Menschen können dann doch mehr Geld mobilisieren für Dienstleistungen, die einfach so entstehen, als weniger arme Menschen auf dem Dorf, für die es sich einfach nicht lohnt, weil da keine Synergien-Effekte und gar nichts da sind. Allein Dichte von Bevölkerung macht da so einen großen Unterschied. Und ja, auch in Berlin gibt es traurige Orte, aber die sind noch mal sehr viel besser als die traurigen Orte in der Sächsischen Schweiz.
Der Traurige ist einfach für mich, Berlin ist immer Potsdamer Platz. Da sind zwar heurere Hotels, aber wenn man da wirklich an einem Sonntag irgendwo sitzt und trinkt einen Kaffee, dann ist das schon sehr, sehr dramatisch. Und da gab es schon irgendwo bei Twitter den Witz, wird Giffey jetzt ganz Berlin in den Potsdamer Platz verwandeln. Ich glaube, das ist so, was ihr vorschwebt, aber man kann nur hoffen, dass sie da genügend Gegendruck bekommt. Auch so sicherlich das Schlimmste, dass sie da es noch mal geschafft hat.
Unglaublich, ja.
Das ist ja in meinen Augen, ich weiß nicht, ich müsste die Wähler jetzt übelst beleidigen, um dieses Wahlergebnis einzuschätzen. Deswegen lasse ich das. Und wir schauen uns an, was die Leute sonst noch so interessiert. Und du kanntest das Phänomen, und ich weiß, ich eben gerade gefragt habe, Gabby Petito, du hast das überhaupt nicht mitbekommen, was da los ist. Dann will ich das kurz einleiten, weil das vielleicht viele dann nicht mitbekommen haben.
Aber ich hatte auch den Tiger King damals nicht.
Ein ganz verrücktes Phänomen. Also, Gabby Petito ist eine junge Frau gewesen, die mit ihrem Freund mit so einem Van durch die USA gereist ist. Und sie hat dann Insta-Stories gemacht. Der Freund hat auch ein Insta-Profil. Und sie hatten, glaube ich, so diese Idee, Reiseinfluencer zu werden. Das war erst noch sehr klein. Also, sie hatte dann irgendwann 12.000 Follower. Das war jetzt nicht alles so der Rede wert, wie groß das da war. Aber immerhin hat sie es doch geschafft, da ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit zu generieren. Na ja, gut. Und ich glaube, die Idee war auch, sich irgendwann so ein bisschen selbstständig zu machen. Nun ist Folgendes passiert. Die sind also jetzt gereist, gereist. Und eigentlich sollte diese Reise auch noch länger gehen. Und dann irgendwann kamen keine Post mehr oder merkwürdige Posts. Und dann wussten die Eltern von Gabby nicht mehr, was ist da eigentlich los? Warum meldet sich die Tochter nicht? Dann kam eine Nachricht, ja, keinen Empfang und so. Und dann kam der Freund zurück von dieser Reise, aber sie nicht. Dann ist ein Bodycam-Video veröffentlicht worden von der Polizei. Da hatte jemand dieses Paar gesehen, hat gesehen, die waren im Streit. Die haben sich da geschlagen. Eher wohl sie, wie der Zeuge berichtete. Und daraufhin hat die Polizei dann die angehalten, hat mit denen gesprochen. Sie wirkt sehr verstört. Man kann das im Internet sehen. Das haben Millionen Menschen sich angesehen. Man weiß nicht, was ist mit ihr. Inzwischen hat man sie gefunden. Sie ist tot. Und der Freund aber ist jetzt flüchtig, weil man ihn zwar verdächtigt hatte, aber er hat dann doch irgendwie den Eindruck vermittelt, dass er es nicht direkt war. Jedenfalls ist er jetzt flüchtig. Also das Netz sucht jetzt diesen Verdächtigen, der sich auch dadurch verdächtig gemacht hat, dass er nicht mehr mit der Polizei sprechen wollte, sich gleich einen Anwalt nahm. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt so einen Live-True-Crime-Fall. Und wir haben Instagram-Profile der beiden, die auch noch immer da sind, die man sich ansehen kann und wie man auch analysieren kann, was haben die da gemacht, plus weitere Informationen, die über die sozialen Netzwerke verbreitet wurden.
Aber er postet jetzt auch nichts mehr.
Er postet auch nichts mehr, er ist irgendwo. Und jetzt wird das ein großes mediales Phänomen. Es gibt, wenn man das bei YouTube eingibt, ich weiß nicht, hunderte Sendungen bereits da, von Fox News bis sonst wohin. Also alles berichtet darüber. Es gibt viele Podcasts, die sich dem Thema angenommen haben. Wir hören jetzt da auch gleich in was rein. Und natürlich auch der berühmte Kopfgeldjäger, Doc, den man kennt mit den langen Haaren, mit den blonden, weißen, langen Haaren. Der meldet sich jetzt auch sofort, und er nimmt das jetzt mal selbst in die Hand, denn der hat da so seine Theorie.
Die FBI hat ultraviolettes Lichttracking. Also ich bin mir sicher, dass sie das mit Drogen zu verbrücken. Nicht mit allem verbrücken, was er mit dem er sich mit dem er sich mit dem er sich mit dem er sich mit dem er sich mit dem So jetzt wird spekuliert, wo ist er?
Es ist jetzt schon Modus Fernseh Serie. Man kann das dann auch sehen bei YouTube. Dann geht dann dort zu dem Haus der Eltern dieses jungen Manns. Klopft da mal energisch an, will mal mit jemanden sprechen.
Aber ist das noch auf eigene Faust oder ist das schon mit Kopfgeld?
Das ist noch auf eigene Faust. Er hat wohl seine Sendung verloren. Also die ist jetzt abgesetzt worden. Und jetzt kann er sich also quasi in den sozialen Medien auch nochmal ganz neu hervortun mit einem solchen Fall. Das ist also auch etwas, was man sehr gut monetarisieren kann. Und jetzt beschreibt er auch mal in seiner ganzen Staatsskepsis, welche Schritte er gehen kann, die andere nicht so gehen können.
Diese Person wird uns anrufen.
Das ist anonym.
Das ist das Beste, was er tut. Ich denke nicht, dass er in der Stadt shopliften kann, und in den Runden sein, und im Schlaf in den Cheap Hotels.
Das ist ja jetzt noch das traditionelle Fernsehen, was jetzt durch ihn vertreten wird. Und er versucht jetzt da nochmal auf anderen Kanälen für sich auch Werbung zu machen.
Aber das triggert auch so diesen, also sagen wir so, der Prototyp ist immer Landlust. Menschen leben in der Stadt und blättern dann durch so eine Zeitung, wo alles grün ist und blüht. Und im Grunde, er hat ja mit dem Bild schon gearbeitet an den Schwarzenegger. Wie heißen diese Filme, da wo er vor den Außerirdischen flüchtet und sich dann eben um deren Infrarotblicken zu entgehen, mit diesem Schlamm einschmiert, um dann eben nicht als 37 Grad warm aufspürbar, sondern und so. Und das ist, das triggert schon die richtigen Dinge. Also hier sieht man auch, er hat gut analysiert, warum seine Fernsehserie gut funktioniert hat und macht die jetzt einfach auf eigene Faust so weiter.
Ganz genau. Und wir haben ja immer mal wieder solche Fälle, bei denen meistens weibliche junge Opfer oder Kinder in irgendeiner Weise entführt werden oder dann nicht gefunden werden oder tot aufgefunden werden, dass dann entsprechende Täter gesucht werden. Und es ist ja erstaunlich, dass so viel Aufmerksamkeit immer wieder binden kann, denn man könnte ja jetzt auch gerade, wo wir uns viel mit Todesraten und so weiter beschäftigen, sagen, ja, es sind tragische Fälle. Wir brauchen eine gute Polizei, gute Ermittler, die das recherchieren. Aber das ist ja nichts, was einen jetzt selbst betroffen macht. Also ich habe das immer mit großem Erstaunen gesehen, was so auf diesen Boulevardseiten steht oder was dann noch zum Teil in den politischen Teil rückt, dass Menschen sich damit auseinandersetzen. Wie wird das jetzt wohl sein? Was ist da vorgefallen zwischen diesem Paar? Gab es da einen Konflikt und deshalb ist das eskaliert? Oder gibt es noch jemand ganz anders, der da aufgetaucht ist und der sie ermordet hat, was auch immer? Das sind ja Fragen, die ich mir nicht stelle, sondern man hätte sie mir schon in einem spannenden Krimi verpackt.
Ja, also die mediale Attraktivität von solchen Fällen ist vorbereitet und das wird nicht im amerikanischen Diskurs, aber im skandinavischen gerade aufgearbeitet, weil man hat ja auch in Skandinavien diese Mankell und so weiter etwas super düsteren Krimis. Und da ist aufgefallen, dass das weibliche Opfer immer extrem stilisiert wurde, sodass der Fernsehzuschauer im Kunde draufsieht und sieht, ah, eine super geschminkte blonde Frau im kurzen Rock liegt tot da. Alle Register gezogen, muss nicht weiter erklärt werden, bis hin zu, na das ist ja ein bisschen selber schuld. Kein Wunder, dass die Männer da irgendwie draufgesprungen sind. Und man versucht da jetzt auch mehr Realismus, um davon wegzukommen, dieses Stereotyp so zu bedienen. Und hier sieht man aber, wie so eine jahrzehntelange Vorgeschichte, die Frau ist ein Opfer, Beziehungsdrama, sexualisierte Gewalt und dann will man das alles aufarbeitet sehen und interessiert sich im Grunde für die Nuancen, wie sich diese Geschichte von anderen unterscheidet, aber man ist auf demselben Pfad, so die ganze Zeit. Und es wäre nicht überraschend, da das ein echter Fall ist, dass man am Ende, je nachdem, wie lange sowas dann dauert, bis es aufgearbeitet ist, aber dann doch zu anderen Schlüssen kommt und es dann doch nicht passt. Aber solange man hier noch auf der Suche ist, kann man die alle noch bedienen, diese Idealtypen.
Ja, du hast eigentlich schon das Richtige angesprochen. Es geht sogar noch weiter zurück. Da müssen wir nicht nur an die Skandinavien-Krimis denken, sondern es gibt den Topos der schönen Leiche, Ophelia, zum Beispiel schon in Hamlet. Es gibt von Elisabeth Bronfen ein Buch, das heißt Die Schöne Leiche, wie Frauen dargestellt werden und dann, wie auch dann dieser Schluss kommt. Also nur, das ist jetzt eine Zuspitzung, dass dann sozusagen die tote Frau die absolut domestizierte Frau ist. Richtig. Dadurch, also nur eine tote Frau ist eine gute Frau, wie Cizek dann sagen würde bei seiner Vertigo-Analyse. Und bei Vertigo haben wir ja eigentlich auch einen Mann, der eine Tote jagt, also das Bild von einer Toten. Sie lebt nicht mehr, aber er ist in das Bild der Toten verliebt. Und jagt ihm nach. Das heißt also, es hat eine sehr große Tradition. Und diese Darstellung, die ist interessant. Also wir haben es hier auch mit einer plonten, jungen, schönen Frau zu tun. Und das ist ein Phänomen, das jetzt allerdings auch kritisiert wird in den US-Medien. Wir hören hier was von MSNBC.
Nun, die Antwort hat eigentlich einen Namen.
Missing White Woman Syndrome.
Ja, das zu thematisieren passt genau an die Zeit und ist auch absolut notwendig.
Ja, es wurde auch in einigen Podcastern darüber gesprochen, habe ich gehört, wir haben im vergangenen Jahr alle über George Floyd gesprochen und haben aber nicht einfach nur das Opfer gesehen, sondern haben es geschafft, das auch zu politisieren. Das in einen strukturellen Kontext von Rassismus zu stellen. Und hier haben wir jetzt wieder sowas, was uns den Konsum ganz leicht macht. Das ist ja eigentlich die einzige Haltung, die dazu einzunehmen ist. Und komplexer wird es auch nicht. Und komplizierter eigentlich auch nicht. Und jetzt hören wir mal hier nochmal weiter. MSNBC.
Daniel Robinson ist ein junger schwarzer Mann.
Sein Vater hat einen privaten Investigator verheiratet, um ihn zu finden. Er ist ein vermischtes Teil eines Arm.
Und sein Fall hat mich verknüpft, weil es sehr ähnlich ist.
Ich habe es nie gehört, bis mir dieser Freund meines vorgegeben hat.
Weil wir, wenn es um verwundete Menschen, Männer, Frauen und Kinder geht, unsere Fälle nicht ernst nehmen.
Aber vielleicht ist dieser Daniel Robinson, und das meine ich jetzt so sarkastisch wie es ist und sarkastisch nicht bezogen auf den Fall, sondern auf die Aufmerksamkeit, die dem gewidmet wird, bzw. auf das Publikum, vielleicht ist der nicht Instagramable. Und wenn wir mal uns das ansehen, am 11. September wird sie dann als vermisst gemeldet, diese Gabby Petito. Da hat sie 13.000 Follower bei Instagram. Und einen Tag, nachdem ihr Leichnam gefunden wurde, hatte sie dann 200.000 mehr. Und insgesamt hat sie jetzt 1, 2 Millionen Follower bei Instagram. Also sie ist jetzt quasi eine tote Influencerin. Und es werden immer mehr. Und am 19. September wurde also diese Leiche gefunden. Und worauf auch hingewiesen wird bei CBS ist, dass ja ganz viele Menschen vermisst werden. Aber die sind dann nicht zum Beispiel weiß.
Und eine große Mehrheit davon sind Kinder.
Auch interessant, dass Indigene vermisst werden.
Wir haben zum einen schockierend aus Kanada diese Aufarbeitung, was in diesen Schulen für die Indigenen abging. Dass da bis in die Jetzt-Zeit hinein immer Kinder verschwanden. Dann hat man jetzt diese Friedhöfe gefunden und hat sich aber vorher gar nicht dafür interessiert. Wo dann auch Trudeau von der Kirche mal eine Entschuldigung eingefordert hat und dann alle drauf kamen. Dann hat sich die Regierung dafür entschuldigt, weil so einseitig kann man es ja auch nicht sehen. Und es gibt, ich weiß nicht, ob du die kennst, Mindhunters, die Serie. Das spielt ja vor 40, 50 oder 40 Jahren, in den 70ern, als die beim FBI gerade entdecken, dass die psychologischen Konstitutionen von Tätern auch eine Rolle spielen könnten und dann kommen sie drauf, ah, es gibt jetzt gar nicht nur Mord aus den Ursprungsansinnen des Kapitalverbrechens, sondern einfach aus Mordlust heraus und die entdecken dann dieses Phänomen des Serienmords. Und die erste Staffel handelt ja nur von diesen weißen Tätern, die dann einfach im Gefängnis interviewt werden, um dann nachträglich, nachdem die schon erfolgreich verurteilt sind, mal herauszufinden, was denn da eigentlich vor sich geht in deren Köpfen. Und die zweite Staffel handelt ja dann nicht von den weißen Tätern im Gefängnis, sondern von den schwarzen Opfern außerhalb. Und da wird ja dieses Muster aufgearbeitet, dass sehr viele schwarze Frauen und Kinder einfach verschwunden sind, auch unter der Maxime, dass sich für die ja niemand interessiert. Also es war sozusagen Trainingsmilieu für weiße Massenmörder. Und dieser spielt ja dann die ganze Zeit damit, dass die Frauen die Polizeiarbeit gar nicht akzeptieren, weil da kommen natürlich dann diese Profiler und wollen die ganze Zeit Gespräche führen mit den Angehörigen der Opfer usw. Und die sagen, was wollt ihr mit uns, wieso interessiert ihr euch für uns? Und für die ist es so völlig der Kulturschock, dass plötzlich die weißen Fats, die weißen Federal Agents, da irgendwie kommen und sich halt für die interessieren. Und da kann man das mal gut nachvollziehen. Also da ist wunderbar aufgearbeitet, was das eigentlich für ein Problem ist, was sich bis heute zieht.
Auch bei Polizeiamittlungen, da sagte dann auch ein Vater von einem vermissten schwarzen Jungen, naja, wenn man dann halt anruft und der Polizei sagt, der Sohn wird vermisst und die hören dann, der ist schwarze Sohn, dann setzen die sich nicht sofort in Bewegung. Wenn man sagt, das ist eine junge weiße Frau, dann ist natürlich alles alarmiert und sofort ist auch die Regionalpresse oder sogar darüber hinaus interessiert an dem Fall. Und so unterscheidet sich dann auch die Berichterstattung. Wir haben jetzt gerade schon die schöne Leiche angesprochen und das wird hier bei CBS auch mal verhandelt, wie eigentlich über diese Fälle berichtet wird. Also da kreiert man nicht die schöne Leiche, sondern sagt, so schlimm wurde der Körper zugerichtet. Und dann wird das aber noch mit verknüpft. Kommt aus finanziell schwachem Hause und elterndrogenabhängigem, was weiß ich.
Also kennen wir in Deutschland unter den Dönermorden. Die türkische Opfer, na klar, die haben doch immer diese Familienstreitigkeiten und so. Dann wird das halt in diesem Milieu verortet, Täter und Opfer. Damit so halb erklärt, das Interesse sinkt, sowohl der Ermittler als auch der Öffentlichkeit. Und dann hast du halt diesen Stempel drauf. Das ist genau das gleiche Modell.
Nun wollen wir uns mal ein bisschen mit True Crime auseinandersetzen. Das ist ja ein Genre, das ich überhaupt noch nie konsumiert habe. Nur jetzt eigentlich für diesen Podcast. Mal dachte ich, jetzt muss man es doch mal hören. Was passierte eigentlich so? Aber ich will erst mal einen Schritt noch zurückgehen. Wir sind ja in den Neuen Zwanziger. In den Alten Zwanziger waren Serienmörder ein ganz, ganz beliebtes Thema der Literatur des Films. Man hatte diese Lustmörder, die Frauenmörder, die Mädchenmörder. Man hatte aber auch dann historische Fälle von Männern, die im schwulen Strichermilieu sich ihre Opfer suchten. Also da konnte man große Schauergeschichten erzählen. Die Presse hat das auch alles aufgegriffen. Und dann nach den Zwanzigern, 31, kommt dann Fritz Lang und greift eigentlich genau diese Stimmung noch mal auf und versucht das dann noch zu verquicken mit medialen Diskursen in dem berühmten Film M. Eine Stadt sucht einen Mörder. Hast du den schon mal gesehen? Du musst dir den ansehen. Es ist so ein hochmoderner, großartiger Film. Na ja, 31 ist natürlich schwarz-weiß. Aber es ist ein Meisterwerk. Also man muss ihn gesehen haben. Und wir hören uns jetzt was an, um auch diese Emotionalisierung ein bisschen nachzuvollziehen. Dieser M, dieser Mörder, der wird nämlich dann geschnappt. Und zwar von Verbrechern. Es ist nämlich so, dass die Polizei zwar ermittelt, aber nicht so recht vorankommt. Und das behindert aber die Arbeit der üblichen Ganoven und Verbrecher, weil die ja ständig irgendwelche Razzien durchziehen. Und dann können die Prostituierten nicht arbeiten, die Schmuggler können nicht arbeiten. Und so versuchen sich dann alle in der Unterwelt zu vernetzen. Und das sollte man wirklich so auch im Sinne von Digitalisierung sehen. Und jagen dann diesen Mörder. Die Bettler spielen eine ganz entscheidende Rolle. Denn sie sind überall positioniert und sollen alles beobachten und geben das dann ganz schnell weiter, wenn irgendwas gesehen wurde. Also die haben hier eigentlich schon so ein Geo-Tracking, das stattfindet, was jetzt auch in diesem Fall mit Gabby Petito wieder eine große Rolle spielt. Weil man sagt, aber die war doch dann da und jetzt soll angeblich das Handy irgendwo in Mexiko sein. Aber wie ist es da hingekommen? Also durch diese Vernetzung haben wir natürlich das. Das ist hier noch auf analoge Weise. Und dann gibt es auch einen Schauprozess quasi. Dieser Mörder wird nämlich dann den Verbrechern vorgeführt und man will dann über ihn richten. Und es gibt dann einmal noch von einem Anwalt ein Plädoyer, ob er dann vielleicht gar nicht anders konnte, weil er psychisch krank ist. Er sagt dann auch immer, Peter Lorre spielt das ganz großartig, will nicht, muss, will nicht, muss. Und dann erhebt sich aber jemand, und da sehen wir wirklich, wie Boulevard-Medien funktionieren. Dann erhebt sich von diesen Ganoven, von den Prostituierten jemand aus dem Publikum und sagt folgendes.
Du hast keine Kinder gehabt, nicht? Na also, da hast du aber noch kein Kind verloren. Wenn du aber wissen willst, wie das ist, wenn einem so ein Kindchen genommen wird. Denf war mal der Eltern, dem der da ihre Kinder genommen hat. Die Phrase war nach den Tagen und Nächten, wo sie nicht wussten, was los war. Die Frau hat Recht, aufzurechten.
Ja, wir sehen hier eine moderne Herzjagd, die jetzt selbstverständlich auch im Internet immer wieder losgetreten wird bei solchen Fällen, dass man Verdächtige hat und die aber auch schon vorverurteilt hat. Also hier haben wir nicht nur einen Verdächtigen, sondern hier haben wir einen Mörder, aber dass man glaubt, man kann jetzt mit sehr viel Emotionen die Sache lösen und das ist auch eine große Gefahr, die jetzt glaube ich bei diesen True Crime Podcasts entsteht, weil die eigentlich auch immer wieder dazu aufrufen, so mit zu recherchieren. Also es gibt ja auch bei diesen True Crime Podcasts Fälle, die nicht geklärt sind und dann versucht man jetzt plötzlich dann auf eigene Faust irgendwas rauszufinden. Und wir hören jetzt mal so ein paar Clips aus dem Podcast Mord auf Ex, der wohl sehr, sehr groß ist. Die beiden Damen gehen auch auf Tour mit dem Podcast und so. Also es ist ein großes Ding, ist offenbar sehr beliebt. Und die setzen sich jetzt auch mit dem Fall Gabby Petito auseinander.
Aber ich fand es so schwierig, kann ich jetzt schon sagen, weil das ist so ein Fall, da ist ja im Moment noch voll viel los. Es sind voll viele Ermittlungen los. Und mein Detektivherz hat halt versucht, so viel rauszufinden. Und wir haben ja wirklich die ganze Woche irgendwie deren Instagram-Kanäle gestalkt, wie verrückt. Und ich wäre am liebsten, also ich habe echt kurz überlegt, buchen wir uns ein Flugticket. Ja, das sind so Fälle, da hat man das Bedürfnis, irgendwie noch was mitzumachen und rauszufinden.
Ja, kleiner Exkurs, aber vielleicht verständlich. Diese Amazon-Regeln für Filme, dass man jetzt Schule nur noch von Schwulen spielen lässt und so weiter, bringt ja, also das Ansinnen scheint ja so ein Authentizitätsding zu sein. Dass man sich hier eigentlich nicht mehr auf Augenhöhe mit dem Publikum sieht, dass irgendwo so ein Quäntchen Realität drin haben will und lieber akzeptiert, dass ein echter Wahlkampf in ein mediales Drama mündet, als dass ein mediales Drama nichts mit irgendwas in der Realität zu tun hat. Also man nimmt lieber sowas wie Trump in Kauf. Der Hauptsache, es steckt ein wahrer Kern hinter dem medialen Ereignis. Und das scheint es hier auch zu sein, dass man so als Podcast einfach hier auch nochmal dem Publikum, es ist ja auch dieser Ansprachenspublikum, also wenn ihr hier dran bleibt, besteht echt die Möglichkeit, dass wir für euch ein Flugticket buchen und noch näher dran sind. Und ich weiß nicht, dass, also mich schreckert das ja gar nicht, überhaupt gar nicht. Gerade du auch so als der Film, das artificielle des Films, Schauspieler, ja, muss sein, aber eigentlich geht es um alles.
Mich stört schon diese Händenblendung nach einer wahren Begebenheit. Das ist für mich schon uninteressant, da man doch weiß, wie Drehbücher entstehen, da man weiß, wie Geschichten aus dem eigenen Leben verlaufen. Und die sind nie 90 Minuten lang. Und die haben auch nicht diese dramaturgische Zuspitzung, sondern alles kommt danach. Alles kommt, wenn man wo war und das erzählt. Also ich kann dir jetzt irgendwie meine Berlinerlebnisse erzählen, aber ich würde sie natürlich nicht so erzählen, wie ich sie erlebt habe, sondern würde sie dramaturgisch so verarbeiten, dass sie für dich interessant sind und mir Freude machen zu erzählen. Und damit sind wir schon losgelöst von dem eigentlich Erlebten und dieser Idee der Nahbarkeit auch. Wenn ich da jetzt irgendwo in Wyoming rumtappe und überlege, ja hier könnte sie gelegen haben oder was?
Ja und jetzt, wo wir so drüber reden, fällt mir auf, wie weitreichend eigentlich dieses fair, wie soll man sagen, dieser Partizipationszirkus, wie ihn Dietmar Daert genannt hat. Dadurch, dass wir alle ein Handy haben mit einer Kamera, können wir alle irgendwie mitmachen. Also warum macht man eigentlich nicht mehr mit und so? Und dann solche politischen Diskussionen, wie auch in Deutschland, dass wir von einer Kanzlerkandidatin ein Buch bekommen, wo Erlebnisse aus Afrika drinstehen, die aber dann wohl nicht ihrer eigenen sind, sondern wo sie Textstellen geklaut hat von anderen Erlebnissen. So, dass wir das so ernst nehmen und so als so ein großes Problem ansehen, wenn Formulierungen der Nacherzählung sozusagen zu weit entrückt sind von der Realität, die uns dargeboten werden soll, so als gäbe es diesen Brückenschlag und das haben wir ja sehr übel genommen und auch nicht verziehen und es scheint sich hier wie so ein roter Faden mittlerweile diese ganze Medienlandschaft zu ziehen.
Bei Mord auf X wird jetzt ein bisschen geschildert, wie dieses Instagram-Paar sich dargestellt hat.
Weil es geht um zwei junge Menschen, die nach außen eine Social Media Präsenz hatten, wo du dachtest, oh Gott, das ist das Traumleben, das will ich auch haben. Ich meine, falls ihr es noch nicht gemacht habt, die beiden sind immer noch auf Instagram aktiv. Also ihre Profile kann man noch sehen. Und mir war nicht klar, wie nahbar sie eigentlich sind. Also sie haben ganz viele Stories. Sie haben Stories aus verschiedenen Bundesstaaten, wo sie reisen waren. Sie zeigen ihre Körper, die Umgebung. Das ist auch zum Beispiel der Grund, warum sich gerade so viele Menschen für diesen Fall interessieren und er überall besprochen wird, weil es so nahbar ist. Also so direkt auf deinem Handy zugänglich, das Leben der beiden. Ja, du kannst alles sehen. Du kannst sehen, wie die rumgereist sind. Das wirkt alles mega schön. Das führt natürlich auch dazu, dass wir ganz viele Informationen haben, die wir uns genauer angucken können. Und deswegen, liebe Exis, holt mal eure Notizblöcke raus. Wir werden heute versuchen, rauszufinden, was mit Gabby Petito passiert ist.
Ich finde das so, wie soll man sagen, da steckt so ein Vorjurismus dahinter und so überhaupt. Aber das ist ein ganz einfaches Vorwurf erst mal. Wir haben ja alle bei Social Media das Problem des Doomscrollings. Wir wissen nicht, wo hört es auf. Denn nahbar sind fast alle Instagram-Accounts. Das ist ja das Prinzip. Nur diese Instagram-Accounts, die wir üblicherweise haben, denen fehlt halt das besondere Salz, weil wir sehen, für den interessiert sich keiner. Warum sollte ich mich dafür interessieren? Das ist jetzt hier anders. Sehr viele Leute interessieren sich dafür. Und, und das ist vielleicht noch wichtiger, diese Geschichte ist auserzählt. Sie ist zu Ende. Es ist jetzt Geschichte. Also man guckt nicht, was postet sie morgen, weil das Prinzip ist ja, sie ist vorbei, sie ist tot. Wir wissen aber noch, wir kennen aber das Ende noch nicht. Und jetzt versuchen alle, und das ist so Colombo-Style, wo der Zuschauer immer am Anfang schon gesehen hat, wie es zu Ende geht. Und nur noch die Frage ist, aber wie beobachtet er, wie kriegt er raus, was wir schon wissen? Und dann geht man so mit ihm mit. Und jetzt interessieren wir uns nur die Frage, wie endet denn die Geschichte? Wir wissen erst mal, nur sie ist zu Ende. Und können wir aus dem Verlauf der Geschichte, die wir so nahebar dargelegt bekommen, Rückschlüsse daraus ziehen, wie es zu Ende ging? Würde mich nicht wundern, wenn es jetzt so Fan-Fiction-mäßig...
Es war nicht so schnell, nicht so voreilig. Wir haben jetzt noch Fan-Fiction gleich. Erst mal noch mal Beispiele. Diese Internet-Detektivarbeit scheint jetzt so was ganz Häufiges zu sein in diesen True Crime Podcasts, also auch im amerikanischen Bereich, dass dann dazu aufgerufen wird, jetzt gibt es hier einen tollen Fall. Und da haben wir das jetzt gerade. Und dann wird nicht nur gegoogelt, sondern dann werden alle Profile links gedreht und noch mal geschaut, was können wir alles in Erfahrung bringen. Also es ist so eine Hobby-Polizei, die sich da jetzt entwickelt. Also wir haben auf der einen Seite in irgendwelchen Rechtenstädten so eigene Bürgerwehren, die sich bilden und dann glauben, sie müssten damit Law and Order sich durchsetzen. Und hier haben wir so Hobby-Ermittler, die jetzt anfangen.
Es kann im Internet auch schnell zu Vorverurteilungen kommen und zu falschen Beschuldigungen. Und ja, wir halten Brian auch für sehr verdächtig. Aber man muss trotzdem noch sagen, er ist jetzt nicht offiziell verurteilt und die Polizei hat ihn noch nicht mal befragt. Deswegen muss man dort ein bisschen aufpassen, was nämlich passieren kann, wenn das Internet sich so mit Beschuldigungen überschlägt. Hat man zum Beispiel gesehen beim Attentat auf den Boston Marathon. Dort hat sich auch danach so eine Internet-Community gebildet und die haben auch einen Mann immer wieder beschuldigt. Dieser Mann war unschuldig, wurde aber wenige Tage später tot aufgefunden. Da hat am Ende wirklich so eine Vorverurteilung heizend tot von jemandem geführt.
Ja, Frau Podcasterinnen, die Unschuldsvermutung ist ein rein juristisches Konzept und es macht sehr viel kognitive Mühe, das durchzuhalten. Das geht in den Medien nicht. Und erst recht nicht in dem Podcast, den man dazu macht.
Genau, wo man auch jetzt alles durchgeht. Nämlich, man schaut sich die Spotify-Liste mal an, denn die ist auch öffentlich. Und was sagen uns eigentlich diese Lieder über die Person? Und da hören wir jetzt mal rein. Also jetzt geht es in die Analyse.
Und Gabby und Brian hatten bzw. haben immer noch eine gemeinsame Spotify-Playlist, welche sich Mountain Tops nennt. Am 1. September werden zu dieser Playlist noch vier Songs hinzugefügt. Wir erinnern uns, an diesen Tag ist Brian mit seinem und Gabby Sven alleine zurück zu seinen Eltern gefahren. Das heißt, wir können jetzt davon ausgehen, dass Brian diese Songs gehört hat, als er auf dem Rückweg nach Hause war, alleine. Und unter diesen Umständen sind die Songs etwas gruselig. Unter anderem wird zu dieser Playlist ein Song hinzugefügt, der sich Woman nennt und von Matt Berry ist. Und ich lese euch jetzt mal einen Ausschnitt aus dem Song vor. Your Woman is your angel, is your left side, is your whole life easily the most beautiful thing in the world. Und unter anderem gibt es einen Song, der heißt The Badger's Wake. Und der spricht darüber, wie ein Dachs unter der Erde sich zerlegt, weil er gestorben ist. Das ist auch ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Ja, das ist doch die Erklärung, warum Menschen im Internet Sachen lesen und sich dann nicht impfen lassen, weil diese Signal-Intelligence einfach so verlockend ist. Ja. Alle Signale, die man bekommt, irgendwie zusammenzubauen, sie als Puzzleteile misszuverstehen. Und dann hat man so ein Panorama geschaffen.
Das ergibt alles Sinn. Alles bekommt dann auch noch irgendeine besondere Schlagsata. Also jede Banalität wird natürlich immer im Ausnahmefall dann als etwas ganz Besonderes angesehen. Und das geht jetzt auch dazu, dass man in die Bildinterpretation geht. Also das machen jetzt die User, dass man jetzt überlegt, was bedeuten jetzt eigentlich diese zuletzt geposteten Fotos? Was wollte Gabby uns eigentlich mitteilen? Und es gibt ja, und da sind wir auch wieder in den Zwanzigerjahren, zwei berühmte Kunsthistoriker, Wissenschaftler. Und zwar ist da Abi Warburg. Der hat 1925 gesagt, der Liebegott steckt im Detail. Also damit meinte er, man muss die Bilder so analysieren, dass man wirklich in den Details erkennt, was die eigentliche große Aussage ist. Und sein Schüler oder Kollege Erwin Panowski ist zu nennen. Der hat ja die Iconografie, Iconologie-Unterscheidung eigentlich in die Forschung reingebracht. Der ist ja dann auch nachher emigriert. Und da gibt es erst mal diese Idee, man kann so eine vor-iconografische Beschreibung machen von Bildern. Also nehmen wir an, wir haben jetzt Maria mit dem Kind als Bild. Und wir würden aber dann erst mal sagen, da ist eine Frau, die ist vielleicht Ende 20 und hat ein Säugling auf dem Arm und hat ein weißes Gewand an und im Hintergrund leuchtet der Mond. Das wäre jetzt so vor-iconografisch. Wenn man dann iconografisch rangeht, dann würde man sagen, ah ja, das ist die Mutter Gottes, das ist Maria, das ist Jesus, Jesus Christus, das ist die Geburt und der Mond steht auch noch für dies und das. Und dann gibt es noch die ikonologische Analyse, die interpretiert das dann noch im Sinne von Zeit und Kontext. Also ist das Bild im 17. Jahrhundert entstanden und will das nicht einfach nur ein Andachtsbild sein, sondern vermittelt der Künstler damit auch noch eine besondere Form von Religiosität, der ist pietistisch, weil Maria das und das anhat oder weil es eine Handbewegung auf dem Foto gibt, auf dem auf dem Gemälde gibt, das für das und das steht. Also da hat man so quasi diesen ideologischen Kontext. Und ähnlich geht man jetzt vor, wenn man diese Fotos sich ansieht. Also man kann auch sagen, gut, wir sehen da, wie so oft bei Instagram, eine junge Frau, die hat einen Kürbis in der Hand, einen kleinen, und ist da fotografiert in so einem Valley, wie sich das oft gestaltet, wenn man durch Amerika reist. Aber hier geht es jetzt auch in die tiefere Interpretation vor allem auch, wie passen Bild und Beschreibung zusammen?
Ich hatte euch ja schon von Gabbys letzten Instagram-Post erzählt. Die Caption war ja wie gesagt Happy Halloween und daneben war ja ein Kürbis und ein Fliegen-Emoji. Wir wissen alle, Halloween ist nicht an diesem Tag, wo das gepostet wurde. Deswegen fragt man sich natürlich so ein bisschen, warum Happy Halloween. Es gibt eine sehr düstere Vermutung von einigen Internet-Detektiven. Und zwar könnte es vielleicht etwas damit zu tun haben, dass die Reise des Pärchens eigentlich am 31. Oktober enden sollte, also an Halloween. Vielleicht wurde das gepostet im Sinne von Happy Halloween, die Reise ist jetzt vorbei. Oder ist sie an einem Ort, der was mit Halloween zu tun hat oder so? Ist ja dieser Fliegen-Emoji auch ein bisschen komisch. Also ich kenne niemanden, der einen Fliegen-Emoji verwendet.
Spielt bei Westworld eine große Rolle. Jonathan Nolan lässt ja die Fliege über die Hosts laufen, die dann nichts winkern und das unterscheidet sich von Menschen. Und ich finde, wenn ein Bild so unter Kontrolle ist, wie Westworld oder die Serie Lost oder was auch immer, bietet es sich total an, sich zu überlegen, was hat sich der Autor dahinter gedacht. Nur wir haben es hier nicht mit einer Autorengeschichte zu tun. Hier wird einfach so getan, als würden wir die ganzen Biografien reduziert auf das, was wir hier sehen. Das wir über Instagram davon sehen, vom Ende her, nämlich des Todes aus, betrachten können. Und es ist sozusagen umgedrehte Psychoanalyse. Nicht die Geburt und dann Mutter und Vater sind der Ursprung von allem, sondern der Tod als Ereignis. Und alles steuert wie so ein schwarzes Loch auf dieses Ereignis zu. Jedes Ereignis ist da zu deuten. Du hast ja gerade die filmanalytischen Theorierarbeiten dazu. Das gibt es auch in der Soziologie. Ulrich Öwermanns Objektive Hermeneutik. Man vertextet und dann sucht man die latente Sinnstruktur und die findet man, indem man den Text in seine Puzzleteile zerlegt und jedes Wort einzeln mit der bewussten Ausblendung, was kommt als nächstes Wort, erst mal auf die Goldwaage legt und sich dann vom nächsten Wort im Satz überraschen lässt, ob es dann passt zu der eigenen latenten Sinnstruktur, die man erarbeitet hat oder nicht. Und das ist alles Blödsinn. Ulrich Oevermann saß bei uns im Bielefeld damals im Seminar und hat das mit uns objektiv, wir haben Leute gemacht und dann fiel so dieser Satz von ihm. Und wisst ihr, das ist wie beim Matterhorn, wenn man am Matterhorn steht, dieser wunderbaren Pyramide. Wenn man genau drauf achtet, jeder kleine Stein, der dort in der Nähe liegt, sieht auch aus wie diese Pyramide. Also eben elementar findet man, also der Teufel steckt im Detail sozusagen, der Gott der Teufel. Und das ist alles Blödsinn, das ist Zeitverschwendung.
Es sei denn, es ist der Künstler dahinter, also der Geniale.
Es sei denn, wir haben den Künstler dahinter.
Was hier eigentlich passiert ist, dass wir, entweder wird hier das Opfer zur Künstlerin gemacht, also dass sie das Foto bewusst so angelegt hat, weil sie noch andere Botschaften transportieren wollte. Ihr wisst, es ist kein Halloween, aber. Und Fliegen-Emoji. Was kann die Fliege noch bedeuten? Ich musste gleich an den Herr der Fliegen denken. Also der Teufel ist der Herr über die Fliegen. Das ist der beste Pupp, also auch das kann man da wunderbar mit reinlesen. Oder man macht den mutmaßlichen Täter, also den Fotografen dieses Fotos und damit Gabbys Freund, zum Künstler, der schon sich dachte, ich habe eigentlich was Schlimmes vor, weil ich will das jetzt auch noch in einen künstlerischen Rahmen ausbringen, was auch eher unwahrscheinlich ist. Und das ist sehr interessant, wie also dieses ikonologische, ikonografische Analysen-Instrument jetzt hier so übernommen wird von der Community, zugleich dann noch verbunden wird mit Detektivarbeit der klassischen Natur bzw. was die Travel-App so hergibt. Darum geht es auch hier.
Es gibt aber auch einige Leute, die jetzt denken, ok, Brian ist gar nicht mehr in Florida, sondern es gibt auch Menschen, die glauben, dass er in Panama sein könnte oder sogar in Puerto Rico, weil Gabby hatte so eine Travel-App auf dem Handy und die zeigt komischerweise an, dass sich Gabby in Puerto Rico befindet. Aber vielleicht befindet sich auch nicht Gabby da, sondern nur ihr Handy mit Brian. Das wäre natürlich auch eine Möglichkeit.
Da sind wir jetzt bei der Fan-Fiction angekommen. Also jetzt wird das schon weitergesprochen, wo kann er sein, wie erzählt man diese Geschichte weiter? Und ich musste sehr stark an diesen ganzen Verschwörungstheorie-Diskurs denken, den wir ja hier oft verhandelt haben. Was passiert da eigentlich? Was sind Leute bereit zu glauben? Man stellt dann jetzt bei Mortal Facts auch noch mal eigene Vermutungen an, ist natürlich da vorsichtiger, als vieles, was in den sozialen Medien passiert. Aber es gibt so einen großen Drang, das auch noch mal einzuordnen. Nach dem, was wir jetzt wissen, können wir sagen.
Was ich krass finde, ich bin mir eigentlich ziemlich sicher, dass Gabby zwischen dem 25. August, also wo sie das letzte Mal ihre Mutter angerufen hat, und dem 26. August, wo Jessica Schulz, Brian alleine im Park gesehen hat, ermordet wurde. Und das würde jetzt bedeuten, dass ihr letzter Instagram-Post, sowie auch die letzte Nachricht von Gabby an ihre Mutter, nicht von ihr selbst stammen würden. Und das finde ich sehr, sehr gruselig.
Ja, das Element hat auch noch gefehlt, das Grusel-Element. Also das Rätsel für die nächste Ausgabe dann.
Ganz genau.
Der Cliffhanger.
Jetzt sind wir schon bei der Fan-Fiction angekommen. Aber es hat uns ja auch ereilt während des Corona-Diskurses, dass die Isotherik zurückgekommen ist. Man sieht das jetzt bei den Impfungen, dass da Leute ganz eigene Theorien entwickeln, wie sich das eigentlich so mit den Körpern und Molekülen und sonst was verhält, wenn man irgendeine Impfung bekommt. Ja, ganz erstaunliche Dinge. Warum dann nicht noch einen Schritt weitergehen und diesen Fall Gabby noch in eine andere Richtung drehen, nämlich dann in die Isotherik, in den Obskurantismus? Und das ist, glaube ich, das, was wir jetzt neu erleben. Also wir haben nicht, ich würde das noch mal ausdrücklich sagen, wir haben nicht das Ende der Religion nur, weil die Leute aus der katholischen Kirche austreten oder so, sondern die Religion kehrt zurück. Und dann passiert zum Beispiel so was hier bei TikTok. Jetzt mal nur ein Clip, man könnte ganz, ganz viele nennen. Da sind jetzt so Medien, also Menschen, die ein Medium sind, die mit Toten sprechen können. Und jetzt hören wir hier mal, ich glaube, sie heißt Magical Katie oder so.
Sie erinnert mich an Gabby Petito.
Und wir dachten, das ist verrückt.
Wir haben es auf dem Schild gesehen, ihr seht, mein Name ist da.
Ja sie. Sie hat da irgendwelche Zeichen auch bekommen. Sie kann auch bei den Ermittlungen helfen. Da ist ein Song gespielt worden. Ich habe da aber an Gabby gedacht. Und das ist ein unglaublicher Zufall. Nein, das ist eine Fügung. Und jetzt könnte man ja auch mal eine Kartenleserin fragen, wie das jetzt so sich mit Gabby fällt. Und das ist jetzt ein YouTube Video, das 100.000 Aufrufe hat. Eine Kartenleserin, die jetzt einfach mal das durchgeht, wie sich das Verhalten hat.
Nein. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr meine Kante flicken könnt.
Ja, die Karten haben gesprochen bzw. Gabby hat durch die Karten gesprochen und gesagt, es war er. Und jetzt nehmen wir noch das dritte und letzte Feld hinzu. Die Astrologie hat auch einen großen Boom. Du hast es vielleicht mal gesehen in solchen Spotify Hitlisten und so was. Es sind Astrologie Podcasts extrem beliebt, was ich sehr, sehr bedenklich finde. Und auch hat natürlich der Astro loge hier eine gute Erklärung. Warum ist sie überhaupt zu diesem Mord gekommen?
Ein Uranus-Mars-Square ist das Kind von Dingen, das, wenn die falschen Behandlungen sind, die Tatsache sein könnte, ein Verletzter eines Verletzten zu sein. Mars hat das Potenzial, zu verbreiten, und Uranus auch.
Schlimm. Oder? Und dass das auch dann jetzt gerade bei dieser Kartenleserin, habe ich es mal genau verfolgt, in den Kommentaren gefeiert wird. Da wird dann auch gesagt, ja danke, dass du dein Talent einsetzt, um uns zu helfen bei diesem wichtigen Fall. Man fragt sich, ist es vielleicht auch gut, wenn nicht alle Leute sich auch noch für Politik interessieren?
Eben, lieber einen Marathon gehen und sich um sowas kümmern. Also es gibt ja auch immer noch die gute Erklärung, warum funktionierte sowas bisher, also so krasse Gewalt, auch wieder dieses besonders skandinavische Demis, warum funktioniert diese gut, gerade bei Frauen. Genau, warum gerade bei Frauen, auch in der Literatur. Und dann war immer eine Erklärung, krasse Kriminalität ist immer nur ein Ausdruck von, ist ganz weit weg von meiner eigenen Lebenswelt. Es könnte auch vieles anderes sein. Also Männer gucken besonders dann gerne irgendwelche Autorennen, Sachen und so, wenn sie sich das Auto niemals leisten können. Wenn sie so halb sich das Auto leisten können, fahren sie lieber selber damit rum. Also so der Erfolg von Formel 1 und so. Das sind vor allem so Jugendliche, so FDP-Wähler halt. Da könnte ich dann bald mal drin sitzen oder wie auch immer. Und das hat man hier auch. Also wir sind in dieser ultra befriedeten Welt, in der uns eigentlich nichts Schlimmes passiert, körperlich. Also die Gewalt, die einem angetan wird, ist ja nun mal eine ganz andere. Du hast ja schon von so alka-rhythmischer Gewalt. Wir haben Armut als Gewalt. Aber so diese körperliche Gewalt, die da thematisiert wird, betrifft uns eigentlich nicht wirklich. Und wenn dann allenfalls als Bedrohung. Also man geht so nachts die Straße lang und denkt so, wenn mir jetzt Gewalt angetan wird, dann jetzt. Das ist aber das Nächste, an das man drankommt. Eigentlich erlebt man kaum Gewalt. Also statistisch einfach gesehen, es nimmt es halt wirklich ab. Gleichzeitig geht aber das Interesse für sowas hoch. Und dann denke ich mir auch immer, es ist diese Überschaubarkeit der Fälle. Ein Pärchen mit einem Smartphone und noch einem Smartphone und einer Spotify-Playlist. Damit sind erst mal alle Ingredienzien da. Der Rest wird einfach nur gerührt. Da ist dann eine Brei, die man so weiter rührt. Und da liegt es natürlich auch aufgrund so einer Attraktivität, es nicht zu verkomplizieren, nahe sich dann einfach Karten und die Sterne legen zu lassen. Das bleibt dann in diesem System. Die Sterne sind halt wie sie sind, da muss jetzt keiner kommen. Es ist völlig abstrus, aber gleichzeitig ist ausgeschlossen, dass bei den Sternen auch noch jemand rein manipuliert hat. Also da kommt niemand von außen und zerrt die an der Geschichte noch mal rum, sondern die bleibt einfach in sich geschlossen. Mit den Karten legen auch. Durch Zufall werden halt Karten gelegt und die können dann irgendwie gedeutet werden. Irgendwo ist schon eine latente Sinnsstruktur, man muss nur lange genug hinschauen. Und dann spinnt man so die Fan-Fiction irgendwie weiter. Und wird halt Teil dieser Geschichte auch.
Diese Abgeschlossenheit ist ja eigentlich das, wonach wir uns so sehnen. Also das ist ja immer wieder der Halt, dass man eigentlich permanent unabgeschlossen ist. Das Leben als Projekt, sagt Lyuk Boltanski, das führen wir eigentlich. Wir erleben es, wenn wir einen Beruf starten und wissen nicht, ob wir den bis zum Ende des Lebens haben. Beziehungen sind unabgeschlossen, alles ist unabgeschlossen und die hat man die Abgeschlossenheit. Das ist das, was eine enorme Sicherheit einem vermittelt, wenn man Krimis liest, ob das Dürrnmatt ist oder ob man modernere Krimis liest. Sie sind meistens in einer sehr abgeschlossenen Welt. Manchmal haben sie es auf die Spitze getrieben. Eine Agatha Christie oder auch ein Edgar Wallace, der was nur noch auf einem Schloss spielen lässt. Man ist auch ein Strom aus, weil man kommt nicht weg. Der Escape Room. Das ist auch eine Übersichtlichkeit und das scheint das Faszinosum zu sein. Ich würde auch sagen, es ist ein stark weiblich dominiertes Phänomen. Zumindest wenn ich jetzt mal meine grobe Recherche mir ansehe, dass ich doch auf sehr viele Podcasterinnen gestoßen bin.
Auch bei Zeitverbrechen. Aber was sollen wir noch dazu sagen? Das ist nicht unser Metier.
Nein, aber es ist gruselig, weil man doch sehen kann, welche Strukturen so gerade da sind. Also dass wir über Verschwörungstheorien reden und merken, dann welche esoterischen Ansätze da plötzlich vertreten sind. Wir hatten ja auch hier so Clips Christian Anders, Nina Hagen, die dann auch noch sagen, vielleicht waren es die UFOs oder so. Und hier haben wir dann auch wieder bei dem Fall sofort Leute, die auch das monetarisieren können. Also die große Reichweite erzielen und sagen ja hier, ich habe mal die Karten ausgepackt, jetzt gucken wir mal, wo sich die Leiche eigentlich befindet.
Ja, also da hätte ich auch mal eine Frage an die Hörer, die das verfolgen. Denn ich erlebe an mir immer wieder zum Beispiel Sonntag 18 Uhr klar, so auch in Vorbereitungen im Fernsehpodcast habe ich halt dann so eine Stunde Fernsehen geguckt, aber es war schon klar, da passiert jetzt nicht viel. Aber zumindest diese eine Stunde. Dann Montag hatte ich gar keine Zeit, irgendwas zu verfolgen, sondern war hier so in der Stadt unterwegs und so weiter. Dienstag war auch irgendwie krass, gestern war der Kindergarten zu und ich habe so den Tag im historischen Museum in Frankfurt verbracht mit den ganz kleinen und wenn ich dann abends noch Medienzeit habe, um irgendwas nachzulesen, weiß ich an solchen Tagen, also spüre ich richtig, ob ich jetzt meine Zeit verschwendet habe mit irgendwelchen Instagram Reels oder nicht. So und ich würde gern wissen, warum hätte ich absolut das Gefühl hier meine Zeit verschwendet zu haben, wenn ich mir irgendwelche True-Crime-Stories anhöre und warum empfinden das so viele nicht so? Warum empfinden hier so viele es als gut investierte Medienzeit, sich mit sowas zu beschäftigen, was das eigene Leben nicht betrifft, was eigentlich völlig uninteressant ist, wo man auch nichts jetzt lernt oder so, wo viel zu viel spekuliert werden muss, um überhaupt mal einen roten Faden zu spinnen. Also wer mir das mal erklären kann, vielleicht aus einer eigenen Begeisterung heraus, das würde mich mal sehr interessieren.
Und warum guckt man sich nicht lieber einen düsteren Film noir an?
Da kommen die nächsten Fragen auf. Zurück in die Wirklichkeit und in die Politik. Wir haben es ja nicht ganz mitbekommen, aber letzte Woche war großes Ereignis in Brüssel. Ursula von der Leyen versucht es ja zu institutionalisieren. Es gab eine State of the Union und da wir ja letztes Jahr ein sehr dramatisches 2020 hatten, bei dem Ursula von der Leyen dann auch die Gelegenheit beim Shop verpackt und meinte, okay, wir sind im Bedrängnis, die Pandemie ist da, also nutzen wir jetzt die Gelegenheit, wir wollen ja die Krise dann auch als Gelegenheit nutzen, das ist ja gute Tradition seit Barroso er Kommissionspräsident war, wir nutzen jetzt die Gelegenheit und machen eine Eigenmittelakquise vor Schuldung der Europäischen Kommission, ist ja breit thematisiert worden, auch von uns, 750 Milliarden beträgt der Schuldenstand der Europäischen Union, beziehungsweise 500 Milliarden, 250 Milliarden, kommen nochmal direkt aus den Mitgliedstaaten, aber was ich crazy finde, ist, dass Europa gar keine Rolle spielte im Wahlkampf und das aber gleichzeitig Italien beispielsweise 200 Milliarden ausgezahlt bekommen hat, um kurzerweiler Geld zu bezahlen und so weiter. Also in Italien ist völlig klar, auch für alle Beteiligten, ja, wir haben jetzt Geld, das uns die EU einfach überweist, da gehen nicht wir in die Verschuldung, sondern das macht denn niemand anderes für uns. Diese Gelder sind ausgezahlt und alle bangen jetzt darum, wer wird hier eigentlich Finanzminister? Weil die Europäische Union wird wohl so weitermachen, aber es wäre doch ein bisschen leichter ohne so einen großen Widerstand aus Deutschland, der so aus Tradition nochmal aufrechterhalten wird. Und in dieser Gemengelage hält Ursula von der Leyen also ihre State of the Union. Und da wir ja gerade schon beim Soul-Searching waren, jeder True Crime-Zuschauer geht auch ein bisschen in sich, während er das so meditativ verfolgt, was da vor sich geht. In sich gegangen ist also auch die Europäische Union.
Und das war auch ein Zeitpunkt für Soul-Searching.
Ja, ist eigentlich in Deutschland auch so, aber wird nicht gemacht. Also das ist auch so eine Gefühligkeit, die man sich in Deutschland nicht traut. Aber man weiß, in Brüssel ist das so ganggeber. Wir machen hier immer Soul-Searching und wie auch weiter. Es ist jedenfalls eine tiefe Wirtschaftskrise. Da sind wir ja auch in Deutschland so ein bisschen drüber geschrammt. Wir hatten das mehr so als Partikulares. Ja, die Künstler und so, die Restaurants, aber so richtig Wirtschaftskrise war eigentlich nicht. In Europa insgesamt dann aber doch schon. Und sie zieht das hier ganz groß auf, auch mit ihren beiden Programmen, die sie da angestoßen hat.
In the deepest global economic crisis for decades, we chose to go it together with the next generation EU. And in the gravest planetary crisis of all time again, we chose to go it together with the European Green Deal.
Ja, jetzt hat sie next generation EU und den Green Deal genannt. Und da fiel es mir dann auch wieder auf, wie sehr Europa davon abhängt, dass Krisen bewältigt werden müssen. Also wie sehr die nicht in einem normalen, jetzt haben wir einen Budget vor uns, jetzt machen wir das mal, sondern es ist Pandemie, dann 750 Milliarden mobilisiert. Hätte man sonst wahrscheinlich nicht so einfach hinbekommen. Und das ist ja beim Green Deal auch. Jetzt nutzt sie einfach die Gelegenheit zu sagen, ja der Green Deal ist im Grunde eine Herausforderung, wie wir bei der Pandemie Hilfe das machen mussten. Also es gibt eine Krise zu bewältigen. Vielleicht ist das die eine Lehre, die sie von Merkel mit aus Deutschland genommen hat. Also was für Merkel immer nur ein Spruch war, stärker aus Krisen rausgehen als man reingegangen ist, es scheint hier irgendwie Programm zu sein.
Wie erklärst du dir, dass das im Wahlkampf nicht in Anschlag gebracht wurde? Denn das ist ja an sich ganz einfach und kann ja wunderbar geleistet werden, dieser Transfer.
Ich glaube dahinter steckt eine große strategische Überlegung der Parteien. Dann man hat gesehen, was bei Martin Schulz er kam aus Brüssel und man hat dieses Brüssel-Ding ganz schnell abgestriffen, um ihn so als den ehemaligen Bürgermeister, der das Alkoholikertum überwunden hatte, noch mal darzustellen. Und bei Armin Laschet, er hat ja wieder, ich komme aus Aachen, Karlspreis, Europa, Pipapo und man hat es dann ausgeblendet. Also ich sehe nur, dass man es ausgeblendet hat. Es spielte dann keine Rolle mehr. Wahrscheinlich hat man sich auch gedacht, nee, das ist eh schon ein schwacher Kandidat, dann können wir ihn noch nicht auch noch mit einem schwachen Thema, das schon mal gescheitert ist, bringen. Und es gibt halt auch keine materielle Notwendigkeit. Deutschland ist ja aus sich selbst stark. Wenn Olaf Scholz über die Pandemie spricht, dann ist das ja immer nur, weil wir bisher so gut gewirtschaftet haben, können wir uns das jetzt leisten.
Diese italienische Abhängigkeit von Europa ist nicht da. Vielleicht bin ich auch nicht mehr erstaunt, aber es ist dann doch immer mal wieder zu konstatieren, dass so Moderatorinnen wie Maischberger und Will nicht einfach mal so was aufgreifen und dazu gespitzte Frage formulieren, wo sie einfach dann eine Reaktion bekommen, sondern auch lieber fragen, wie finanzieren wir das denn alles gegen, statt jetzt einfach zu sagen, aber hat das uns nicht gezeigt das und das bedeutet doch. Das wäre ja eine Leistung, die man auch erbringen könnte.
Ja, vor allem, es gibt ja auch was Inhaltliches zu beraten. Während bei Plasberg, da hat ja diese Fraktionschefs da mal da gehabt in seiner Runde und hat dann alle begrüßt und Lindner kam noch nicht, weil er im Stau stand und dann kam Lindner so rein und dann war so der allererste Wortlaut von Lindner gleich, aber ich habe den Fernsehpodcast nicht lustig gemacht, aber wie da Lindner so da sitzt und das allererste, ja, China und Amerika wachsen mit 7, 8 Prozent, Italien mit 4 und wir mit 3. Wir sind also irgendwo da im Hintertreffen und so. Und wenn man es jetzt ernst nehme, um zu sagen, naja, aber Italien kann man nicht wie China und Amerika als die anderen, sondern Italien sind auch ein bisschen wir. Also es gibt hier so eine europäische Dimension eigentlich. Das kann sie dann halt hier machen. Und das hätte man auch ruhig mal aufgreifen können. Denn wenn man Ursula von der Leyen folgt, sieht es gar nicht so schlimm aus mit unserem aktuellen Wachstum.
Last time, it took us eight years for the Eurozone GDP to get back to pre-crisis level. This time, we expect 19 countries to be at pre-pandemic levels this time.
Also hätte man mal Griechenland damals ordentlich ausgestattet und gefördert, dann hätte man dieses Wachstum auch erzielen können.
Genau, also in der Ansicht, klar, können wir jetzt sagen, na gut, der Zuschnitt auf das letzte Quartal, wie aussagekräftig ist das denn und so, aber sie hat jetzt das letzte Quartal genommen und deklariert dann ein größeres Wachstum als woanders. Und hier hätte man auch durchaus mal sagen können, ja, also dieses Wachstum geht überhaupt nur, wenn man es dafür in die Kelten ernst nimmt und den Staaten sagt, gebt erst mal Geld aus, die Einnahmen können wir dann später klären. Und wenn man das deutsche Mantra gemacht hätte, nee, wir müssen jetzt erst mal drei, vier Jahre lang die Wirtschaft wieder, wie auch immer, aufbauen, um dann Geld zu haben, dass man investieren kann. Nee, ginge nicht. Also es ist schon auch eine kleine Lobeshymne hier auf, erstens Verschuldung und zweitens ihr eigenes Programm Next Generation EU. Also die 750 Milliarden sind ja ausgezahlt plus nochmal die weiteren 1, 5 Billionen der Europäischen Zentralbank, die ein gar kein politisches Programm ist, einfach nur Pandemie-Hilfe. Deswegen blendet sie das hier auch aus. Aber die kleine Feierstunde, die sie hier macht, wir wachsen tatsächlich stärker. Europa insgesamt als Amerika und China hat eben sehr viel mit der neuen Geldpolitik zu tun. Und wir in Deutschland stehen halt daneben und wollen hier irgendwie Schuldenbremse und so. Und da hat sie einen klaren Appell gemacht. Zum einen, Schuldenbremsen müssen weg. Und zweitens, und das wird eben ausgeblendet hier in Deutschland, es gibt ja noch jüngere Menschen, an die man auch denken könnte. Also so wie ich jetzt schon meinte vorhin, die FDP sollte sich ihre jungen Wähler mal genau anschauen und denen folgen und eben nicht das altere Mantra von, was weiß ich, Schuldenbremse, weil 50-Jährige irgendwie Neid auf irgendwen haben oder so. Und da ist sie hier ganz deutlich. Also wir sehen hier in Europa mittlerweile ein Anti-Bundes-Regierungsprogramm. Und das ist jetzt die Stelle, wo sie Französisch spricht. Sie wechselt ja immer hin und her. Da hören wir einfach die deutsche Übersetzung.
Wir alle profitierten von der Grundlage, von der Basis unserer europäischen sozialen Marktwirtschaft. Wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass die nächste Generation in der Lage ist, ihre Zukunft aufzubauen. Wir haben eine junge Generation, die sehr gut ausgebildet ist, stark talentiert, hoch motiviert. Das ist eine Generation, die so viel geopfert hat, um die Sicherheit der anderen zu garantieren. Jugend, das ist normalerweise die Zeit der Entdeckungen. Man erlebt neue Dinge, man findet Freunde fürs Leben. Man entdeckt seinen eigenen Weg. Aber was haben wir heute von den jungen Leuten verlangt? Dass sie soziale Distanz einhalten, dass sie sich in den Lockdown begeben, dass sie von zu Hause aus zur Schule gehen, und zwar Dinge als ein Jahr. All das was wir tun, vom grünen Deal bis hin zur Next Generation EU, alles dient dazu, ihre Zukunft zu sichern. Next Generation EU muss daher finanziert werden durch neue Eigenmittel, an denen wir arbeiten.
Das ist wirklich ganz, ganz, also viel deutlicher kann man in diesem Amt nicht mehr werden.
Sie spricht halt für Europa, aber man kann ja sagen, sie sagt einfach der Staat. Ist jetzt erstmal da für die Jugend. Wir wollen ihnen eine Zukunft hinterlassen, das kostet Geld und dafür brauchen wir Eigenmittel, also Verschuldung. Das ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was in Deutschland immer. Damit der Jugend noch Zukunft bleibt, dürfen wir sie nicht mit einem Schuldenberg belästigen. Bei ihr ist es genau das Gegenteil.
Im Dezember hat Merkel im Bundestag gesagt, das sind jetzt Kosten, die natürlich auch für die nächste Generation zur Belastung werden. Das Gegenteil ist der Fall. Es ist erstaunlich zu sehen, wie das hier so abgekoppelt ist und dass das auch interessanterweise da stattfinden kann. Man weiß schon gar nicht mehr, ob es nicht sogar dann gut ist, dass wir gar nicht nach Pussel blicken. Damit die das einfach machen können und man das gar nicht so mitbekommt, während wir hier mit anderen Dingen noch beschäftigt sind, fällt das ein bisschen zahm, macht das da irgendwo in Brüssel für uns.
Genau, diese Verschuldung funktioniert natürlich nur, wenn am Ende die deutschen Finanzminister auch mit zustimmen. Man hat aber die Bemühung, von dem Einstimmigkeitsprinzip in diesen wichtigen Ministerratsentscheidungen auch wegzukommen. Klappt umso leichter, umso weniger, dass mediale Aufmerksamkeit ist, weil umso mehr mediale Aufmerksamkeit drauflegt, umso mehr müssen, dass dann die Finanzminister wieder im eigenen Land verkaufen. Und das wird dann schwer. Und diese Jugend ist halt in Europa einfach ein anderes Thema, weil du Jugendarbeitslosigkeiten in Spanien von 20-30 Prozent hast. Und sie sagt ja, das ist eine sehr gut ausgebildete Jugend. Das stimmt natürlich nicht. In Spanien sind die Hälfte der 30-Jährigen einfach überhaupt gar nicht ausgebildet. Also die sind für nichts zu gebrauchen, zu verwenden.
Perspektivlosigkeit ist so groß, dass auch gar kein Anreiz besteht, da Tolles zu machen.
Das war reine Dienstleistungs-Gig-Workerei, dass man sich da von einem Projekt zum nächsten irgendwie schleppt und dann bricht der Tourismus weg und dann bricht alles weg.
Und das geht nur, indem man wirklich die Wirtschaft beflügelt dort. Also das ist jetzt auch gar nicht nur mit staatlichen Maßnahmen oder so zu machen, sondern man kann eigentlich nur jetzt richtig anschieben und kann da eine prosperierende Wirtschaft schaffen, um dann in irgendeiner Weise wieder richtig Arbeitsplätze zu haben.
Und sei es nur ein Dienstleistungskreis, es kann durchaus sein, dass sich am Ende einfach nur alle im Kreis die Haare schneiden, aber es muss halt Geld zirkulieren und so weiter. Und das ist dann die Basis. Nur rumsitzen und nichts zu tun zu haben, keine Aufträge und nichts. Genau, deswegen auch die wichtige Rolle des Staates. Und sei es nur der Aufbau von Infrastruktur, da sehen wir jetzt in Amerika Infrastruktur, ist ja da auch immer so ein beliebtes Ding, wo man auch die Republikaner ans Boot bekommt, weil wenn im August ein Infrastruktur-Investitionsplan läuft, dann sind im September die Leute im Job. Dann sind da die Ausschreibungen für hier Straßenbauer und so weiter. Und dann kann da halt gebaut werden. Diese Ausbildungssache ist super interessant, denn Olaf Scholz stand im Bundestag und hat es auch in den Trielen immer wieder betont, die wichtigste Ausbildung in Deutschland ist die Berufsausbildung. Die wir mit dem schönen dualen System und so weiter, wird ja immer abgefeiert. Aber er sagt ja ausdrücklich die Berufsausbildung und klammert dann immer so indirekt ein, nicht das Studium. Also dieser Hang zu, wir müssen alle Abiturienten sein und dann studieren. Und dann fragt man eigentlich mit 25 Jahren, was hast du jetzt gelernt? Und man stellt irgendwie fest, naja, also klar haben wir jetzt ganz schön viele Leute, die irgendwas machen können, aber die eigentliche Arbeit, etwas zu reparieren, etwas aufzubauen und so weiter, da wartet man ewig auf die Handwerker. Das fällt denen ja im Ahrtal jetzt allen schon auf. Also man kriegt das Ahrtal gerade nicht aufgebaut, weil es einfach keine Handwerker gibt in diesem Maße.
Das ist ja das Schönste. Ich glaube, ich habe dir das ja schon erzählt. Im AfD-Programm stand hier drin, dass man hier die Flüchtlinge ausbilden soll im Handwerk, um sie dann wieder zurückzuschicken. Wo ich dachte, genau die Leute, die am meisten fehlen, die bilden wir aus und schicken sie zurück.
Genau. Und da gibt es hier eine große Klammer. Da kann nämlich Deutschland tatsächlich mit der EU, glaube ich, dann ganz gut. Klar, diese Betonung auf Jugend, aber es soll auch ein neues Programm namens ALMA geben.
Denn Europa ist angewiesen auf seine gesamte Jugend. Wir müssen diejenigen ermutigen, die durch die Maschen des Netzes fallen, diejenigen, die keine Beschäftigung haben, diejenigen, die weder Unterricht noch eine Lehre folgen. Für sie werden wir ein neues Programm anbieten, ALMA. ALMA wird diesen jungen Menschen die Möglichkeit anbieten, eine befristete berufliche Erfahrung in einem anderen Mitgliedstaat zu absolvieren. Denn auch sie verdienen es, eine Erfahrung wie Erasmus zu genießen.
ALMA ist jetzt stellvertretend für die grundsätzliche Attraktivmachung des Ausbildungsberufes. Man nimmt alle Vorzüge, die man Studenten gegeben hat, und gibt die auch denjenigen in der Berufsausbildung. Mit europäischen Reisen, klar ist das erst mal eine gemeint.
Und nicht ohne Hintergedanke, denn wir haben ja auch hier Personalmangel.
Richtig.
In verschiedenen Berufen, die keine große Ausbildung verlangen. Wir sehen ja jetzt gerade, was in Großbritannien passiert, mit Lkw fahren und plötzlich sagt man, ja gut, wir müssen jetzt über das Visum noch mal neu nachdenken. Wir lockern da mal, weil wir jetzt dringend Leute brauchen. Also ist das erst mal auch eine gute Möglichkeit.
Genau, das ist ja der Trick der Japaner, die dann einfach sagen, hier kommt kein Ausländer her, da sind nur Werksstudenten. Und dann bleiben die so fünf Jahre und dann irgendwie, ja, willst du nicht bleiben und so. Und dann wachsen die so rein. So ist das hier so ein bisschen auch. Betrifft allerdings erst mal nur Binnenmigration, ne? Also das erste Potenzial, das wir schöpfen, ist, dass wir identifizieren, wo wird denn richtig reingepowert? Deutschland, Niederlande, Dänemark und so. Und dann hat man ja ein Arbeitnehmerpotenzial in Spanien. Das kann man ja erst mal nehmen, während wir gleichzeitig feststellen, naja, in Spanien arbeiten auch eine Million Afrikaner, um das Gemüse zu ernten. Das könnte man ja genauso gut mit Spanien machen und da mal für ein ordentliches Wirtschaftsniveau sorgen.
Aber diese Binnenmigration ist ja auch schon relativ stark. Also ich hab's jetzt auch gerade erlebt, als ich in Berlin dann mit dem Taxi fuhr, war der Taxifahrer ursprünglich aus Rumänien und hat dann einige Jahre in Spanien gefahren und ist jetzt seit, ich glaube, vier, fünf Jahren in Berlin. Und sagte dann, dass er so gut Spanisch spricht, aber sein Deutsch sei noch nicht so gut. Das war aber ziemlich gut. Und das fand ich auch ein interessanter Werdegang, Rumänien, Spanien und jetzt Berlin.
Genau, das Prinzip ist ja immer, man kommt gut ausgebildet, wächst dann aber von unten in den Arbeitsmarkt hinein. Also man fährt erst mal Taxi, aber dann lernt man niemanden kennen und dann kriegt man ein Angebot und dann irgendwann ist man dann da, so dieses kanadische Modell. Und Binn-Migration ist so bedeutend, das sehen wir jetzt gerade an dem Kontrollgruppenfall, sozusagen in England, wo einfach Supermärkte leer sind und auch die Tankstellen, weil dann niemand mehr hinfährt, um die zu beliefern und wie auch immer, weil einfach alle Polen sich jetzt gedacht haben, ach so, na dann gehe ich halt zurück in die EU, ja. Die polnische Regierung nimmt sie alle mit Handkuss zurück. Und in England kann man sehen, wenn so Binn-Migrationsströme versiegen, dass das nicht gut ist. Und in deren Sicht ist das hier eine große Förderung dieser Migrationsströme, damit jeder Jüngere seinen Platz findet. 2022 möchte sie hier als Themenjahr für die Jugend.
Wenn wir unsere Europäische Union nach ihrem Bild gestalten wollen, dann müssen die jungen Menschen auch die Möglichkeit haben, die Zukunft Europas mitzuprägen. Eine Union muss eine Seele haben, eine Vision, die diese jungen Menschen anspricht, wie Jacques Delors es verlangt hat. Und ich zitiere, wie erwarten wir es, Europa zu schaffen, wenn die jungen Menschen darin nicht ein kollektives Projekt sehen, eine Repräsentation ihrer eigenen Zukunft. Und aus diesem Grunde schlagen wir vor, 2022 zum Jahr der europäischen Jugend auszurufen.
Davon wird man in Deutschland nichts merken, in Italien, Spanien, Portugal, aber doch.
Vermutlich, ja.
Das müsste man sich dann mal anschauen, was da genau für Projekte und Programme laufen. Dieser grundsätzliche Tenor hier, das erste Thema Pandemie und so weiter, Klimakrise, aber dann gleich auf die Jugend zu sprechen zu kommen, war auch so anders als dieser deutsche Wahlkampf, dass es überhaupt mal Thema ist. Das ist wirklich sehr erfrischend, deswegen haben wir uns…
Ja, da war ja eher so die Frage, wird Baerbock dann überhaupt Zeit fürs Kanzleramt haben, weil sie ja Kinder hat? Also das waren so Fragen, die sich dann hier Leute stellen.
Ja, und da hätte man Baerbock gerne den Mut gewünscht, sagen, wieso, ich mach doch eine Viertagewoche. Das muss doch gehen als Kanzlerin, ich hab doch Personal. Also in der Ansicht diese Betonung der Jugend hier, das ist wirklich auch ein bisschen erfrischend.
Unsere Union wird stärker werden, wenn es mehr wie unsere nächste Generation ist. Reflektiv, bereit und bemerkenswert, gegründet in Werte und stolz in die Aktionssituation.
Ich brauche es nicht unbedingt.
Warum nicht? Das hat sie einfach mal so gemacht. Beim Thema Impfung, das ist ganz erstaunlich. In Deutschland gibt es nur Georg Maskelo, der seit einem Jahr immer wieder darauf Wert legte, die Pandemie ist erst vorbei, wenn die ganze Welt geimpft ist. Also diese Sprüche hören wir nicht mal von Lauterbach. Die jammern ja immer nur die deutsche Impfquote.
Ganz erstaunlich. Und das ist dann in der UN Antonio Guterres, der das ganz, ganz scharf sagt auch. Also der hat ja vor der UN, wir hören da gleich einen Clip zu was anderem, denen eine Rede gehalten, aber wirklich mit Schmackes und wie der das betont. Aber tatsächlich hier ist man nur dabei, wenn man die siebte Booster-Impfung hat, wird dann Karl Lauterbach auch die 3M-Maske ausziehen.
Ja genau, es ist wirklich Wahnsinn, dass er da selber der Impfung nicht so sehr vertraut und sich dann noch in dem Gruppenbild nur mit Maske ablichten lässt. Für Ursula von der Leyen ist das Pandemie-Thema und insbesondere das Impfthema dann doch ein globales.
Ich verstehe es alles nicht. Es gab in der Financial Times vor einigen Monaten eine Rechnung, was das kosten würde, wenn man alle impft und wenn man da so richtig Kapazitäten zuschafft und das ist, glaube ich, eine Sache von drei Tagen, dann wäre das volkswirtschaftlich, also wäre das globalwirtschaftlich wieder reingeholt, weil wir früher anfangen könnten, wir hätten nicht dieses Lieferkettenproblem, wir hätten viele Dinge nicht. Also es gibt nichts billigeres als eine Impfung und ich kann das nicht kapieren und würde auch mir da einfach wünschen, dass dann mal so ein starker Nationalstaat wie Frankreich oder Deutschland einfach sagt, wir haben hier nochmal so ein Budget frei, jetzt gehen da 30 Milliarden hin. Und dann müssen die anderen irgendwas machen und da brauchen wir auch nicht die ganze Zeit über Impfpatente und so weiter diskutieren, sondern es ist einfach auch eine Frage des Geldes und das ist jetzt nicht mehr eine Frage, wem gehört das Impfpatent, wer sitzt da gerade drauf, sondern man kann es produzieren und es ist jetzt eine Sache der Distribution und auch, dass man vielleicht da nochmal Leute hinschaffen muss, die diese Impfung dann verabreichen, weil man da natürlich nicht eine Ärztestruktur hat wie hier, aber das ist einfach eine Frage von ziemlich wenig Geld.
Ja, die Unternehmen haben die Infrastruktur der Produktion aufgebaut. Das muss jetzt nur noch gekauft werden.
Ich verstehe es auch nicht, dass von der Deutschland, wir haben auch da in Afrika doch einige deutsche Unternehmen, also dass da nicht mal so eine große Kampagne gestartet wird. Also da kann man sich doch wirklich jetzt nochmal auch ins rechte Licht rücken, wenn man möchte.
Gerade gegen China, ja. China leidet ja selber an der eigenen schlechten Qualität der Impfstoffe und exportiert aber wie blöd.
Also man könnte da so viel jetzt machen. Also man könnte all diese komischen Reisen, die da immer veranstaltet werden mit tollen Zugeständnissen, was Deutschland für Afrika tut oder für Lateinamerika, da könnte man jetzt richtig gut vorangehen.
Also sie betont halt immer, dass Europa so viel exportiert hat, wie sie selbst verimpft hat. Anders als Amerika, die hatten ja ein strenges Exportverbot. Aber die europäischen Exporte gingen natürlich auch nur in die westliche Welt, ne? Also weiße und so, das ist ja alles im Milieu geblieben. Sie betont dann nochmal ihre European Health Union, das ist auch so ein Programm, das sie nennt. 50 Milliarden, also ist nicht wenig, dafür, dass ja die Mitgliedstaaten eigentlich, und selbst in Deutschland ist es dann, also Gesundheit ist ja immer so eine lokale Sache, Landessache. Da will sie aber nochmal groß rein und betont auch nochmal, dass mit der Impfung auch wirklich so ein gewisser Erfolg da ist. Sie betont hier nochmal so ein anderes Pandemie-Problem.
Während der Pandemie wurden zu viele Frauen dieser Freiheit beraubt. Es muss eine besonders schreckliche Zeit für diejenigen gewesen sein, die sich nirgendwo verstecken konnten, die nirgendwo vor ihren Peinigern fliehen konnten. Wir müssen Licht in dieses Dunkel bringen. Wir müssen Wege aus dem Schmerz aufzeigen. Ihre Peiniger müssen vor Gericht gestellt werden.
Das ist ja in Deutschland immer noch tabu, den Lockdown aufzuarbeiten. Wir sind immer noch mit Long-Covid und sowas beschäftigt. Wir suchen uns wie wild bei den Kindern, finden es einfach nicht. Die ganzen Spezialkliniken in Freiburg und so machen es schon wieder zu, weil keine Patienten kommen.
Dabei ist das andere ja statistisch in aller Eindeutigkeit da, was da an häuslicher Gewalt stattgefunden hat.
Es findet nicht statt. Erstes großes Thema nach der Pandemie und der Jugend. Digitale Infrastruktur, sie betont nochmal, es waren ja angezielt 20 Prozent von Next Generation EU sollte ins Digitale gehen.
In an unprecedented manner, we will invest in 5G and fiber. But equally important is the investment in digital skills. This is such an important topic.
Und sie betont dann auch nochmal, dass man das übertroffen hat, dieses 20 Prozent Ziel. Die Länder sollten ja Programme vorlegen, wie sie das Geld ausgeben. Und da sind sie ganz zufrieden. Sie betont dann nochmal, das hat ja auch, es ist so wahnsinnig, wie wenig Welt in diesem Wahlkampf hier eine Rolle gespielt hat. Aber das Thema hatten wir ja auch beim letzten Mal. Lieferketten und vor allem Hype-Leider, wo kriegt man sie her? Bei ihr ist das total normales Thema.
Aber lassen Sie mich nur noch kurz auf die Semiconductor fokussieren. Also ist das nicht nur ein Thema unserer Wettbewerbsqualität, sondern auch ein Thema der Technikverwaltung. Designtests und Testkapazitäten verbinden. Wir müssen die europäische und nationale Investition an der Wertschicht koordinieren.
Deutschland hat schon mal bei den Batterien aufgeholt. Europa insgesamt, aber vor allem Deutschland. Jetzt hat man doch festgestellt, wir können nicht auf den nächsten Technologiesprung warten. Wir müssen jetzt mit Lithium-Ionen arbeiten. Also macht man das jetzt auch. Dasselbe könnt ihr bei Halbleiter noch mal gelingen. Das sickert ja so langsam als Wissen durch. Ich war auch total überrascht. Aber klar, kommen die Chips erst mal aus Taiwan. Aber die Maschinen, um die Chips herzustellen, die kommen von ASML aus den Niederlanden. Und dann gibt es schon Überlegungen, wenn man Terror machen sollte, wie sähe der aus? Wenn man einen Rotterdam am Hafen drei solche Fabriken zerstört, dann hat man die Chips-Produktion der ganzen Welt lahmgelegt. Es sind ganz dünne Nadelöre, aber eben auch in Europa. Es ist so ein gewisses Potenzial, um eben auch hierzulande dann doch, man muss ja nicht gleich mit den fünf Nanometern anfangen.
Genau, das ist ja was Yevgeny Morozov hier hat, in einem Text, der im Salon gesagt hat, in Le Monde Diplomatique, dass diese Chips eigentlich hier nicht von Interesse sind beziehungsweise dass die woanders so günstig gemacht werden, dass man sich fragen kann, werden da Unternehmen interessiert sein. Was ich mir noch gut vorstellen könnte, ist, dass jetzt da auch mit Konzernen nochmal ganz anders verhandelt wird, möglicherweise. Da Amazon ja jetzt auch das Chips produzieren für sich selbst plötzlich als ganz wichtig erkannt hat und möchte da auch nicht mehr abhängig sein. Und Amazon macht das natürlich immer für sich. Und dann weiß man aber, wenn die was für sich machen, dann wird das natürlich auch ein darüber hinausgehender Markt. Also könnte Amazon vielleicht, wenn wir in zwei, drei Jahren hier reden, der ganz wichtige Chip-Hersteller sein. Und die Frage ist dann, wo werden die produziert?
Genau, da ist einiges in Bewegung. Es ist natürlich so ein bisschen blöde, dass jetzt die Chips-Produktion wieder in die Hände der Unternehmen fällt und damit so proprietär wird.
Und ich glaube, das hat auch eine strategische Sache mit der Politik. Also dass man mit Amazon jetzt gerade weiß, es ist nicht so nett, was vielleicht die beiden Regierungen da vorhaben könnte mit uns in den nächsten Jahren. Aber wenn wir jetzt so eine entscheidende Stelle sind für die Chips-Produktion, die entscheidend ist für die geopolitischen Zusammenhänge, dann werden die uns gut behandeln, beziehungsweise wir werden kooperativ arbeiten.
Genau, man hat dann was zum Bieten auf dem Weltmarkt. Man wird nicht so schnell rausgenommen. Mal gucken, in welche Richtung das weitergeht. Europa, es sind ja genug Leute da, die so was ingenieursmäßig sind. Es fehlt halt nur dieser Anreiz. Bei den Batterien war eins der ersten Felder, wo man es mal richtig gesehen hat, wo statische Investitionen einfach nötig waren. Ich fände es gut, grundsätzlich einfach, wenn man sagt, es gibt Chips-Produzenten. Die sind dann auf dem Weltmarkt tätig. Auch wenn man sagen muss, selbst heute sind die Produzenten, die man hat in Taiwan und so weiter, so langfristig an irgendwelche Lieferverträge gebunden und Preisvorstellungen, dass man eigentlich schon von einem Unternehmen so insgesamt sprechen kann. Und es gar nicht mehr Marktgeschehen ist, sondern nur noch politisches Strategie. Das fand ich auch interessant, wenn man sich China anschaut mit dieser großen Strategie, wir holen die 15 Schlüsseltechnologien bis 2025 zu uns, sind das so Überlegungen, die dann Google auch hat. Deswegen diese ganzen Ausflüge zu Boston Dynamics und den Robotladen und dann stellt man fest, naja, brauchen wir dann doch nicht. Und das macht Amazon halt jetzt auch. Sie sagen einfach, die Schlüsseltechnologien wollen wir bei uns im Unternehmen. Und eine dieser krassen Zahlen ist eben, in der Halbleiter-Chip-Industrie entfällt 22% aller Produkte auf Apple. Dadurch, dass die jetzt sogar in ihren Stiften Chips einbauen, in den Uhren, davon gleich wieder Milliarden verkaufen und so weiter, Handys, Computer, iPads und so. Also irgendwie ein Viertel der Chips-Produktion fällt auf Apple. Und da sieht man wieder, was Tim Cook für ein Talent ist. Denn das Apple-Liefer-Schwierigkeiten hat, hat man noch nicht gehört. Alle müssen hinten anstehen, außer wieder Apple. Tim Cook hat die Lieferketten wieder abgesichert.
Also da wurde nicht gesagt, dauert aber jetzt ein halbes Jahr länger.
Also da sieht man mal wieder Genialität. Also nicht so der Marktgeschehen, sondern wirklich dieser politische Zugriff auf irgendwelches inklusive Verhandlungsgeschick sichert einen dann doch irgendwie ab. Europas Demografie, sie betont, was wir in Move to Move, dem Buch zur Migration, schon besprochen haben, traut sich aber nicht ganz all in zu gehen.
Wir waren jeden Tag da, jeden Abend da, vor unseren Fenstern, vor unseren Türen, um den Arbeitnehmern an erster Front zu applaudieren. Wir alle wissen, wie stark wir von diesen Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmern abhängig sind von denjenigen, die sich für ein sehr geringes Gehalt weniger Sicherheit opfern.
Ja, also wir sind völlig abhängig von denen. Wir haben da eine Binnenmigration, die völlig aus dem Ruder ist, weshalb das Arbeitsgericht in Deutschland so sagt, die polnischen Omas, die hier noch die Uromas pflegen, kriegen jetzt auch mal Mindestlohn und so. Also alles außer Rand und Band. 80 Prozent der Pflege in Deutschland findet im privaten Bereich statt, also außerhalb der Pflegekasse. Jetzt gibt es die erste Überlegung, in Amerika war es glaube ich, weiß gar nicht, wo ich es gelesen habe, dass man Pflege, also familiäre Pflege, tatsächlich vergütet. Dass der Staat einfach als virtueller Arbeitgeber eintritt, dafür, dass du deine Alten pflegst.
Im Feminismus gibt es in den 70er Jahren schon diese Idee. Warum man eigentlich da nicht sagt, bei solchen Arbeiten, das muss so und so bezahlt werden. Und das ist etwas, was jetzt erst wieder aufgegriffen wird. Und ich will auch nochmal betonen, ich stand natürlich nicht draußen an der Tür und habe irgendwie applaudiert, sondern ich war immer für höhere Löhne.
Genau, jetzt hier, Applaus hat nicht gereicht. Jetzt habe ich schon gesagt, sie geht nicht so ganz all in. Wir vergleichen nochmal ihre europäische Pflegestrategie mit dem, was in Amerika gerade vor sich geht. Biden hat ja die Human Infrastructure erfunden, um die Pflege ins Infrastrukturprojekt mit einzugliedern.
Aus diesem Grunde schlagen wir eine neue europäische Pflegestrategie vor.
Sie hat es nicht ganz ausgeführt, aber man kann es ausrechnen, wenn eine Person ihren Schwiegervater oder seinen Schwiegervater pflegt, dann ist er raus aus dem Arbeitsmarkt, weil er damit zu tun hat. Welche Synergie-Effekte gäbe es, wenn man das professionalisiert und mit einem ordentlichen Mindestlohn ausstattet, dass einer 10 pflegt, so wie einer 10 Hunde ausführt zum Mittag und damit 10 Leute frei hält zum Arbeiten? Hier liegt ein unglaubliches Potenzial, das unbedingt gehoben werden muss in dieser älteren europäischen Union, die auf Migration nicht unbedingt scharf ist, da einfach den Arbeitsmarkt auszustatten mit Personen, die eben nicht durch Kehrarbeit und so weiter da einfach zu Hause gebunden werden.
Diese Arbeitsmarkt ist noch nicht vorhanden und deswegen ist da auch noch Skalierbarkeit möglich. Also sonst haben wir ja bei vielen Dienstleistungssektoren nicht mehr die Möglichkeit viel zu skalieren. Der Friseur wird jetzt nicht 15 Köpfe mehr schneiden können plötzlich. Aber wo hier noch gar nichts ist, da kann natürlich noch ganz viele Wachstum auch produziert werden. Klimaneutral.
Genau, das ist klimaneutrales Wirtschaftswachstum. Das ist Geld, das dann zirkuliert, ohne dass irgendwas kaputt geht. Apropos Klimaneutralität, das hat man in deutschen Wahlkampf nicht so deutlich gehört. Man hört hier immer nur so 1, 5 Grad Ziel, Ziele, Ziele, Ziele. Aber wie sieht es mit dem Programm eigentlich aus? Da nennt sie hier zumindest die Lektürebasis, die Textbasis.
The United Nations recently published an IPCC report, the Intergovernmental Panel on Climate Change.
Das fehlt in Deutschland. In Deutschland belässt man es bei Appellen für das Pariser Abkommen und die Klimaziele, aber nicht die programmatischen. Und der IPCC-Bericht ist ja einer, der mit verschiedenen Szenarien arbeitet und dann auch Handlungsmöglichkeiten aufzeigt und in denen auch Politiker mitgeschrieben haben, damit man es eben verwenden kann. Und nicht nur die Wissenschaftler mal wieder was betonen, sondern da ist schon auf Programmatik geachtet. Na ja, wird in Deutschland alles ausgeblendet. Hier so eine Zahl, die hat mich ein bisschen überrascht.
Es ist warm, es ist uns, wir sind sicher, es ist schlimm, aber wir können es fixieren. Mehr Elektrofahrzeuge als Diesel-Auto-Karren wurden in Deutschland in der ersten Hälfte dieses Jahres registriert.
So, im ersten Halbwert 2021 mehr E-Autos als Diesel.
Nee.
Also das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Hast du das nachgeguckt?
Nö, ich hab's nicht nachgeschaut. Wäre auf jeden Fall überraschend. Man sieht es ja auch so ein bisschen. Ja, wir gehen eben nochmal nach. Ich fand's erstaunlich. Auch erstaunlich fand ich. Neben den Klimazielen gibt's ja noch ein anderes Problem, nämlich die Umwelt selbst.
The COP26 in Glasgow will be a moment of truth for the global community. Major economies, from the US to Japan, have set ambitions for climate neutrality in 2050 or shortly after.
Ja, genau. Also sie guckt auf Glasgow. Da sind wir alle sehr gespannt, ob sie man sich mal auf Programme einigt. Das Biodiversität, wir haben ja hier im Salon kurz angesprochen, diesen Spiegeltext zu dem Text, den unter anderem der Bauernverband mitgeschrieben hat, zu 90 Milliarden Klima- und Umweltschäden pro Jahr durch die Landwirtschaft. Das hat ja auch keinen Niederschlag gefunden, auch nur bei den Grünen. Das ist immer nur Klima, Klima, Klima, aber dass wir pro Jahr 90 Milliarden Umweltschäden haben, wer weiß. Ein Pflichtthema, das sie hat, und das aber superschnell abgefrühstückt hat, fand ich überraschend, gerade durch Afghanistan, ist diese internationale Sicherheit.
Die aktuellen Fälle in Afghanistan sind nicht der Grund für diesen Veränderungen, aber sie sind ein Symptom.
Die gute Nachricht ist, dass wir in den vergangenen Jahren ein europäisches Defense-Ekosystem entwickeln.
Aber wir brauchen jetzt die Europäische Defense-Union.
Und sie belässt es im Grunde bei so einem Plädoyer, will auch China gar nicht richtig sagen, aber sagt ja in diesem Indo-Pazifischen Raum, wir sehen schon, was Biden da so macht.
Ja, ja, das ist ja bei beiden auch so, wir werden das sehen, dass man jetzt sich immer darauf einigt, dass man nicht zu häufig China sagt, also nicht so wie Trump.
Ja, genau, man macht das so durch die Blume irgendwie, aber schon recht deutlich.
Europa muss aktiv und vorhanden sein in der Region.
Will smarter sein. Sie hat ja so ein Template vorgeschlagen, könnte ein Modell werden, aber es ist im Grunde dieser Präampel Charakter irgendwie. Dann wurde sie aber doch konkret und zwar blicken wir mal bei China auf auch die neue Seitenstraße, die ja China sozusagen auch aus der Misere. Man sieht ja so, wenn China mal auf sich gestellt ist, dann funktioniert fast gar nichts. Also dieser Bausektor geht da völlig da nieder. Gerade Energie mussten sie jetzt sogar Strom abschalten, weil sie es irgendwie nicht organisiert bekommen. Wer da mal wo wie Strom ins Netz ein wird. Aber dieses Exportmodell, mit dem ja Deutschland auch gut fährt, das will ja China da auf Biegen und Brechen über die neue Seitenstraße organisieren. Und da möchte sie jetzt konkret darauf antworten, dass das Programm heißt Global Gateway.
Wir wollen Investitionen in Qualitätsinfrastruktur, Menschen, Inhalt und Nutzung, um die Welt zu verbinden. Wir werden eine wertgemäßige Ansicht nehmen, die Transparenz und gute Gewinnung unserer Partner bietet. Seit dem Sommer hat die neue Fiber-Optik-Kabel Brasilien mit Portugal verbunden. Wir werden mit Afrika investieren, um einen Markt für grüne Hydrogen zu schaffen, der die beiden Schuhe des Mediterrainischen hat.
In Brasilien ist China schon sehr aktiv. Das wird das eine Kabel nicht tun. Ich bin doch ein bisschen verwundert bzw. irritiert. Es ist eine merkwürdige Gleichzeitigkeit, zum Teil von denselben Institutionen. Man hat jetzt China als Wettbewerber oder als Konkurrent erkannt. Das ist etwas, was man mit Amerika auch gemeinsam hat. Zugleich gibt es diese deutsche Sonderstellung mit der Industrie, die sehr davon profitiert, dass es in China vorangeht und dass man da eng zusammenarbeitet. Das muss ja fast zeitgleich gewesen sein. Also am 24. im Handelsblatt Sorge vor Abschottung. Da warnt der Präsident der EU-Kammer in Peking, Jörg Wuttke, dass das gefährlich sein könnte für die deutsche Industrie und die europäische Wirtschaft. Es geht hier nicht nur um die deutsche Industrie, sondern auch um die europäische Wirtschaft. Wenn China seine Vision durchsetzt, und zwar heißt die ja Dual Circulation, man möchte jetzt die Binnenwirtschaft stärken, man möchte sich entkoppeln, und wir haben so einen großen Markt, wir haben vielleicht dann doch nochmal auch ein Bevölkerungswachstum, wenn wir jetzt von der einen Kindpolitik abgerückt sind, dass wir eigentlich eine florierende Wirtschaft schaffen könnten, ohne allzu sehr vernetzt zu sein. Und da wird dann gewarnt, da heißt es dann nochmal deutlich, ich sage dann Wuttke, wir sind hier keine Gäste, wir sind ein integraler Bestandteil der chinesischen Wirtschaft. Und man kritisiert also sehr diesen China-Plan, das wird zu Reibungen führen. Und eigentlich sei das doch ganz toll, wenn EU und China eng zusammenarbeiten. Und dann hört man zugleich das und weiß auch, was sonst so militärisch aufgeboten wird. Und ich glaube, da sind sehr widerstreitende Kapitalinteressen gerade.
Ja, es kommt immer ein Set-off an, in welchem Bereich man arbeitet. Die Automobilindustrie, die zu 40-50 Prozent ihre Profite in China einstreicht, kann es sich nicht erlauben, da nicht präsent zu sein. Andere Unternehmen haben aber Sorge, dass sie, wenn sie mit nach China gehen, als Zulieferer irgendwas, dort dann in diesen Strudel der, ja, da musst du aber erstmal einen Joint-Venture mit China gründen und auch Technologie transferieren und so weiter, dass sie da dann untergehen. Also für die wäre Abschottung gar nicht so schwer. Und dann hat man diese Versuche von ihr, eben diese peripheren Märkte wieder zurückzuerobern. Also Brasilien wieder als Kunde Europas zu sehen. Diese große Gefahr, dass China aus sich heraus, also da bin ich sehr skeptisch, ob das überhaupt auch von China aus so organisiert werden kann. Also es gibt diese Entwicklung, dass sie immer weniger abhängig sind von Exporten, weil die Bidden-Nachfrage so wächst. Aber du hast ja gerade jetzt dieses Durcheinander. Also es gab jetzt so viele Podcasts zu dieser chinesischen Investitionsbank, die vor allem die privaten Kredite für Häusebau und so organisieren, die da mit 500 Milliarden oder so in der Miese ist. Genau. Und die zum einen in einem Bereich tätig sind, der Bauwirtschaft, der zu 30 Prozent des Wirtschaftswachstums trägt. Also wir haben ja anhand des Zements schon gehört, wie krass da gebaut wurde und dies aber nicht organisiert bekommen haben, vorher das Geld einzukassieren. Also da wartet man ja auf sein Haus wie auf so ein Trabi damals. Man hat es schon mal bezahlt, aber dann kommt das Haus erst drei Jahre später und so weiter. Und gleichzeitig die große Verschuldung, dass man jetzt nicht weiß, wie viele Millionen Familien jetzt gerade nicht ihr Haus gebaut bekommen in China. Und wer soll das dann wieder machen? Also da scheint es doch bei der reinen, also wenn man drauf setzt, dass China das jetzt aus eigener Kraft schafft und nicht abhängig ist von Geldströmen von außerhalb, dass es nicht gelingt. Also es ist wirklich verrückt, wie China da immer wieder selber als zweites Thema eben dieser Strom, wir mussten da vor zwei Tagen wirklich einfach den Strom abschalten, weil sie intern es nicht, man will ja Marktwirtschaft machen, es hinbekommen haben, Kraftwerksbetreiber zu motivieren, die ihre Energiequelle am Netz zu lassen, weil die Vergütung nicht entsprechend war. Also haben die dann aus BWL-Logik ihre Kraftwerke ausgeschaltet, was natürlich entsprechende VWL-Konsequenzen hatte. Da fragt man sich wieder, warum konnte China da nicht eingreifen?
Das ist erstaunlich.
Sagen wir, wir bezahlen jetzt einfach mal den Strom, egal zu welchem Preis. Hauptsache, die Industrie ist versorgt.
China hat ja keine Dollar-Hegemonie. Also die haben ja ihre Wirtschaft und wir haben eine Dollar-Hegemonie noch immer. Die versuchen natürlich die eigene Währung zu stärken und zu versuchen, dass vielleicht sogar irgendwann die eigene Währung die Weltwährung wird. Da bin ich natürlich sehr skeptisch, dass das funktionieren kann, weil Dollar nun wirklich so dominant ist, dass man da alle anderen schon einfach weglassen kann. Das ist auch für uns wichtig, wie die FED reagiert. Nur dann können wir auch wiederum. Diese Abhängigkeiten sind da. Ich glaube, bei Evergrande ist es jetzt so, dass China ein bisschen mal austesten will, was müssen wir eigentlich mitmachen? Was muss die KP mitmachen, wenn Konzerne solche Misswirtschaften an den Tag legen? Es scheint wohl nicht so zu sein, dass es vergleichbar ist mit den Lehman Brothers, dass es einen solchen Dominio-Effekt gibt.
Weiß man eben noch nicht.
Man weiß es nicht. Es gibt auf jeden Fall schon Effekte. Das hatte ich auch im Handelsblatt gelesen. Luxusaktien unter Druck. Denn da sind natürlich auch viele investiert in dieses Unternehmen. Und plötzlich heißt es dann, hier ist dann kein Geld mehr für den Pelzmantel da. Und so sind die Aktien von Dior zum Beispiel oder auch von LMVH sind dann gefallen. Weil dann Investoren merken, ach, das Geld könnte ja futsch sein, wenn ich hier bei Evergrande investiert bin und die das nicht retten. Denn das ist ja immer noch so ein bisschen unklar. Wird China am Ende sagen, too big, too fail, die müssen wir retten? Oder sagen die, gut, dann gehen die halt über die Europa. Wir haben aber noch genug andere.
Ja, also ihr habt ja einen Wohlstand für alle, auch mal kurz auf China geblickt. Vor allem dieser Wechsel, wie kommt man eigentlich von so einer staatsgläubigen Kapit, marktwirtschaftlichen, nicht marktwirtschaftlichen, sondern planwirtschaftlichen, wir organisieren das mal zu, kann man ja auch mit einem Schock machen. Und wenn die sich da so bei Ludwig Erd und so weiter bedienen, das steht ja alles in dieser Tradition, die man jetzt bei Lars Feld noch findet, Strukturwandel. Man braucht einfach nur einen guten Strukturwandel. Nur den Strukturwandel findet man halt nicht, weil man ständig too big to fail drin hat und dann retten muss. Da finde ich es ja in Deutschland ganz interessant, in Deutschland gibt es ja nicht so richtig gigantische Immobilienentwickler, sondern es gibt so ganz viele kleine. Also das jetzt mal hier in Frankfurt, das eine Gebäude für eine Milliarde, bevor es fertig wurde, verkauft wurde, war halt der größte Kaufpreis, der immer für ein Gebäude bezahlt wurde. Das ist ja in China alles Peanuts. Da werden ja halbe Städte irgendwie so verhöckert. Mit gigantischen Playern. In China hat man dann noch diese Eigentums-Sache, dass da wirklich jeder ein Haus besitzt. Also in China hat ja irgendwie 90% der Familienwohnungen irgendwie im eigenen Haus oder besitzen mindestens ein Haus. Also da ist eh eine große Verquickung von so Vermögenswerten mit dieser Industrie, die diese Häuser bereitstellt. Und wenn du dann einen so Player drin hast, der eben einfach einen Strukturwandel nicht mitmacht, sondern sich in absoluten Niedrigzinsphase Kredite holt mit zweistelligen Zinsraten, die er sich erholt. Nur weil man in einem Metier des Bauens tätig ist, wo eben klar ist, die letzten 20 Jahre sind wir auch mit 25% pro Jahr gewachsen. Irgendwann hört das auf. Und das verstehe ich halt nicht, dass dann viele denken, dass ein Unternehmen, das sich Kredite holt, im 11-12% Zinsen, die sind ja wohl sehr davon überzeugt, dass sie es irgendwie hinkriegen und so. Und dann stellt man 40% fest, ach nee, doch nicht. Und dann platzt so ein 500 Milliarden Ding. Und viele stehen ohne Haus da, das ist ja dann noch so ein Ding.
Also die Belohnungsnote ist ja ohnehin schon nicht unerheblich.
Also ob China das ohne Welt schafft, da auf eigenen Füßen irgendwie zu stehen, da haben sich glaube ich jetzt die Woche wieder gezeigt, dass da wenig funktioniert. Und Ursula von der Leyen will hier auch nochmal die Züge enger ziehen. Wir haben ja zum einen Klimazölle schon thematisiert. Man zieht einfach Grenzen hoch und sagt, alles, was nach Europa geliefert wird, muss, wenn es durch Klimaschendung billiger war, nachverzollt werden, sodass der Preisdruck da hoch ist. So will sie auch mit der ein oder anderen sozialen Sache verfahren und beispielsweise Zwangsarbeit ausschließen. Ich würde sagen, es ist ein Zeug gegen China, den sie hier thematisiert. Sie wird nicht so ganz deutlich, aber ich glaube, man kann da schon ein großes Warenportfolio finden, wo man demnächst sagt, so nicht. Also was die Uiguren herstellen und wie sehr sich da auch VW schon in die Nesseln gesetzt hat, als Herr Dees da nicht einsehen wollte, was da so passiert. Das klickt man glaube ich leicht identifiziert und dann noch einfach per Beschluss sozusagen ausgeschlossen. Dann sagt man, ne und das würde auch jeder akzeptieren. Also die Zustimmungswerte dafür werden ja groß genug. Und so wie sie hier China attackiert, attackiert sie auch relativ direkt Russland mit dieser Aktion über Belarus, da immer Flüchtlinge nach Europa zu bringen.
Look at what happened at our borders with Belarus. The regime in Minsk has instrumentalized human beings. They have put people on planes and literally pushed them towards Europe's border. This can never be tolerated. And the quick European reaction shows that. And rest assured, we will continue to stand together with Lithuania, Latvia and Poland and let's call it what it is, it is a hybrid attack to destabilize Europe. We'll never tolerate that.
Ja, also hier läuft ein Angriff, sagt sie. Warum nicht? Recht deutlich.
Sehr deutlich.
Vorhin hat sie ja auf Französisch gesprochen, als es um die Jugend ging und so weiter und so fort. Jetzt zum Ende der Rede spricht sie auch nochmal auf Deutsch und wir können alle mal kurz überlegen, was für eine Prosa packt sie wohl aus?
Und es sind genau die gleichen Werte, die die Freiheitskämpfer einten, die vor nun mehr als 30 Jahren den eisernen Vorhang niederrissen. Sie wollten Demokratie. Sie wollten ihre Regierung frei wählen. Sie wollten den Rechtsstaat. Vor Gericht sollen alle gleich sein.
Sie wollten nochmal die Sonntagsrede zu 89 raus.
Das ist ein bisschen verwunderlich, was sie jetzt da gerade macht. Sie redet ja eigentlich fast immer an seißen Festrede, oder? Es ist immer Festrede. Immer mindestens Paulskirche.
Sie hat ja auch so einen Rednerpult. Das gibt es da eigentlich gar nicht. Eigentlich redet man ja da vom Platz aus. Auch der Kommissionspräsident Jean-Claude Juncker hat ja immer nur aus dem Plenum heraus an so einem Stehding gesprochen. Aber sie hat sich da so einen Pult in die Mitte gestellt.
Es ist immer Sonntagsrede.
Ja, warum nicht? Auf Deutsch bleibt sie aber nochmal bei einem Thema, das uns hier auch interessiert, gerade mit der CDU.
Und ab 2022 werden diese Berichte zur Rechtsstaatlichkeit zusätzlich konkrete Empfehlungen an die Mittelstaaten enthalten.
So, das hatten wir hier auch ausführlich thematisiert. Diese EU-Budgets werden jetzt daran geknüpft, wie das Geld verwendet wird. Und wenn da europäisches Geld verschwendet wird, sei es durch Handlanger von Orbanen oder sonst irgendwie, dann gibt es das nicht. Und auch wenn Rechtsstaatlichkeit nicht eingehalten wird, werden Gelder zurückgehalten. Wenn die Polen sagen, wir machen jetzt mal eine schwulenfreie Zone, dann gibt es kein Geld. Das Next-Generation-EU-Geld fließt auch gerade nicht nach Ungarn. Das wird auch völlig übersehen hier. Dass Italien 200 Milliarden bekam und Ungarn gerade nichts.
Und es ist erstaunlich, dass Orban seinen Leuten auch noch so verkaufen kann. Der muss natürlich diesen Anti-EU-Kurs haben, muss aber eigentlich auch erkennen, dass er auf dieses Geld angewiesen ist. Und dass der noch immer da halbwegs gut rauskommt, ist erstaunlich.
Und das will sie auch erst mal so programmatisch fortführen.
Trotzdem gibt es in einigen Mitgliedstaaten besorgniserregende Entwicklungen. Und hier ist mir eines wichtig. Am Anfang steht immer der Dialog. Aber der Dialog ist kein Selbstzweck. Er muss auch zu einem Ziel führen.
Am Anfang steht immer der Dialog. Da kann man auch die letzten Jahre nochmal umdeuten, weil die EVP, was hat sie sich schwer getan mit der, wie heißt sie, nicht der PiS, sondern Orban-Partei. Fidesz, genau. Und was hat man sich schwer getan? Und sie ist immer nur, ihr redet ja nur. Und sie ordnet jetzt dieses Reden erstmal ein mit, ja, das war nur Phase 1. Jetzt kommt halt Phase 2. Also wir haben jetzt genug geredet.
Was bedeutet, dass die Union dann auch mal aufhören sollte, mit denen zu reden?
Genau, das Gerede ist jetzt dabei. Jetzt wird einfach werden Budgetentscheidungen gehalten.
Nicht noch mal Orban feiern in Bayern.
Genau, nicht noch mal ein großer Auftritt in Brüssel, den man sich dann so für die Kameras noch mal inszeniert, sondern dann ist halt einfach Schluss. Und da betont sich ja auch nochmal, was die EU jetzt eigentlich schon macht.
Und meine Damen und Herren Abgeordnete, der europäische Haushalt ist die in Zahlen gegossene Zukunft unserer Union. Und deshalb muss auch er geschützt werden. Wir müssen dafür sorgen, dass jeder Euro und jeder Cent seinem Zweck zugutekommt und nach rechtsstaatlichen Grundsätzen ausgegeben wird.
Das war auch schon so ein Tenor, der hat sich angedeutet. Vor einem Jahr, als das Next Generation EU 750 im Jahr, in dem wir vor Schulden uns mal selbstprogramm kam, weil da schon der Tenor war, ab jetzt ist das unser Geld. Wir vermitteln nicht mehr, was die EU-Länder einzahlen und dann wieder ausgezahlt wird. Jetzt ist es unser Geld. Das heißt, wir können jetzt mit dem Schutz europäisches Geld argumentieren. Was sie ja auch wieder, dieser Schutz, betont hat. In der Ansicht gibt es hier eine gewisse Motivationslage, das Geld nicht der Korruption hinzugeben. Sie hat am Ende noch mal ein zweites Thema betont, Pressefreiheit und Europa. Da ist sie recht deutlich geworden, hat dann auch im Zuge dessen noch mal Namen von toten Journalisten vorgelesen. Da war sie ganz deutlich.
Journalistinnen und Journalisten werden angegriffen, einfach nur, weil sie ihre Arbeit machen. Einige werden bedroht und verprügelt, andere tragischerweise ermordet. Mitten in unserer Union.
Also dadurch, klar, Sonntagsrede sehr feierlich und so weiter, aber dadurch, dass sie so viele Programme nennt, die entweder anstehen oder die jetzt schon wirklich substanziell Ländern helfen, finde ich, ist da ein bisschen zu leicht drüber hinweggegangen. Wir haben in Deutschland immer noch dieses Ja, ist ja Ursula von der Leyen und so weiter, aber da ist doch ein bisschen mehr Substanz insgesamt drin in diesem Europa mittlerweile.
Absolut.
Sei es nur durch diese eigene Verschuldung, die man da hat, dass man da mehr hinschauen sollte.
Und dann sieht man auch, dass die Lage sich ein bisschen anders darstellt, als man das in Deutschland gerne sieht. Zum Beispiel, wenn man über die NATO diskutiert. Das war ja ein Thema, das müssen wir noch mal kurz aufgreifen. Bei der Bundestagswahl, das so absurd war, dass man also laufend in jeder Sendung, die es kam, von den Linken ein Bekenntnis zur NATO erzwingen wollte. Und wir wissen um diese Position der Linken oder beziehungsweise einiger Linken, die es aber dann noch immer wieder sehr nach vorne schafft und auch im Programm sich wiederfindet. Also dass man eigentlich nicht mehr an die NATO glaubt oder nie dran geglaubt hat und aus der NATO austreten will. Und bekennen sie sich dann zur NATO. Und sonst können wir doch gar nicht koalieren, wenn sie nicht zur NATO stehen. Und das war dann auch immer für die Moderatoren so ein gefundenes Fressen, dann auch noch mal Scholz zu fragen. Ja, Herr Scholz, wie ist es denn? Können sie überhaupt mit den Linken? Denn die stehen ja nicht zur NATO. Und dann hat man mit Afghanistan auch geglaubt, man hätte da noch mal was in Anstark bringen können, wo man ja sagen könnte, na ja, also, ich glaube, die Linke waren wirklich die einzige Partei, die von Anfang an immer auf diese ganzen Missstände hingewiesen hat und diesen Einsatz als falsch empfunden hat. Und da könnte man eigentlich ja denken, jetzt nach diesem Fiasko, das wir hier verhandelt haben ja auch in der vergangenen Folge, da müsste man jetzt Abbitte tun und zumindest nicht mehr die Linken jetzt damit nerven, könnte eher sagen, es tut uns leid, aber ihr habt ja da eigentlich 20 Jahre lang recht gehabt.
Man kann es noch viel konkreter machen, im Juni hatten die Linken einen Antrag im Bundestag, die Ortskräfte jetzt zu evakuieren. Als man, wie wir ja heute wissen, noch Monate Zeit hatte, weil klar war, in welche Richtung das geht. Also selbst klar, vor dem 11. September noch, diesen Niederlage in Kabul. Damit hat dann keiner gerechnet, aber bis Weihnachten war eigentlich klar, dass es solange da nicht hält. Und die Linken hatten im Juni noch diesen Antrag gestellt, die Ortskräfte jetzt zu retten, weil es jetzt wirklich drängend wird. Und es haben alle abgelehnt. Und dann kam es ja erst im August dazu, dass man nachträglich den Hauruck, jetzt müssen wir aber wirklich mal jemanden retten, und sei es nur die drei Leute, die dann so am Flughafen auffindbar waren irgendwie. Und da haben sie ja nicht mitgestimmt, sondern haben sich flächendeckend enthalten. Und das wurde ihnen dann vorgehalten. Und das war so verlogen, diese Juni-Aktion im Bundestag einfach auszublenden, um dieses Argument jetzt zu machen.
Das fand ich auch wirklich schäbig von einigen Grünen, dass die das auch so gemacht haben. Karl Lauterbach und Cem Özdemir und wie sie alle heißen, haben dann immer wieder darauf hingewiesen. Da sind dann auch so junge Grüne einfach ein bisschen cleverer. Also so wie die Sarah Lee zum Beispiel, die dann auch nochmal einen Jacobin aufgeschrieben hat, warum das eigentlich gar kein Problem wäre, Rot-Rot-Grün da eine Koalition einzugehen. Denn das ist ja nicht geknüpft. Also die NATO-Mitgliedschaft ist ja nicht jetzt kriegsentscheidend für eine Koalition. Da sagen ja nicht die Linken, wir können nur mit einer Partei eine Koalition machen, die ab sofort sagt, wir steigen aus der NATO aus. Das hat ja damit gar nichts zu tun. Und du hast ja einen Clip, den sollten wir mal spielen von Dietmar Bartsch, der das auch in aller Deutlichkeit auf den Punkt bringt, diesen Wahnsinn mit der NATO.
Aber Herr Zamperoni, also jeder Mensch dieser Welt weiß, dass die Linke sich nicht erst an einen Tisch setzt, wenn die NATO aufgelöst ist. Das ist doch absurd, uns das zu unterstellen.
Ja, wir können uns fragen, ist es sinnvoll, aus der NATO auszutreten? Was hätte das für Folgekosten? Wir wissen, dass Europa dann sehr viel Eigenständiges machen müsste. Also das wäre nicht gleiche Abrüstungsprogramm. Also wir verwandeln uns, wenn wir aus der NATO austreten, nicht automatisch in die Schweiz und halten uns das alles raus.
Was hieß er es überhaupt, aus der NATO austreten? Genau, klar, die NATO ist eine Organisation und hat so eine Hauptquartier in Brüssel. Aber die NATO ist erstmal ein völkerrechtlicher Vertrag, wenn man halt eingegangen ist, so. Das ist wie bei dem Paris-Abkommen, wo dann öffentlichkeitswirksam der Präsident der Amerikas irgendwie sagt, wir drehen jetzt aus dem Paris-Abkommen aus. Und so zwei Jahre später stellt man dann fest, ach so, wir sind immer noch gebunden. Ab jetzt gilt das erst und so. Und dann ist aber später der neue Präsident da und dreht schon wieder bei und man weiß auch nicht, ah ja, jetzt ist er beigetreten. Was heißt das jetzt eigentlich? Also hält man jetzt in Amerika die Klimaziele 2021 ein oder was? Also das ist sowieso, man verwechselt da immer so ein bisschen, was das eigentlich irgendwie miteinander bedeutet. Am Ende ist es wahrscheinlich eine Budget-Frage in Deutschland, die man da strapazieren müsste, aber nicht die NATO.
Möglicherweise wäre das ähnlich teuer. Man kann glaube ich auch nochmal sehr stark machen, dass man sich nicht so sehr unter Druck setzen lassen muss, dass man immer sagt, ja ihr habt dieses 2%-Ziel noch nicht erfüllt. Wir können auch mal gucken, was Amerika alles nicht so erfüllt oder was die einfach gar nicht ratifizieren, wo die sagen, haben wir nichts mit zu tun.
Die ILO-Arbeitsnorm und so.
Ganz genau, also da wäre ganz viel zu nennen. Ich glaube, da könnte man vieles in die Waagschale werfen. Ob das so sinnvoll wäre, jetzt da auszutreten, weiß man nicht. Aber dass die NATO zu kritisieren ist und dass die jetzt immer so abgefeiert wurde, leuchtet mir überhaupt nicht ein, dass die zu kritisieren ist, ist doch vollkommen klar. Wir haben doch NATO-Partner, die sich mittlerweile fast selbst schon bekriegen. Also wir haben ja schon fast einen Bürgerkrieg in der NATO, wenn wir uns ansehen, was auch mit der Türkei da los ist. Also dieses Fest der NATO hat mich wirklich daran erinnert, wenn jetzt so im Jahr 2002, ja, wir haben jetzt den Afghanistan-Krieg und jetzt ist man überlegen, was könnte man noch machen. Aber man ist glaube ich noch in diesem Modus drin. Und so ist auch diese Berichterstattung. Und zum Teil sieht man ja auch die Gesichter, die schon 2002 dabei waren, die das dann alles nochmal so vorbringen. Und da frage ich mich auch wieder, blickt da eigentlich jemand auf die Weltbühne? Und wir machen das jetzt mal, denn es gab ja auch was, was die NATO sehr erschüttert hat, wenn plötzlich da Bündnispartner so ihre eigene Masche machen und wenn dann Australien eigentlich einen U-Brot-Deal hat mit Frankreich, was auch für Frankreich finanziell interessant ist, und sich Australien aber dann umentscheidet und plötzlich mit Großbritannien und mit unserem NATO-Partner USA da eine eigene Sache macht und Europa plötzlich aus dem Force. Und das werden wir uns jetzt mal zu Gemüte führen.
Für Frankreich war es ein Jahrhundertvertrag. Zwölf U-Bot-Lieferungen an Australien für knapp 58 Milliarden Euro. Der Deal ist erstmal geplatzt. Australien will jetzt selbst Boote bauen und lässt sich dafür mit nukleare Antriebstechnik aus den USA und Großbritannien versorgen. Die drei Staaten haben einen neuen Sicherheitspakt für den Indo-Pazifik vereinbart. Als historischer Schritt wird der vom US-Präsidenten verkauft.
Gibt doch viele, viele Milliarden.
Ja, ist das dann auch gleich historisch? Wenn es um Milliarden geht, ist das wohl eher das, was da noch so alles drinsteckt. Und das schauen wir uns mal an, was da alles drinsteckt. Jedenfalls ist für Euronews doch ziemlich deutlich, dass Europa da erstmal auf sich allein gestellt ist.
Ein eigener milliardenschwerer Deal mit Australien für den Bau von 12 U-Booten ist damit wohl geplatzt. Es ist ein Zeichen, dass Europa allein überleben muss, sagte EU-Außenbeauftragter Josep Borrell. Kritiker sprechen von einem Schritt im Stile Trumps.
Also Borrell sagt schon, Europa ist jetzt auf sich allein gestellt. Also etwas, was Macron immer wieder deutlich macht, er sagte ja, die NATO sei hirntot und hat natürlich da eigene militärische Ziele und auch Aufrüstungsziele. Also es ist jedenfalls ganz erstaunlich gewesen, dass ich so ein bisschen die Berichterstattung im Handelsblatt mitverfolgte, weil ich das immer im Zug dann las. Und dann war da einmal schon fast so, dass man dachte, ach so läuft jetzt der Hase, denn man ist sehr pro transatlantisch und will dieses NATO-Bündnis aufrechterhalten da beim Handelsblatt. Also bei vielen zumindest hat man diesen Eindruck, dass dieser Tenor sehr, sehr stark ist. Und dann wurde aber diese Macron-Position schon so fast in die Nähe gerückt von Linkspartei. Also das ist so Linkspartei oder vielleicht noch so Rechte, die würden das auch noch vielleicht so sehen. Aber das war sehr interessant, dass man da jetzt so eine neue Querfront plötzlich sah, also die Linke und Macron, wo ich auch dachte, das wäre eigentlich ganz gut gewesen, wenn die Linke mal deutlich gesagt hätte, ja wir sehen das ja im Prinzip ähnlich wie Präsident Macron. Da kann man dann wirklich mal für Irritationen im Fernsehstudio sorgen.
Genau, auf Twitter wurde ja auch immer wieder nach einem Bekenntnis der Franzosen zur NATO gefragt, so wie Bekenntnis nach NATO sonst hier nur mit den Linken verknüpft ist, weil sie gerade sagte, Kritiker sehen darin einen Schritt wie bei Trump. Das ist ja original der französische Außenminister, der sagte, das ist wie, Biden ist wie Trump, nur ohne Tweets. Das ist ein Zitat. Also das sind schon alle ziemlich all in gegangen.
Ganz genau. Wir hören in den Podcast rein Streitkräfte und Strategien vom NDR. Da geht es noch um Frankreichs Interessen, die nicht nur monetäre sind.
Der U-Boot Deal war ein Kernelement für die ebenfalls angestrebte französische Sicherheitspartnerschaft mit Australien. Die Franzosen haben im Pazifik in der Region eigene Interessen in den Überseegebieten, in Polynesien und Neukaledonien und anderen Inseln. Dort leben über eine Million Franzosen. Kurz, Paris fühlt sich von Australien ausgebotet und hintergangen, aber noch mehr von den USA. Denn Washington ist bisher als historischer Partner angesehen worden.
Ja, man kann da fast sagen, da hat die Dekolonialisierung auch noch nicht ganz stattgefunden. Deswegen gibt es da alte Verbindungen, die man aufleben lassen will. Beziehungsweise nicht beenden will. Und hat deswegen auch gesagt, wir sind der natürliche Partner dafür. Entsprechend sauer ist der französische Außenminister Jean-Yves Ladrian. Der sagt Folgendes im französischen Fernsehen.
Wir wurden belogen. Mit uns wurde ein doppeltes Spiel gespielt.
Es ist ein riesen Vertrauensbruch, eine Missachtung.
Also es läuft nicht gut zwischen uns, ganz und gar nicht.
Wir haben eine Krise.
Als ich das so sah, habe ich auch gedacht, das ist aber sehr flapsig. Klar, nicht Macron selbst äußert sich dazu, sondern der Außenminister, der geht dann so ins Fernsehen. Das war aber auch kein regulärer Termin, sondern es war so klar, heute ist der Außenminister da. Und dann so ein, ja, es läuft nicht gut zwischen uns. Also dann so nicht die richtigen Worte gefunden irgendwie. Also es war so ganz gezielt und diplomatisch ausgedrückt und hatte da auch so eine niedliche Seite irgendwie, weil man dachte, spielen jetzt alle ein Spiel. Das kennt man ja so ein bisschen aus Deutschland. Wenn Andrea Nahles irgendeinen Vorstoß macht zum Thema Arbeitsrechte, dann kommt automatisch von den Gewerkschaften ein Widerspruch, weil sie ja sagen müssen, das reicht nie, was die Regierung macht. Gleichzeitig finden sie es aber eigentlich gut und kündigen ihr dann an, so sieht unsere Antwort dann aus, kommt heute Abend in den Tagesthemen usw. Und dann wird das halt so durchgespielt. Und ich frage mich jetzt die ganze Zeit, hat der Franzose hier...
Ich glaube, die sind richtig sauer. Die haben ja dann auch so Treffen abgesagt oder haben... Ja, aber auch das kann ja alles abgesprochen werden. Auch wenn Biden gesprochen hat, die Rede war so... Aber ich glaube nicht, also ich glaube, dass es da schon jetzt am Ehrgefühl auch ein bisschen kratzt, wenn die das so machen. Neuseeland jedenfalls, ja auch da entsprechend wichtig, hat sofort sich geäußert, also Jacinda Arden und hat gesagt, ja, das könnt ihr da alles machen, aber nicht mit uns. Also durch unsere Hoheitsgewässer könnt ihr da nicht mitfahren, mit so einem Atom-U-Boot. Ich möchte gleich hinzufügen, es ist kein U-Boot, das Atombomben an Bord hat, das Atombomben abfeuern kann. Das gibt es natürlich auch, und sowas haben die Amerikaner auch. Aber es geht hier um den Atomantrieb. Der Vorteil ist, dass diese U-Boote länger unter Wasser bleiben können. Sie sind leiser und sie können auch wohl schlechter geortet werden. Und sind also moderner. Jedoch ist man generell, was Atomen angeht, nicht gut da bei Neuseeland drauf zu sprechen. Und deswegen entsprechende Reaktionen.
Die Anker dieser Anlage sind nukleare Submarine.
Sie können nicht in unsere internen Wälder kommen.
Man will nicht, dass sie auf dem Grundraum liegen.
Genau.
Weil üblicherweise gehen die nicht im Krieg kaputt, sondern gehen einfach kaputt und dann liegen sie da.
Und man will sich auch aus diesen Schamützeln wohl raushalten. Und da gibt es einen breiten Konsens in New Zealand und das wird nicht passieren. Nun haben die Herrschaften, die das ausgehandelt haben, es natürlich auch vorgestellt, also Biden, dann Premierminister Morrison von Australien und Boris Johnson. Und wir hören uns jetzt nichts Groß von Biden an. Er hält dann eine recht pathetische Rede, wie toll dieses Abkommen ist und was man da jetzt alles in Zukunft machen könnte. Und er nennt da China nicht. Das macht man dann nur, wenn man wieder intern irgendwo Interviews gibt. Aber für diese offizielle Konferenz hat man sich wohl darauf geeinigt, dass man jetzt nicht nochmal den Feind beim Namen nennt. Aber Biden fällt dann am Ende seiner Rede noch ein. Ach ja, wir haben ja auch noch da andere Verbündete, die jetzt nicht zu AUKUS gehören. Also AUKUS setzt sich zusammen aus Australien, UK und US. Aber es gibt ja grundsätzlich auch noch andere Verbündete. Ja, irgendwo da in so einem Nebensatz nochmal ja. Und Europa gibt es ja auch noch. Aber wir könnten da auch noch mal fragen, Nato, ja, gibt es, aber für die gibt es inzwischen schon ganz andere Fragen. Insofern werden die wahrscheinlich lächelnd sich das ansehen, wenn hier so eine NATO-fixierte Wahlkampfveranstaltung stattfindet und man immer noch glaubt, dass man damit jetzt überhaupt wen erreicht. Also sicher ist ja, dass die jetzt in diesen Trabi gestiegen sind, in Zwickau, oder die sich das angesehen haben, nicht zu Hause auf der Couch sitzen und nachdenken. Was wird eigentlich mit der NATO sein?
Ja, ich meine, NATO, das N-A in NATO steht für North Atlantic. Und so langsam kommt man hier in Zugzwang, Sachen zu erklären. Denn Australien und Europa, ja bei Europa ergibt das irgendwie Sinn. Das ist eigentlich fast Pflicht, das zu nennen. Weil wir liegen am Nordatlantik, aber Australien nicht.
Moulson betont die gemeinsamen Werte. Das kennen wir dann immer irgendwie aufgerüstet wird. Dann geht es eigentlich um Werte. Ja, also nochmal auch deutlich gesagt, wogegen sie da eigentlich kämpfen. Und das ist dann nett umschifft, dass es sich um China handelt. Aber auch das ist ja ganz klar, dass es hier in erster Linie um Wirtschaftswege geht. Denn man weiß, dass dieser Bereich wird sicherlich der wichtigste für den Welthandel werden. Oder ist es jetzt eigentlich heute schon fast. Insofern ist ganz entscheidend, wer da die Hoheit über die Gewässer hat und wer da durch kann und nicht. Und wenn da irgendwas blockiert ist, dann sind hier die Regale leer.
Genau. Jetzt gerade, wir lesen im Salon so einen Text vom Economist dazu, geht es ja drunter und drüber in Lieferwegen auf See. Die Container sind, obwohl sie immer unter 2000 Euro zum Beispiel lagen, um von China an die Westküste in Amerika zu fahren, plötzlich 10.000, 20.000 Euro teuer. Also Faktor 5, Faktor 10 hat man über Jahre nicht gesehen, dieses Phänomen. Und die Zahlen sind ja wirklich beeindruckend. Es sind zwar nur ein Viertel der Güter, die über Seeweg transportiert werden, aber drei Fünftel des Wertes. Und in deren Sicht ist das, was da aus China kommt, ziemlich wertvoll. Und das, was wir aus Deutschland sehen, Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer hat ja auch ein Schiff losgeschickt, ohne Bewaffnung, um in diesen Meeren da so ein bisschen mitzupatrullieren. Keiner weiß genau, was das da soll. Aber sie hat ja in dieses quasi Mandat, das sie ausgegeben hat, den Schutz der Lieferketten eindeutig mitgenannt. Also so wie damals, als er zurückgetreten ist, der Bundespräsident für solche Sprüche. Köhler, genau. Also in der Ansicht wirklich erstaunlich. Die Amerikaner gehen damit auch ganz offen um. Also die sitzen vorm Kongress, Leute und Milly und sagen, ja, also klar, da geht es um amerikanische Interessen, Lieferketten und alles Mögliche. Da sagt man lieber noch, es geht um Lieferketten, als irgendwann mal China zu nennen. Also da ist man aber ganz direkt.
Jaja, man ist auf jeden Fall nicht so sehr mehr darauf fixiert, die ganze Zeit, also wie das in Deutschland ganz stark gemacht wird. Im Übrigen ja auch von den Grünen immer ganz stark gemacht wird, dass man immer diese Werte und Demokratie und so. Das ist nicht die Frage, sonst würde man auch nicht mit Indien entsprechend umgehen. Das ist ja auch erstaunlich gewesen, dass Indien in diesem ganzen Wahlprogramm gar nicht vorkam. Obwohl man da ja eigentlich auch was zu sagen müsste, wie denn diese Kooperation ansehen würde. Ich fand es auch interessant, bei den Grünen gibt es ja ganz viele Länder, die einzeln aufgelistet werden. Da ist dann Indien gar nicht dabei, wo ich denke, dann verliert er noch ein paar Zeilen dazu. Boris Johnson äußert sich dann im Unterhaus dazu und macht das noch mal seinen Briten schmackhaft, was er da tolles eingefädelt hat.
While our partnership will begin with nuclear-power submarines, now that we have created AUKUS, we expect to accelerate the development of other advanced defence systems, including in cyber, artificial intelligence, quantum computing and undersea capabilities.
Immer wieder hat er auch erwähnt, hunderte neue Jobs. Und ich denke mir, Java, was sind hunderte neue Jobs? Das ist ja lächerlich.
Für Boris Johnson ist das ja ein großer Segen. Er sollte ja eigentlich gerade erklären, warum der NHS jetzt doch Geld braucht. Und zwar durch Steuererhöhungen. Man kommt wohl nicht drum herum, nachdem man doch so eindringlich gesagt hat, wir müssen aus der EU aussteigen, damit die 350 Millionen, die wir pro Woche nach Brüssel schicken, in den NHS fließen können. Und da kam er jetzt drum rum. Es war genau dieser Termin, als alle Journalisten, was? Steuererhöhung. Und dann war plötzlich diese Pressekonferenz mit Biden. Und dann konnte er im Parlament schön dieses Thema hervorholen.
Und auch noch mal hier die Werte.
Wir haben auch einen geschlossenen Interesse in die Promotion der Demokratie, der Menschenrechte, der Freiheit der Navigation und der Freiheit der Handel um die Welt.
Das sagt jetzt jemand, der fast einen Operettenstaat aus seinem eigenen Land gegründet hat. Der verteidigt jetzt die Demokratie da irgendwo anders. Das ist verrückt. Nun kommt der Labor-Chef, Keir Starmer, und erstaunlicherweise begrüßt der dieses Abkommen auch, hat aber dann so ein paar Fragen später.
And China's assertiveness does pose risks to UK interests in a secure Pacific region, in stable trading environments and in democracy and human rights. We need to deal with those risks, defend our values and defend our interests.
Also Wirtschaft ist dann ein Thema, wir können das ja nicht abkappen. Also Großbritannien kann jedenfalls kein Decoupling machen in der Weise, dass die jetzt ganz für sich sind. Das funktioniert ja schon bei den kleinsten Dingen nicht. Da geht es gar nicht. Also am Weltmarkt muss man teilnehmen, muss auch mit China kooperieren. Und dann bringt er ja als zweites Argument noch, naja, und dann gibt es ja auch gemeinsame Probleme, die zu lösen sind und die können wir nicht konfligierend eigentlich lösen, sondern das geht nur mit einer gewissen Partnerschaft.
Also Kirste Armer als Labor-Chef und Nachfolger von Jeremy Corbyn, selbst den wünscht man sich wieder zurück unter Labor-Anhängern auf der Straße. Heute Morgen wieder lustige Clips gesehen von Anna Katharina, die ja da lebt und mich immer mal versorgt mit irgendwelchen Sachen. Es ist wirklich absurd. Man kann hier einfach nur sagen, Kirste Armer, das ist jetzt so eine naive deutsche Sicht auf die englischen Verhältnisse, aber Kirste Armer kommt so wenig vor in den Medien, ist so unterbelichtet, dass er sich seine Konflikte nicht aussuchen kann. Ja, weshalb er bei solchen Sachen einfach kurz sagt, alles klar. Hauptsache, wenn wir, also wenn ich Konflikt mit Boris Johnson, da habe ich nur einen Schuss frei im Monat, alles andere wird übersehen. Da muss ich auf die Innenpolitik gehen, weil für den Rest interessiert sich niemand. Und da kommt dann sowas bei rum.
Ganz genau. Antonio Guterres hat gesprochen bei der UN-Generalversammlung.
Die es auch noch gab, die wir nicht mitbekommen in Deutschland.
Die gar nicht rezipiert wurde. Ich habe die Rede angesehen, sehr toll. Er macht da einen Sechs-Punkte-Plan und sagt, was da eigentlich jetzt diese großen Fragen sind. Und er sagt, es ist Klima, es ist Ungleichheit, es geht auch um die Impfgerechtigkeit. Und er bringt mehrere Punkte und er sagte aber als ersten Punkt Frieden. Und das sei die Voraussetzung auch für alles andere. Und er stellt dann jetzt mal so ein bisschen eine Frage in den Raum, wo man auch sagen kann, ja das ist jetzt auch schon bezogen auf hier AUKUS.
Geopolitische Bedingungen sind die internationale Kooperation untergebrochen und die Fähigkeit des Sicherheitskonsulums zu schützen, die notwendigen Entscheidungen zu nehmen.
Also jetzt der Systemwertstreit China USA kommt zu einem sehr ungünstigen Zeitpunkt angesichts der Probleme und jetzt gehen wir noch mal zurück ins Unterhaus. Kias Dahmer ist dann, nachdem er das jetzt alles sehr begrüßt hat und sehr staatsmännisch aufgetreten ist, auch noch mal zu einer Frage bereit. Er fragt jetzt Johnson, ja, aber gefährdet das denn jetzt unsere tolle Beziehung zur NATO? Und formuliert das so?
Sie ist auch der erfolgreichste.
Ja, sie sind hin und her gerissen. Das ist ja das Letzte, was Global Britain noch an Europa hält, dass man nämlich zumindest in Militärfragen gemeinsame Sache macht. Und auch da jetzt, nach dieser wirtschaftlichen Entkopplung, auch da jetzt eine politische Entkopplung, nur um so einen Medien-Stunt zu machen, um von NHS-Steuererhöhungen abzulenken und so weiter, ging dann auch ihm ein bisschen weit. Das ist wirklich wahnsinnig verrückt.
Und dass das jetzt von den Labors eingefordert wird, wie ist denn das mit der NATO, das bringt dann auch unseren Boris Johnson zum Lachen.
Es ist ein Freude, den Gehirn der Nato zu hören.
Ja, Korbbein wollte auch aus der Nato eigentlich raus. Also ganz wie die Linken hier. Und jetzt wird das begrüßt, dass es da eine Kehrtwende gibt. Also wir sehen, wie instrikat das Verhältnis zur Nato ist, und zwar in allen Ländern. Und wie brüchig da alles geworden ist. Insofern, glaube ich, müsste man zumindest jetzt mal, wenn man die Nato als Konstrukt weiter verteidigen will, mal ganz klar diese Mängel aufführen und sich einfach mal auch so Narrativen lösen, die irgendwie noch so mit rübergenommen worden sind aus den 90er Jahren, aus den 0er Jahren und mal im 21. Jahrhundert ankommen. Und das wäre eigentlich auch was, was tatsächlich dann journalistisch geleistet werden müsste in solchen Triellen und Schlussrunden, dass man dann sagt, ja, aber es ist doch folgendermaßen so und so. Da können wir doch jetzt nicht einfach nur so sagen, ja, und die Nato, wie das dann jetzt noch so passiert, weil man mal vor 25 Jahren in irgendeinem amerikanischen Think-Tank so ein Fellowship-Ding hatte oder irgendwas. Also das ist immer so erstaunlich, dass man dann irgendwie da so stecken bleibt. Also offenbar ist das auch für Politiker sehr schwierig, wie für alle Menschen, dass man so mit Mitte 40 oder Anfang 50 nochmal neu über etwas nachdenkt. Also dass man gerne so das, was man gelernt hat, oder was man besonders in so einer prägenden Phase wie nach Abitur bis hin zum dritten, vierten Berufsjahr dann, was man da so gelernt hat. Und man war dann vielleicht mal an der amerikanischen Uni und hatte auch mal eine tolle Vorlesung besucht, dass man dann jetzt nochmal irgendwie versucht, da anders drauf zu blicken. Denn die machen das ja. Also das ist ja genau das, was Biden eben macht. Der unterscheidet sich ja deutlich auch von einem George W. Bush oder Bill Clinton, wie der über NATO und Partnerschaft nachgedacht hat.
Genau, es ist auf jeden Fall Programm, wobei ja George W. Bush damals den ersten NATO-Bündnisfall, von dem wir heute wissen, wie er sich entfaltet hat. Also vom 11. September über die bedingungslose Solidarität bis zum Afghanistan-Fall jetzt. Wir gehen mal kurz diese Nachrichten-Clips hier noch durch, weil das ist wirklich, wie soll man sagen, ein bisschen amüsant, das mal so im O-Ton zu hören. Zum einen diese Nachrichtenmeinung Global Britain, die wir aus Deutschland mitbekommen und die auch so weit stimmt. England hat sich ökonomisch komplett von uns entkoppelt. Und eigentlich ist diese militärische Zusammenarbeit der letzte Brückenschlag, den man noch hatte nach Europa.
Der britische Verteidigungsminister wurde heute kurzerhand von militärischen Konsultationen in Paris ausgeladen. Es ist eine nie dagewesene Krise zwischen den beiden europäischen Atommächten, mit ausnahmsweise Großbritannien am längeren Hebel.
Ich glaube, dass sich Großbritannien ganz geschickt positioniert hat, weil im Bereich Sicherheits- und Verteidigungspolitik Großbritannien sehr viele Fähigkeiten hat, auf die die EU-Europäer auch schauen. Der Drang, mit Großbritannien zusammenzuarbeiten, ist weiterhin groß, auch trotz des Brexit.
Je nach Lage will Global Britain neue Bündnisse schließen oder alte ausbauen. Beim Handel funktioniert das Rosinenpicken bislang nicht. Kein Grund ist in der Verteidigung nicht weiter zu versuchen.
So, und genau da kam jetzt das von Kirs Dahme auch angemerkte, naja, bei die NATO und so, wird es uns da wirklich einseitig auf die Seite Amerikas drängen. Biden schwieg ja dazu Maaßen. Und da sieht man wieder, wie schlecht, also was für ein schlechter Außenminister Maaßen ist. Maaßen hat dann, Maaß, Maaß, richtig, Maaß. Heiko Maaß, der Peter Altmaier, der ja seinen Bundestags-Directmandat geklottet hat, ist im Grunde bei so Wortspielen zu lassen.
Zuletzt hatte Bidens Kurs beim Afghanistan-Abzug wie auch beim Atombot-Deal für Wirbel gesorgt, bei vielen Verbündeten. Australien hatte letzte Woche ein milliardenschweres U-Boot-Geschäft mit Frankreich platzen lassen. Und möchte nun, zum Ärger von Präsident Macron, amerikanische Atom-U-Boote anschaffen. In seiner Rede erwähnte Biden den Streit mit Frankreich nicht einmal das Verhältnis sehr großartig. Das sehen die Franzosen ganz anders und bekommen Unterstützung von den Europäern.
Ich kann den Ärger unserer französischen Freundinnen und Freunde gut verstehen.
Dass was dort entschieden worden ist und die Art und Weise, diese Entscheidung zusammen zustande gekommen ist, ist irritierend und es ist ernüchternd, nicht nur für Frankreich.
Irritierend und ernüchternd, nicht nur für Frankreich, sondern auch für uns. Dieses auf Twitter zu schreiben, ist befremdlich. Ein Wort, das man sonst nie benutzt und in diesem Kontext dann irgendwas bedeuten soll. Ja, er ist jetzt irritiert. Na gut, ist halt der Deutsche immer wieder irritiert. Glaubt aber wieder, wir machen das mal übers Hinterzimmer und so weiter.
Aber ich glaube, dem sind wir ja auf jeden Fall los, oder? Ich glaube, Heiko Maas wird jetzt nicht noch mal Außenminister werden.
Das war ja nur, um Gabriel auszudrängen. Auch weil der Außenminister, der nicht Gabriel war damals.
Das wird sicherlich dann jemand von den Grünen machen, wenn es denn die Ampel gibt.
Auch da wird man neue Ideen haben. In Frankreich eben im Original ist es wirklich erstaunlich. Da zeigt man sich eben nicht nur irritiert, sondern...
Es war auch so, dass während der Rede von Präsident Biden nicht mal der Botschafter anwesend war, schon gar nicht der Außenminister, der ja hier in New York ist. Also die Botschaft ist schon klar, Frankreich sieht sich typiert, die Atommacht schmollt und lässt das jetzt wirklich jeden wissen, ganz ohne Zweifel. Man ist eben ernüchtert und irritiert, wie es der deutsche Außenminister gesagt hat. Aber Le Drian, der französische Außenminister, sagte auch, er würde sich gar nicht erst mit seinem Kollegen, dem amerikanischen Außenminister Blinken, treffen. Man würde sich möglicherweise unter Umständen mal auf dem Korridor begegnen. Und davor hat er ja auch noch gesagt, also Biden, und das war ganz schon eine Beleidigung, sei wie Trump ohne Tweets.
Ja, also das war jetzt ein Zitat des Außenministers in Frankreich. Na, wer weiß, wie weit er das irgendwie mit wem auch immer abgesprochen hatte. In dieser Veranstaltung bei der UN, na, das war ganz interessant, sieht man hier mal Biden in seiner Rede, wie er sozusagen nicht so groß dazu reden will, was jetzt gerade tagesaktuell passiert, sondern diesen Schwenk der NATO zum Pazifik, wo ich mir denke, nee, das braucht dann echt einen neuen Namen oder so. Ja, man kann da jetzt nicht den North Atlantic, den 3D da irgendwie umwidmen. Er versucht es und Ursula von der Leyen Antwort fand ich gar nicht schlecht.
Anstatt die Kriege der Vergangenheit zu führen, werden wir unsere Augen auf die Schlüsselfragen richten, die unsere gemeinsame Zukunft bestimmen werden. Die Pandemie beenden, die Klimakrise angehen, die Veränderung der globalen Machtverhältnisse zu managen und die Regeln der Welt zu formen in Handels, Cyber und Technologie-Fragen. Und er machte deutlich, in welcher Region in Zukunft Amerikas Prioritäten liegen. Während die Vereinigten Staaten ihren Fokus verschieben auf die Regionen, wie den Indo-Pazifischen Raum, die besonders wichtig sind heute und in der Zukunft, werden wir das mit unseren Verbündeten tun. Er wolle sich dabei eng mit NATO und Europäischer Union abstimmen, sagte er. Doch dort ist man nach dem Abzug aus Afghanistan und dem hinter Frankreichs Rücken eingefädelten U-Boot-Deal mit Australien nicht besonders gut auf den US-Präsidenten zu sprechen. Gestern Abend schon machte die EU-Kommissionspräsidentin in New York ihrer Zerknirschung Luft. Einer unserer Mitgliedsstaaten wurde auf eine Weise behandelt, die nicht akzeptabel ist. Wir wollen wissen, was und warum es passiert ist, bevor wir weitermachen können, wie bisher.
Also ich finde es schon auffällig, dass sich doch alle öffentlich äußern dazu. Und uns suggerieren, sie reden gerade nicht miteinander, irgendwelche Termine werden abgesagt. Denn so richtig komme ich nicht umhin, hier Elmar Thewesen doch ernster zu nehmen. Also das, was er sagt, wenn er hier kurz diese Einschätzung gibt.
Und nun sind Biden und auch sein Außenminister Blinken ja eigentlich sehr, sehr erfahrene Außenpolitiker. Da drängt sich der Verdacht ein Stück weit auf, dass dieser ganze Lärm Absicht ist, um ein wirklich klares Signal nach China zu senden. Man meint es ernst. Und auch, um die Europäer wach zu rütteln, dass sie selber mehr tun müssen in ihrer eigenen Region, Stichwort Russland. Und dass sie sich entscheiden müssen, wo sie denn stehen in der Auseinandersetzung mit China.
Hier gibt es ja zwei Profite einzustreichen. Also das klares Signal gegen China und dann aber auch den Europäern zu zeigen, ja, also Nato könne demnächst wirklich das NA streichen. Es geht nicht mehr um Nordatlantik. Ihr seid dann entweder auf euch selbst gestellt oder ihr macht irgendwie mit. Jetzt muss man sich entscheiden. In Deutschland war Wahlkampf, wir waren alle abgelenkt, deswegen war das nirgendwo Thema. Und als es dieses Triennium mit Wolfgang Ischinger gab, vor drei Monaten oder so, war es eben noch nicht so weit, so was zu thematisieren.
Und diese europäische Zweigleitsigkeit ist für Amerika ein großes Problem und ich glaube, dass Europa gar nicht umhin kommt mit China zusammenzuweiten, im Übrigen auch Frankreich nicht. Also ich habe es ja eben mit den Luxusmarken genannt. Wem gehören alle Luxusmarken? Frankreich natürlich. Also das ist Bernard Arnault, das ist Kering und das sind noch ein paar Eigenständige. China reist nach Frankreich, das ist ganz entscheidend für den Tourismus. Also diese ganzen Dinge, also Frankreich könnte nicht sagen, wir machen nicht mehr mit China. Also vielleicht nicht ganz so stark jetzt wie die deutsche Industrie, aber auch da ist eine so hohe Vernetzung da, dass man eigentlich nur nach so einem zweigleisigen Modell gucken kann, während jetzt die USA das offenbar nicht vorhaben. Mit Großbritannien wird man sehen, weil die auch da andere Abhängigkeiten haben. Also das ist glaube ich auch so eine Sache, dass das verkannt wird, dass Amerika da auch nochmal ganz eigene Interessen hat, die nicht dann unsere Interessen sind, weil die eine andere Form haben des Unabhängigkeitsmachens. Also die müssen jetzt nicht vielleicht dann mit China so stark arbeiten, auch wenn sich da dann die Frage stellt, ob sie das dann alleine hinbekommen. Denn da ist ja auch schon viel abgewandert. Also man war ja auch auf China angewiesen. Aber wenn, dann noch Amerika, aber sicherlich nicht Deutschland.
Amerika organisiert sich ja ein bisschen neu. Auch Apple wird ja immer weniger abhängig davon, dass iPhones jetzt in China gebaut werden. Wir hören uns zum Abschluss diesen kleinen Spruch von Xi an. Der hat ja nur eine Videobotschaft geschickt. Man fährt ja wegen der Pandemie nicht mehr bis dahin. Macht sich es also einfach. Er hat dabei diesen kleinen Spruch hier losgelassen.
Jüngste Entwicklungen auf der internationalen Bühne zeigen wieder einmal, dass militärisches Eingreifen von außen, sogenannte Demokratisierungsprozesse, nichts außer Leiden bringen.
Während sich China selbst gerade, die Taliban und so weiter, da unter den Nagel reißt und man jetzt die drei Billionen Bodenschätze holen will, gibt da noch mal einen mit und sagt, diese sogenannten Demokratisierungsprozesse funktionieren ja nie. Und man muss sagen, ja, das stimmt. Funktionieren irgendwie nie so richtig. Jedenfalls nicht so wie geplant, sofern man überhaupt über die Zielsetzung sich mal im Klaren war. Wir sind in Amerika und gucken uns mal kurz Facebook an. Das ist ja ganz interessant. Heute Nacht, also unserer Nacht gestern in Amerika, hat das Wall Street Journal die Facebook-Pages veröffentlicht. Facebook hat also in den letzten Wochen so ein Edward Snowden-Moment erfahren. Man hat intern Trainingsmaterialien, eigene Studien und so weiter. Was ist mit Instagram? Was ist mit den Esssüchtigen? Sind wir wirklich beteiligt an Menschenhandel? Wie fördern wir das, wo es unsere Schuld zu finden? Und wie auch immer hat man sich intern Fragen gestellt und auch beantwortet. Und diese Papers wurden geleakt und wurden im Wall Street Journal bislang nur journalistisch aufgearbeitet, aber noch nicht im Original veröffentlicht.
Ich musste aber gleich an unser Buch denken, das wir im Salongerät gelesen haben. Da ging es ja darum, dass immer mehr Mitarbeiter plötzlich Zugang hatten zu den empfindlichen Daten. Und man sich dann wunderte, wie das eigentlich sein kann. Und dann sagte man, wir haben ja mal hier mit 100 Leuten gestartet. Und plötzlich waren es dann ein paar tausend. Und da frage ich mich auch bei diesen Papers, die da entstanden sind, hatten da vielleicht auch sehr, sehr viele Leute dann doch Zugang. Und so ist dann ein Leak auch gar nicht so schwer.
Genau, die Einschätzung teilen auch Caras Wischer und Scott Galloway. Man weiß es einfach nicht, aber sie spekulieren ja auch viel in ihrem Podcast. Das machen sie hier bei dem Thema auch.
Der erste ist Mark Zuckerberg, der zweite ist Sheryl Sandberg.
Wenn die beiden sich umsetzen, und sie werden nur unter dem Schaden steigen, wie ich denke, die Wolfe, die sich um Kriminalverbrechen umgehen, denke ich, dass die Firma die Potenzial hat.
Caris Swisher klingt ein bisschen anders als sonst. Sie ist erkältet. Aber das ist, was hier passiert, nachdem Scott Galloway sagt, da müsste es eigentlich mal einen Aufstand intern geben gegen die Führung. Und ja, diese Leaks sind wahrscheinlich so ein interner Aufstand. Irgendwer hat gedacht, ey, jetzt reicht es mir jetzt. Gebe ich das mal raus. Und die zentrale Einschätzung von Caris Swisher ist eigentlich diese hier.
That meme, and it's so deep within Facebook, trust me, it is. And if they think it's a PR problem, we have a real problem with Facebook. And by the way, my greatest worry is it's gonna work.
Ja, 900 Leute arbeiten in der PR dort. Also doppelt so viel wie im Bundespresseamt. Und das Problem ist das Produkt selbst. Also Facebook selbst ist das Problem. Jede PR dazu ist einfach nur über Tünchen. Eine Sachlage wurde dann doch diskutiert, zumindest da in diesem Tech-Podcast und bei Casey Newton, den haben wir hier auch schon häufiger angesprochen, dass einfach jetzt, wo die Veröffentlichung oder die Berichterstattung zu diesen geleakten Dokumenten da ist, dass dann Facebook einfach sagt, okay, liebe Forscher auf der Welt, hier habt ihr sie von uns. Das ist jetzt unser Angebot an. Das hat Facebook allerdings nicht gemacht, sondern jetzt hat das Wall Street Journal, die heute Nacht selber veröffentlicht. Und man muss noch dazu sagen, es gibt einen sehr ausführlichen Text in der New York Times, wie Facebook die letzten Monate und Wochen verhindert hat, dass es überhaupt Forschung mit Facebook geben kann. Also man hat selbst in irgendwelchen Metadaten noch mal so Garbage-Code untergebracht, um einfach auch so flächendeckende, wir laden jetzt mal Facebook runter, um uns da so Muster erkennen und so weiter. Das ist nicht mehr möglich von außen. Also nicht nur hat Facebook institutionell einfach gesagt, ne, wir veröffentlichen hier nichts von intern, sondern sie haben auch den technischen Zugang so schwer gemacht, dass, also es ist wirklich eine dramatische Chronik, die die New York Times da aufgearbeitet hat. Es ist genau das Gegenteil von dem, was sich Casey Newton da so wünscht und Carole Swisher da auch beipflichtet. Und deswegen hören wir mal kurz in diesen Podcast rein. Also die Facebook Papers wurden vom Wall Street Journal als Text aufgearbeitet, aber sie haben das auch in ihrem Podcast gemacht. Bisher sind vier Ausgaben erschienen zum Thema und sie haben noch mehr angekündigt, ist aber bis jetzt noch nichts weiter gekommen. Die Essenz zu den Materialien ist glaube ich kurz zu fassen.
Die Dokumente haben Namen, wie das Verständnis der Intersektion zwischen kriminellen Organisationen und Menschenverkauf, Project Daisy Launch Discussion, die die Version Mark ausgesucht hat.
Martin Ferenzen, der in Deutschland den Social Media Watch-Blog macht, hat heute schon mal eingeschaut in die Papers, ich habe sie noch nicht gesehen, und meint, das ist aber gruselig, in welcher Detailschiefe sich Facebook, in welcher Tiefe sich Facebook informiert hat und auch Erkenntnisse, wie junge Mädchen Instagram nutzen und dann ihr Selbstbild verändern. Also wirklich dramatisch.
Und es ist das exakte Gegenteil vom Auftreten.
Genau, genau das Gegenteil.
Der dann sagt, wir haben es nicht gewusst, wir haben nicht ahnen können und wir wollen besser werden.
Genau, wir wollen lernen, besser werden. Und das war ja auch eine von Niklex Antworten, die er schriftlich gegeben hat. Wir sind halt so groß und so. Und das muss man dann auch verstehen. Wir brauchen hier mehr Zeit. Wir sind ja sensibilisiert. Das zeigen wir ja auch durch die Forschung. Wir interessieren uns dafür. Naja, sie wissen, dass sie Schaden verursachen, tun aber wenig dagegen, ist so der Tenor in diesem Podcast. Und das erste Thema, und das ist auch so stellvertretend für vieles, sie haben eine Whitelist. Und verraten sie sich, hey, eine Whitelist, was hat es damit auf sich? Also sie haben diese gigantische Moderation mit 30.000 Leuten, die alles Mögliche raussatieren, darüber auch wieder psychische Probleme kriegen. Da gibt es ja auch diese Besucher von Casey Newton, wo das mal beschrieben wurde, was man zu Gesicht bekommt, wenn man auf Facebook Müll aussatieren muss. Und dann gibt es aber recht viele Accounts, für die gilt das nicht, die werden nicht moderiert. Sie stehen auf einer Whitelist und man fragt sich, warum? Warum gelten für die andere Regeln? Und ja, es gibt halt vogelfreie Accounts.
Das erste Mal, als ich das Dokument sah, war es einfach eine Wow-Situation.
Eine Wo-Situation, als er das sah, ist ein bisschen überproduziert, dieser Podcast. Das hört man hier, das ist so mit Gimlet zusammen gemacht und so. Aber egal, also diese Whitelist, wie kam es dazu? Es gab zu viele Sperrungen und Facebook musste dieses Problem umgehen, weil man auch immer wieder Influencer weggesperrt hatte.
Ja, im Netz sind nicht alle gleich. Das weiß man auch, wenn man bei YouTube ist. Je mehr Abonnenten man hat, wenn man dann über gewisse Marken kommt, hat man auch einen besseren Traum zur YouTuber. Ich habe den nie genutzt, aber ich glaube, dass ich auch jetzt mit 70.000 Abonnenten leichter in Kontakt herstellen kann als jemand, der 10.000 hat. Und dass ich wahrscheinlich auch, wenn ich irgendwas hochladen würde, was nicht so ganz okay ist oder so, dass man mich vielleicht sogar warnen würde, oder dass ich da in Kontakt treten kann. Bei Facebook scheint das dann so richtige Freifahrtscheine zu geben.
Genau, also da gibt es Accounts, die sind einfach kompletto vogelfrei. Und die Frage ist halt, wie es kam dazu. Und sie konnten nicht immer alles checken. Es war zu viel zu beobachten. Also haben sie dann erst mal so ein Shield und so ein Crosscheck. Also sie haben erst mal eine Liste geführt, um zu sagen, wird zwar auch moderiert, aber da gibt es dann noch mal jemanden, der drüberschaut und so und so lange bleibt das dann erst mal stehen. Und dann eskalierte das so ein bisschen zu dieser Whitelist. Also man hat eine Crosscheck-Liste geführt und da haben die Mitarbeiter selbst, alle hatten Zugriff, gesagt, ja der soll mal auf die Liste, weil das nervt immer, jedes Mal kriege ich einen Anrufer, habt ihr den Influencer schon wieder gesperrt und so weiter, dann kommt er einfach in Crosscheck und ist damit vogelfrei. Und dann stellen sie fest, ja da stehen jetzt so viele Leute drauf, wir kriegen nicht mal die Crosscheck-Liste ordentlich moderiert, geschweige denn ganz Facebook. Also da findet sehr viel Overblocking anscheinend statt und dann bei den Crosscheck, also bei den Herausgründerhobenen, bei den Influencern, die dann ins Crosscheck-Programm kommen, kommt man aber auch nicht richtig hinterher. Und dann fragt man sich, wie viele Crosscheck-Accounts gab es denn?
Also wie viele Accounts waren eigentlich vogelfrei?
So, da kann man sich ja fragen, wie viele haben die eigentlich so gepostet? Also wie viel eigentlich Zweck zum moderieren des Zeug gab es denn da so? Und die Inhalte, die nicht, also die von der Moderation gefleckt wurden, als sollte man sich eigentlich mal anschauen, aber online blieben, blieben dann sogar noch in der Promotion drin.
Also man konnte die weiterhin per Geld und so weiter promoten.
Ja, und da kann man sich ja fragen, Wahlkampf und so weiter, politische Werbung, die ja nun über Promotion läuft, die muss dann nur über einen Account kommen, der gesetzt ist, weil was weiß ich, AfD ist eine Bundestagspartei, da hat man nicht einfach irgendwas weg. Also konnte man da einfach kreuz und quer buchen, buchen, buchen. Und jetzt rechnen sie hier, haben sie durchgerechnet. Wie viele Views haben eigentlich Sachen bekommen von prominenten Accounts, die ansonsten hätten wegmoderiert werden müssen?
Posts, die sonst nicht mehr auf den Kurs werden, wenn die Accounts nicht hochprofiliert und über den Crosscheck geschützt werden.
16 Milliarden Kontakte, also sichtbare.
Ich begreife das alles nicht mehr. Wenn man das jetzt mal überträgt auf ein Restaurant, da kommt ja auch das Gesundheitsamt und macht entsprechende Tests. Und ja, da wird man fast überall irgendwas Kleines finden. Oder da wird man noch zugemacht und so weiter. Aber irgendwann ist ja so ein Punkt, wo die sagen, nö, jetzt sperren wir zu. Ja, haben sie halt Pech gehabt. Jetzt ist Schluss. Und das hier sind ja solche Dimensionen, wo man sagen muss, ja, Facebook ist das Problem. Also das Produkt ist das Problem. Eigentlich könnte man sagen, ist das für uns wirtschaftlich relevant? Also bekämen wir ein Problem? Also ich würde sagen, wir bekommen ja in Amerika jetzt schon ein Problem, wenn man ab sofort sagen würde, Amazon ist zu.
Oder Google.
Oder Google ist zu. Aber bei Facebook?
Null.
Würde ich sagen, da würde nichts passieren.
Die Produktivität würde steigern, würde man sagen.
Aber es würde ja nichts passieren. Also das wäre einfach so, wie wenn man jetzt sagen würde, ja, wir machen irgendwie ein Lockdown für irgendwas. Da ist dann auch nicht viel passiert. Also gut, Leute konnten nicht ins Kino gehen oder so. Aber hier könnte man auch sagen, gut, geh nicht auf Facebook, machen dann irgendwas anderes. Ist ja noch genug da am Internet.
Ja, man müsste sich das mal so visualisieren. Facebook ist die Autobahn, auf der wir ins Wahllokal fahren. Und während wir da hinfahren, ist links von uns so ein Gefahrgut-Transporter, der brennt aber hinten schon. Und es ist auch schon ein Reifen geplatzt. Und um noch weiterfahren zu können, zahlt er aber dem Autobahnbetreiber Facebook Geld und darf dann sogar noch schneller fahren in diesem Zustand. Das ist so ungefähr das Bild, das wir hier haben. Und so werden unsere Kaufentscheidungen, unsere soziale Landkarte wird so gestaltet, weil die Leute nutzen Facebook. Und das ist dann der Zustand. Und das ist ja erst mal nur die White List. Das war das erste Thema, was sie aufbereitet haben. Tiefergehend und auch ein bisschen schlimmer ist es bei den mentalen Problemen der Instagram-Nutzer.
And those results suggest that Instagram can have negative effects on many of its millions of young users.
Ja, und das sind jetzt Facebook-eigene Zahlen. Also zu einem Drittel der jungen Mädchen, die eh schon Probleme mit ihrem Körperbild haben, ihrer Selbstwahrnehmung und so weiter, wird das nochmal verschärft.
Und mir leuchtet das absolut ein. Ich kann das ja dann so in einer privaten empirischen Studie auch nachvollziehen. Also ich habe ja für das Buch mit Ole das alles mir angesehen. Und wir haben uns auch mal so Kommentare, gerade bei Influencern angesehen, die tolle Körper haben und die auch vor allem so Fitness-Influencer und so was sind. Und was man da einfach merken kann in diesen Kommentaren ist, dass der Druck sehr hoch ist und dass es diesen Nachahmungseffekt besonders stark gibt, wenn es um Körper geht. Also bei beruflichen Sachen oder so, da kann man ja auch so eine eigene Abstraktionsleistung machen. Naja, der ist jetzt in diesem Beruf erfolgreich. Aber ich mache was anderes und das mache ich ja auch gern, bin da erfolgreich. Aber Körper ist halt einfach, dass man sagen kann, ja, Sixpack sieht so aus, habe ich einen oder nicht? Busen sieht bei ihr so aus, habe ich den oder nicht? Und was muss ich tun, um ihn zu bekommen? Und das ist so ganz direkt gebunden und da ist auch nicht mehr irgendwas dazwischen. Da kann man nicht sagen, ja, aber wohnt ja in Köln. Nee, hat ja damit nichts zu tun. Körper ist Körper dann. Und da war doch deutlich in den Kommentaren zu merken, das setzt junge Leute unter Druck. Und bei manchen war das ziemlich ehrlich auch artikuliert.
Genau. Und da fällt Instagram auch besonders raus, beispielsweise im Verhältnis zu TikTok oder Snapchat. Eine dieser Studien, die intern lief, ist die Teen Girl Body Image. Study. Das ist ja auch nur noch Körpergetanze und es ist sehr sehr körperteil geschuppelt.
Sehr junge Körper, aber schon sehr muskulös oder dann besonders auf sexy gemacht und ich würde auch sagen, dass Instagram ganz klar Körper ist und dass das auch entsprechend so fotografiert wird. Also es ist immer der Körper, also das ist gar nicht davon abzusehen.
Und ich finde es auch wenig verwunderlich, dass die solche Studien machen, denn das kennen wir schon, da konnte ich einen Redaktionsschluss schon drüber schreiben, 2015, dass Facebook natürlich ein Testpublikum hat, wo die qualitativ nachfragen, entweder als Fokusgruppengespräch oder wirklich eins zu eins, wir rufen dich montags an und fragen, wie hast du dich gefühlt, warst du mit deinem Newsfeed zufrieden, schreib uns deine Highlights auf, sag uns, was dich gestört hat. Also da haben die, also mehrere tausend Menschen, die sie da eigentlich schon seit Jahren immer nachfragen und das ist schade, dass jetzt hier wieder so, ach die machen auch qualitative Studien, aber ja, die machen halt auch qualitative Studien mit Fokusgruppen. Hier zum Beispiel die...
Sonst kann man ja auch gar keine Algorithmen vernünftig programmieren. Also das sieht ja jeder, also wenn ich jetzt bei Instagram Fitness eingeben würde, also alles da, Hashtag suche oder so, dann ist ja vollkommen klar, dass der Algorithmus so programmiert ist, dass er weiß, also jemand in meinem Alter aus Deutschland und so weiter will vor allem Weiße sehen und deswegen wird mir auch das angezeigt, selbstverständlich.
Genau, das Prinzip ist, man macht im Grunde, man testet die Variation des Algorithmus. Man kann nicht den Algorithmus so zielgenau programmieren, weil er lernt ja auch viel selbst, aber man bringt dann verschiedene Variationen einfach in Anwendung und dann guckt man, macht man sozusagen Return on Investment und fragt dann einfach nach, wie hat man sich gefühlt und die erfolgreichen Algorithmenmodulationen, die man hat, die bietet man dann einfach allen an. Also sind diese typischen AB-Tests wie bei Google auch. Die wissen dann immer selber nicht, warum ihr Algorithmus jetzt funktioniert, aber die Studien haben gezeigt, das ist der Weg, den wir gehen müssen. Und da haben sie hier Fokusgruppenstudien gemacht zum Thema und so heißen halt die Studien. Teen Mental Health Deep Dive. Das war ihr Projekt.
Sie fangen an, was sie nennen, den Teen Mental Health Deep Dive.
Und welche Fragen haben Facebooks internen Forschern gefragt?
Also zum Beispiel, eine der Dinge, die sie betrachtet haben, war, Teenen von einer Menge von verschiedenen Typen von Gefühlen zu fragen, wie oft diese Gefühle auf Instagram beginnen.
So, hier trickern sich natürlich schon die Zuhörer. Sie haben auch nach Suizidgedanken gefragt und da kamen doch ganz deutliche Zahlen raus. Haben sie selber als Quelle ausgemacht für Suizidgedanken. Und dachten dann aber wieder, das haben wir ja in Inside Facebook gelesen, damit müssen wir doch nicht an die Öffentlichkeit gehen, oder? Während Sheryl Sandberg schon immer mal so Texte bekommt aus der eigenen Forschung, wo es heißt, sollten wir das jetzt der Polizei zeigen, oder behalten wir das für uns beim Thema Wahlen und Wahlmanipulation? Und hier eben genau das Gleiche. Instagram, soziales Netzwerk, verstärkt natürlich auch Einsamkeitsgefühl. Ja, und während man in seinem konkreten sozialen Netzwerk, in dem man hängt, dem Klassenverband, dem Sportverein, wie auch immer, eine begrenzte Vergleichsgröße hat, um seinen eigenen Platz in der Welt zu finden, vergleicht man sich auf Instagram natürlich mit der ganzen Welt und das triggert dann Angst.
Und die Forschers sind klar darüber in den Dokumenten.
Sie kommen dann also intern immer zu diesen Überlegungen, was könnten wir denn jetzt machen? Und jetzt hat man ja oben schon gesagt, ja Snapchat macht so mehr so lustige Gesichter und so, können wir nicht auch da so ein bisschen ausweichen? Das ist natürlich immer die Frage, wie will man den eigenen Feed positionieren für die Werbewirtschaft? Soll das jetzt lustig Tralala sein oder eben so ein seriöses Ding? Hier sind die Erfolgreichen und so weiter. Und dafür hat man sich dann halt entschieden. Es gab allerdings interne Überlegungen, doch mal so ein bisschen auch Abbiegungen zu ermöglichen.
Facebooks Team of Internal Researchers recommended that Instagram expand its tools that encourage users to take breaks, that the app offer more fun filters that are not beautifying and that the app show less fashion and celebrity content.
Diese Berichterstattung zu diesen Mental Problems haben sie so kontrastiert mit so einer Protagonistin. Das haben sie immer gemacht bei jedem Thema. So ein Schicksal, in dem Falle war das so eine junges Mädel, macht Instagram, stellt dann fest, oh, hier muss ich aber ganz schön engaged sein, ist also jeden Tag auf Instagram aktiv. Und stellt dann irgendwann fest, okay, so geht es nicht weiter, wendet sich dann dem Vertrauenslehrer und sagt, ich glaube, ich will mich umbringen, das wird mir alles zu viel und so weiter. Und ihre Lehre am Ende, Anastasias Lehre, ist ganz interessant, weil hier, wie auch schon Clara Swisher sagte, das ist nicht nur PR-Problem, sondern das Produkt selbst ist das Problem, weil sie dann auch zur Erkenntnis kommt, in der ich kann nur ohne Instagram glücklich weiterleben.
Sehr schön, denn wir haben ja einen Paralleldiskurs, einen Verzichtsdiskurs oder einen Transformationsdiskurs beim Klimawandel. Da wird ja dann immer von Boomer oder wie man auch immer gesagt, ne das geht ja nicht. Also wir können jetzt nicht auf Kohle verzichten. Wir können nicht darauf verzichten oder wir können jetzt auch nicht glauben, dass das alles mit Wind und Sonnenenergie und so. Also man möchte eigentlich alles so lassen, vielleicht ein bisschen klimafreundlicher gestalten, aber eigentlich ist nicht möglich. Und einen ähnlichen Diskurs haben wir auch bei den sozialen Medien und wir haben das auch bei dem Influencer-Thema so erfahren, dass man immer so sagte, ja aber wie könnte dann gutes Influencertum aussehen und wie könnte das und das und das, wo wir einfach sagen, ne man braucht ja keine Influencer. Also man kann doch einfach gute Podcasts hören, Nachrichten verfolgen. Warum Influencer? Also einfach weg. Und das ist so erstaunlich, dass wir bei den Boomer so diesen Diskurs haben. Ja ne, also wir können da nicht verzichten drauf. Aber wenn man irgendwas sagt, wie zum Beispiel, wir könnten ja Facebook schließen, dann sagt man, also ne, das ist jetzt aber zu radikal. Und man fragt sich, ja wieso soll das denn so radikal sein? Es ist eine Plattform. Wir haben immer noch unsere Telefonnummern. Wir können weiterhin kommunizieren. Man hat andere Nachrichtendienste und und und. Es gibt gar keinen Grund, nicht auch da mal radikal zu sein und das zu fordern. Vielleicht wäre das auch nochmal so eine Idee. Habe ich auch überlegt, weil es diesen Leidensdruck ja gibt. Und das ist ja nur ein Beispiel von hunderttausenden Millionen, ob nicht da auch nochmal so eine junge Bewegung sich draus entwickeln könnte oder ob man da manche Dinge auch vernetzt.
Also ich sehe hier, also solche Clips wie die eben, kann man ja immer so ambivalent. Zum einen ist es anekdotisch, ist halt ein Schicksal. Ist das generalisierbar? Ich bin aber völlig deiner Meinung, ja das ist generalisierbar. Das betrifft im Grunde alle. Und im Grunde haben wir hier dieses Problem von too big to fail, dass wir diese enorme Abhängigkeit von der Plattform und damit auch dieses Ausgeliefertsein einer Plattform haben. Denn Social Media könnte ja auch bedeuten, dass man Einschränkungen vornimmt. Wir haben ja zum Beispiel Mastadon, dieser Twitter-Alternative, wo so jeder seinen eigenen Server betreiben kann. Dann kann man sich aber über den Server hinweg auch miteinander connecten. Und da gibt es zum Beispiel den Chaos Social, also vom Chaos Computer Club so einen Betriebenen, der war dann halt irgendwann voll. Also da passt halt nur 50.000 Accounts oder so drauf, keine Ahnung. Und so kann man ja künstliche Limitierung, dass es sich wirklich wieder in Segmenten aufsplittet. Sei es regional, sei es hier, es aber hier reden Sportvereine oder so über ihr Schicksal oder hier, das ist so die Tauschbörse für irgendwas. Aber nicht alles auf einer Plattform in einem Feed, also dass man diesen Feed wieder rausnimmt. So könnte man ja auch Facebook organisieren, dass man eben diesen großen Schritt hin zum Newsfeed, der plötzlich alles sichtbar und transparent gemacht hat, dass man den wieder rausnimmt und dann sagt, wie bei Google, wenn du auf die Seite kommst, ist da erstmal gar nichts zu sehen. Du musst ein initiales Engagement zeigen und sei dir dann aber bewusst, die Suchergebnisse, die du siehst, sind deine. Also fang nicht an auf Link Nummer eins zu klicken, nur weil da steht, da haben schon 50.000 andere drauf geklickt. Sondern es ist im Grunde wie bei einer Bundestagswahl vorher keine Wahlumfrage zu machen, damit man sich einfach an den Gewinner dranhängt und denkt, ach der Scholz gewinnt jetzt nicht, der Laschet, dann wähle ich halt den Scholz. Hauptsache ich habe einen Kanzler mitgewählt, am Sonntagabend. Dass man diese Prinzipien alle mal rausnimmt.
Diese Umfragen zumindest mal.
Ja, also da wäre es auch dringend.
Drei Monate vor der Wahl zu verbieten. Dann wäre ich auch mal gespannt, was man dann in Berlin sonst so schreiben könnte.
Genau, dass man sich wirklich mal überraschen lässt und die Leute wirklich mal an Inhalten orientiert lässt und nicht an diesen Zahlen. Eins der Themen, ja das dritte, das ist wirklich atemberaubend. Ich hatte in dieser Dimension nicht im Blick. Es geht tatsächlich um Sklaverei. So, Human Trafficking. Was ist hier gemeint? Ein Fall, den sie vorstellen, ist eine junge Kenianerin sieht auf Facebook eine Anzeige für einen Job in Dubai. Nimmt ihn an, fliegt dahin, stellt dann fest, ach so, die nehmen mir erstmal meinen Reisepass weg und mein Arbeitstag hat 20 Stunden und ich darf auch das Haus nicht verlassen.
Krass.
So, also hängt sie da einfach ein halbes Jahr drin, mittellos, kann die Sprache nicht, es ist völlig verloren und muss halt so Hausdienertätigkeiten machen. Schreibt dann aber auf Facebook, ihr könnt mir mein Geld schicken, ich muss hier wieder nach Hause fliegen, worauf sehr viele darauf aufmerksam werden, ne, welcher Situation bist du eigentlich gerade? Und dann stellt sich raus, ja, sehr viele sind in dieser Situation. Also, irgendwelche Agenturen machen Fake-Werbung, versprechen den falschen Job auf der Plattform und locken damit einfach junge Frauen, die dann sich selber gar nicht helfen können in solche Situationen. Und Facebook hat nie unterbunden, dass es diese Werbung gibt. Also, dass da einfach irgendwelche Agenturen irgendwas in Dubai versprechen und halt sagen, und so, da nie nachgearbeitet, was findet dann statt, nachdem die da Kontakten miteinander aufgenommen haben und so. Bis, und das ist wirklich erstaunlich, bis Apple plötzlich auf den Plan trat.
Das heißt, was die Politik gar nicht mehr im Blick hat, das machen jetzt schon die Konzerne.
Genau. Es ist ein globales Problem. In Kenia fand man sich nicht zuständig, in Dubai auch nicht. Man will ja nicht diesen Art Dienstleistungssektor, den man als Staat selber betreibt, plötzlich privat da unterbinden. Also in deren Sicht war hier für niemanden Hilfe, außer Apple. Die haben einfach gesagt, also hört mal zu, wir schmeißen eure Apps raus. Wir haben gesehen, die Apps sind nicht rausgeflogen, also wurde Facebook dann auch mal tätig. Und in diesem Fall die Kenianerin, die als Protagonistin mit dabei war, hat dann auch noch mal betont am Ende, ja, also Facebook hat eigentlich die Pflicht, weil sie organisiert sich da jetzt auch und sagt, das muss sein, hat eigentlich die Pflicht, jede Werbung zu verifizieren. So wie bei Wahlwerbung das mittlerweile. Dass man nicht mehr einfach in Rubel irgendeinen Scheiß auf Facebook und ist, sondern dass man jetzt klar erkennt, das ist Wahlwerbung, das wird erstens archiviert und zweitens begutachtet. Und das müsste bei Jobs eigentlich genauso sein, wird aber bis heute nicht gemacht, also wirklich gruselig.
Und dann wird ja wahrscheinlich auch jetzt mal von dieser Sklaverei abgesehen, mit Prostitutionen und so, in entsprechenden, also da wahrscheinlich wird man noch so viel finden, wenn man da mal nachgeht, was da noch so alles passiert.
Es ist alles Facebook. Es sind ja auch, früher gab es ja diese Craigslist in der Marketplace und so. Und da gab es Aufarbeitung, dass der Marketplace jetzt eine Milliarde Nutzer hat, wo Leute einfach mit sich irgendwas verhökern. Aber nach keinen Regeln und irgendwie. Also das Drogenumschlag, Platz und alles. Also ohne, dass sich jemand zuständig fühlt oder überhaupt weiß, wie gigantisch groß der Facebook-Marketplace größer ist als Ebay. Das ist einfach, das weiß man halt nicht. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Als nächstes gucken wir uns hier noch kurz das Horrorjahr an. 2017 hat Facebook eine interessante Beobachtung gemacht. Wir können alle drüber nachdenken. 2017 klingelt da irgendwas bei uns? So, wie kann das sein? 2017 kam plötzlich das Engagement runter. Klar, Donald Trump ist gewählt. Der Wahlkampf ist erstmal vorbei. So, und jetzt denkt man so, okay, wir haben ja gelesen in Inside Facebook, wie durcheinander das bei Facebook alles war, dass sie irgendwelche russischen Hacker zu den, Zitat, wichtigsten Redakteuren der Nachrichtenwelt einfach mal hochgejesst haben und so, durch diese Erfolge, die da gefeiert werden konnten. Und ja, 2017 war dann halt so ein Teil der Tränen für Facebook. Plötzlich kein Trump mehr, also klar immer noch Trump, aber nicht mehr so dieser große Wahlkampf-Hype. Und man hat sich irgendwie mit Videos vergaloppiert. Ja, alle waren nur noch zurückgelehnt. Leanback Medium, Facebook war das neue Fernsehen. Keiner wollte mehr irgendwas teilen oder irgendwo Engagement zeigen und so. Und die Werbebranche hat so gedacht, wenn man Fernsehen buchen wollte, dann buchen wir halt Fernsehen. Aber machen das nicht bei euch. Also führt Facebook die Meaningful Social Interactions ein. So, ziemlich catchy. Wie genau wurde das gestaltet? Wie folgt? Also es wurde gepostet und dann wurde nach einem Punktesystem der Post auf- oder abgewertet. Also ein like ein Punkt, ein share fünf Punkte und ein signifikanter Kommentar. Wahrscheinlich mehrere Absätze und irgendwie viele Substantive. 30 Punkte. Also eine krasse Überbewertung von Kommentaren unter Posts. Also wenn eine Diskussion losging, konnte man den Post so richtig dadurch promoten.
Was man ja weiß. Das hat man wahrscheinlich am eigenen Leib schon erfahren bei Facebook. Wenn dann ein Post kommt und da gibt es einfach nur zehn Likes, dann wird auch nichts mehr passieren. Aber wenn da anfangs zwei schon mal durchdrehen da unten und einem eigentlich erklären, dass man das völlig falsch sieht oder so, dann geht es richtig ab. Und wenn man dann, ich gucke ja Facebook so gut wie nie nach, also das ist so einmal am Tag, gucke ich, ob da irgendwas reingekommen ist oder so. Aber eigentlich ist das für mich nicht relevant. Wenn man aber dann den Tag später das Ganze nochmal anklickt, dann sieht man, ach so, da sind jetzt 87 neue Kommentare.
Genau, dann werden alle Freunde, Freunde darauf aufmerksam gemacht, dass es ein Post, wo heiß diskutiert wird, diskutiert auch mal mit.
Ja, das ist ja bei TikTok übrigens anders. Also da haben wir das ja beim Wall Street Journal auch gehabt. Die haben das ja nach vollzogen. Da sind es nicht die Kommentare und eigentlich auch nicht die Likes. Da ist vor allem der Algorithmus getriggert, wenn es lange sich angesehen wird. Also das heißt, das, was sich viele ansehen, das ist das Seeverhalten. Und das spült dann auch entsprechend nach oben.
Genau, das klappt bei TikTok super gut, weil man da in Zehntelsekunden nachmessen kann, wie lange nicht weiter gescrollt wird oder wie oft sich im Loop das angeguckt wird. Das hat ja Facebook auch immer versucht, aber so richtig aussagekräftig war es dann doch nicht. So Mausrad und so weiter, weil die Leute sind aus Gründen, dann machen irgendwas anderes oder so. Und dann kommt das alles durcheinander. Na ja, man hat jetzt hier ein System geschaffen, bei dem alle irgendwie mit irgendwelchen Posts beschäftigt waren, um mit irgendwem im Internet zu widersprechen, weil mal wieder jemand falsch lag. Entsprechend sind die Ergebnisse dann auch gewesen. Engagement ging hoch, aber die Laune ging runter. Das hat dann zu Effekten geführt, dass man so mitgekriegt hat in den Nachrichtenredaktionen nach Donald Trumps Wahl. Ach so, das zieht jetzt bei Facebook. Na gut, dann machen wir jetzt mal diesen Scheiß, also irgendwelchen diskussionswütigen Blödsinn. Da hat daraufhin der Buzzfeed CEO mal bei Facebook angerufen.
Jonah Peretti, der CEO von Buzzfeed, hat eine E-Mail zu einem hochgrössenden Facebook-Exekutiven gesagt, dass MSI eigentlich bewegend war, dass das Ding, das theoretisch für eine zwingende soziale Interaktion gegründet wurde, keine zwingende soziale Interaktion gegründet hat und in der Tat die Publisher wie Buzzfeed und andere, um die schlimmsten, toxicsten.
Der Buzzfeed-Chef sagt, also hört mal zu, ihr fördert gerade nur den Müll. Wir sind selber nicht glücklich damit, wenn wir nur diesen Blödsinn, den wir hier schreiben. Wenn ihr den nehmt, dann nehmt mal unsere großen Recherches, Stories, die man einfach nur so liest und so. Man hat sich also für dieses Muster entschieden bei Facebook, weil Engagement hoch und mit der guten Laune könnte man ja noch nacharbeiten. Man hat dann Vorschläge gemacht an Facebook, es anders zu machen, intern. Das sind ja alles interne Sachen. Hier blickt man noch mal in eine so eine interne Diskussion. So, Max Zuckerberg hat also gesehen, naja, wir können ja nicht pauschal jetzt diese Engagement-Treiber zurücknehmen, weil wir würden ja dann auch die positiven Sachen wieder rausnehmen. Die dürfen also nicht in Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden. Und die gingen dann so weit intern vorzuschlagen, lass uns doch den Reshare-Button rausnehmen. Die Chefetage, die nur noch gelacht hat darüber und jetzt kann man ja überlegen, diese Story steckt jetzt hier so nicht drin, aber wir müssen jetzt nur eins und eins zusammenzählen. Man hat nach 2017 festgestellt, Engagement geht in die Bachrunde, wir müssen jetzt diese persönlichen Geschichten, wo jemand meinungsstark, dann wird ihm widersprochen und so weiter und so fort. Dann plätschert das so dahin, man versucht so an kleinen Stellschrauben das zu machen. Und dann kommt aber Pandemie und wir haben plötzlich so Themen wie Impfung.
Wo man eine Meinung zu haben hat.
Genau, wo genau so promotet wird, Facebook intern. Und wir hatten ja die Sachlage, dass Facebook diesen Bericht, welche Texte waren eigentlich im Januar, Februar, März 2021 im ersten Quartal am erfolgreichsten zurückgehalten hat. Und dann später raus kam, ja, das war alles Impf-Lügerei. Die erfolgreichsten Posts, die zehn erfolgreichsten Posts von Facebook waren, hatten alle irgendwie mit Lügen über Impfung zu tun. Und da haben die Leute wild drunter diskutiert. Deswegen wurde das dann von dem Algorithmus da hochgespült. Und mittlerweile fragt man sich, was soll denn jetzt noch passieren? Ja, Trump, Pandemie, jedes Mal dasselbe und wir haben absolut keine Lösung dafür. Und in diesem New York Times Text wurde aufgedröselt oder auch zitiert von Facebook. Die Strategie für Mark Zuckerberg ist öffentlich auftreten, aber nicht über die Krisen und Probleme reden, sondern nur über die eigenen Produkte. Und wie das geschieht, ist unglaublich. Das ist also hier auch aus dem September 2021. Mark Zuckerberg ist im Fernsehen und redet dort über das Internet.
Das wird auch schon Ready Player One eingespielt.
Oder Tron oder so.
Mich macht diese Frisur so fertig, aber ich sag das jedes Mal.
Er ist halt ein Bot. Ich glaube, er spielt einfach mit der Idee, dass er als Bot missgedeutet wird. Hier mal ein Anwendungsfall fürs Metaverse. Alle fragen sich jetzt, hey Metaverse, wovon reden die schon wieder?
Es ist ein Virtual Reality Service, um zusammen zu arbeiten und zusammenzuarbeiten.
Das ist eine Teil der Vision, die wir hier haben.
Ich verstehe das nicht. Was soll das jetzt sein?
Jeder sitzt bei sich zu Hause und setzt eine Brille auf, eine Virtual-Reality-Brille, und kriegt dann dort simuliert, dass er in einem Raum mit anderen ist. Nun hat man aber den Nachteil, anders als bei einer Videokonferenz, man hat ja eine Brille auf, man kann also nicht gefilmt werden. Also werden alle anderen Teilnehmer als Avataren nachgebaut in dieser Situation. Du bist also die ganze Zeit in so einem Paw Patrol, Netflix, Kinderfernsehen, alles ist gezeichnet Setting, während du nach Mark Zuckerbergs Logik dort der Arbeit nachgehst. Denn das ist die neue Veröffentlichung Workplaces. Du hast dann verschiedene Konferenzsituationen, Präsentationssituationen.
Ich bewege mich aber quasi als eine Comicfigur.
Genau, du bist nur als Comicfigur sichtbar für die anderen, und die anderen siehst du auch nur als Comicfigur.
Und der versucht jetzt eigentlich schon im Real Life so auszusehen.
Die Comicfigur.
Das ist schon so eine Anpassung. Das ist ja sowieso so ein interessanter Effekt, dass es gar nicht immer darum geht, können die Computer irgendwann so intelligent sein, wie wir Menschen, sondern vielmehr haben wir so eine gewisse Entwicklung, können wir selbst bald so doof sein, wie die Computer.
Ja, genau, es ist so eine schöne Singularität, die hier stattfindet. Wir finden jetzt alle in diesem Metaverse statt. Er führt es vor. Und die sitzen jetzt quasi in so einer dreifarben gezeichneten 2D-Kinder-Trick.
Genau, wir sehen jetzt also Marc als Comicfigur und er sieht plötzlich so menschlich aus.
Ich mag sie hier. Das ist mein erstes Virtual Reality Interview.
Das ist auch mein erstes Virtual Reality Interview.
Aber sag mal, das ist ja jetzt CBS, was wir hier sehen und hören. Machen die da einfach so eine Verkaufsshow?
Das ist ja unglaublich. Es ist CBS This Morning, also eine Nachrichtensendung, aber es ist absolut einfach nur so ein Verkaufsverhökagespräch.
Also das wäre jetzt, wenn, weiß ich nicht.
Es ändert auch seinen Charakter nicht. Das ist...
Und das ist ein langsamer Projekt.
Wir müssen das jetzt nochmal deutlich machen. Also da sind jetzt eine Moderatorin und Mark Zuckerberg und die haben jetzt diese Brillen auf, unterhalten sich weiter, weil sie aber getrennt voneinander sitzen. Also er war jetzt vorher nur zugeschaltet und jetzt ist es so, dass sie in einem Raum gemeinsam sind, in einem Zeichentrickraum und sind dort Zeichentrickfiguren. Und jetzt erklärt er, dass das schöner ist, weil man jetzt so ein Raumgefühl bekommt.
Man sieht zwar nicht mal, mit wem man da ist.
Das ist wirklich Idiotie und ich bin schockiert darüber, wie diese Sendung ist. Gerade, wo man ja auch nicht seit gestern erst weiß, was Facebook alles macht. Also das wäre, wie wenn Klaus Kleber heute Abend mit einem Diesel-SUV ins Studio reinfährt und sagt, ja hier und ich habe ja noch den Vorstand vom VW dabei und jetzt reden wir mal, das ist ein wahnsinns Produkt hier.
Über den neuen EU7 Diesel oder so. Ja, es ist wirklich crazy. Ich finde auch, wenn man mal mit einem großen iPad Facetime gemacht hat, ist das hier so ein Müll dagegen, weil da verliert man dann wirklich mal Raum und Zeit und denkt man ist so miteinander im Gespräch, aber das ist einfach dumm. Google hat ja auch so Versuche gemacht über Hologramme, so dass man sich am Tisch wie gegenüber sitzt und die Kamera ist dann hinter dem Hologramm, so dass man sich in die Augen guckt und den ganzen Kram. Das ist alles Müll finde ich, das ist alles durch Schrott und das ist besonders Schrott.
Wir haben ja hier Podcasts aus Lockdown-Gründen auch immer mal wieder nur per Kamera machen müssen. Das ist nicht so schön, wie sich gegenüber zu sitzen, aber es ist ja durchaus machbar. Und ich würde auch nochmal ganz stark machen, weil das jetzt gerade auch so ein bisschen verloren gegangen ist durch die Pandemie. Man kann auch nochmal telefonieren. Also jetzt bekommt man ja immer irgendwelche Zoom-Calls vorgeschlagen, auch wenn man nur fünf Minuten was handeln will und dann denke ich, wir können auch einfach mal telefonieren. Und ehrlich gesagt habe ich ja sehr intensive Bekanntschaften und Freundschaften auch, die sehr stark über das Telefon funktionieren, weil wir uns selten sehen können. Und da geht es aber auch nicht darum, dass wir nochmal vor der Webcam winken und wir wollen uns auch nicht als Comicfiguren begegnen, sondern da reicht auch oft die Stimme und der Erfolg von Podcasts zeigt es ja auch, dass die Stimme ein Träger von Bedeutung, von Nähe und all das ist.
Wir haben ja das Buch von dem ehemaligen Spotify-Manager gelesen, der ja auch meinte, bei Podcasts hat man wieder die Intimität gefunden, die man vorher mit der Musikindustrie verloren hat im Kontakt mit dem Publikum. Und ich meine, ich stelle dir vor, wir würden diesen Podcast hier fünf Stunden lang wirken wir uns so als Avatare, wo wir uns vorher das Avatar zusammenklicken.
Und auch noch alle, die uns hören, können uns dann auch als Comicfiguren sehen.
Was für ein Quatsch, ja.
Aber die sehen wir dann aus, frage ich mich auch gerade.
Wer verkauft das hier als, ja, man hat dann ein Gefühl für Raum und diesen Raum kann man dann noch die ganze Zeit immer hin und her ändern.
Das ist ziemlich nett.
Ja, wir sehen jetzt Mark Zuckerberg ohne Beine als Comicfigur stehen und auf ein Whiteboard etwas schreiben. Und das ist auch so ein Quatsch. Und da würde ich auch jetzt noch mal ganz stark machen, die eigene Erfahrung, die man ja so gerade macht, wenn man wieder am öffentlichen Leben teilnimmt. Niemand möchte sich in solchen Comic-Situationen auf Dauer befinden, sondern was jetzt, glaube ich, passiert ist, dass man da, wo man pragmatisch einfach sagt, da brauchen wir kein Treffen, wir telefonieren oder zoomen, das wird bleiben. Aber man erlebt gerade, dass die körperliche Nähe etwas ist, auf das man nicht verzichten möchte. Und das ist gerade in Restaurants und Bars zu erleben, dass Menschen wieder dicht zueinander rücken und wieder einen richtigen Austausch pflegen und dass da alles, was wichtig ist, stattfindet. Und das ist überhaupt nicht herzustellen mit diesem Kram. Also das ist für mich eher so was, das ist mal für so einen lustigen Tag an der Schule, da kann oder wenn man mal einen Ausflug macht, dann war man vorher auch schon mal in irgendeinem Museum. Und dann hat man mit so ein bisschen moderner Museumspädagogik da noch mal so ein paar Spirenzchen gemacht.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist während das Wall Street Journal die Facebook-Pages veröffentlicht, ist das Nicklex Antwort. Mark Zuckerberg geht in die Öffentlichkeit und redet über Produkte. Und 800 Menschen in der PR-Abteilung führen dann eben auch zu sowas.
Ich sagte, du hattest das in der Mittelschule gedacht. Wir hatten keine Cellphones.
Was erzählen die denn da? Ihr saßt in der Schule und dann geht man auseinander und dann wäre das doch schön, wenn man immer zusammen wäre. Ja, da muss man sich halt treffen.
Ja, also es ist so, dieses verrückte, das kann man so im Fernsehen erzählen. Und dann später eine Fokusgruppe der Zuschauer, da empfinden wir bestimmt daraus, die fanden das auch irgendwie faszinierend. Aber diejenigen, die darüber entscheiden, also sowohl jetzt so diese Journalisten vom Ranges, also jetzt nicht Journalist, aber Scott Galloway, aber dann auch Carers-Wisher, die ja auch diese ganzen Konferenzen, jetzt die Code-Konferenz macht und so weiter. Und die Mitarbeiter der Kongresseabgeordneten, die sich nicht nochmal vorführen lassen wollen von Facebook, die sehen das und werden wütender. Also das ist so durchschaubar und so dumm, dass man da echt irgendwie denkt, ey Leute, das jetzt aber mal halblang.
Ja, und vielleicht geht man auch schon mal auseinander, weil man sich jetzt gerade nicht sehen will und verabredet sich am Abend, weil man sich dann wieder sehen will. Sehr, sehr wahnsinnig. Und man ist schon fast gewillt, China zu loben, weil die wenigstens mal durchgreifen. Wir werden jetzt das auch nochmal betrachten, was passiert da eigentlich in China. Da wird enorm viel reguliert. Zum Beispiel ging es darum, dass man Lieferdienste jetzt dazu anhielt, entsprechend zu bezahlen und auch bessere Arbeitszeiten zu machen. Dann gibt es ja immer noch dieses 996-Modell dort in China, was eigentlich schon verboten war, also dass man von 9 Uhr bis 9 Uhr arbeitet. Und zwar sechs Tage die Woche, als wir das Schönstenbuch hatten, war das nochmal der Thema. Da soll auch härter jetzt durchgegriffen werden. China hat eigentlich eine 40-Stunden-Woche, regulär werden so 43, 44 Stunden gearbeitet. Aber auch da ist jetzt schon das Thema Arbeitszeitverkürzung. Offenbar kann man sich das auch leisten. Und diese Tech-Konzerne werden massiv angegriffen, sodass die Tech-Aktien gerade richtig im Keller sind. China will also da ein Exempel oder mehrere Examples statuieren. Und wir hören erstmal von Bloomberg, was die über die Videospielregulierung sagen.
Wir reden nur um eine Stunde von Spielzeit für Kinder, während der Wochen, zwei Stunden, während der Wege und die Ferien.
Eine ganz deutliche Reduzierung. Also es darf dann nur noch ein paar Stunden gegamed werden, gespielt werden die Woche. Jetzt fragt man sich, wie will man das umsetzen? Das erklärt die ARD.
Die Umsetzung der Regeln ist in China technisch relativ einfach. Den Spieler müssen sich mit den Daten ihrer Personalausweise anmelden. Tencent versucht außerdem mit Gesichtserkennungstechnologie zu verhindern, dass junge Spielerinnen und Spieler nachts die Accounts ihrer Eltern nutzen, um Verbote und Sperren zu umgehen. Die Behörden kündigten außerdem an, die Gaming-Konzerne künftig stärker zu überprüfen.
Mal sehen, zu welchen Ausweichbewegungen das noch führt. Das sind ja hier Einladungen für Hackereien und Spielereien, die wahrscheinlich sehr dankend angenommen werden.
In der Tat. Bloomberg spricht über dieses Thema. Und da wird noch mal darauf hingewiesen, wie das erstmal lanciert wurde, diese Anti-Gaming-Kampagne.
Now Beijing saying through the economic information daily, which is a state owned media, that as you said, those very strong words, electronic drugs, opium, saying that you cannot, an industry should prosper by eradicating an entire generation.
Opium, elektronische Drogen, zum einen könnte man jetzt Marxistisch an Opium fürs Volk denken oder Opium des Volkes, je nachdem Marx oder Lenin welche Variante man gerne hätte. Ich glaube aber, wir sollten bei Opium wirklich an Opium denken, also an den Opium-Krieg auch. China ist ja auf einem unglaublichen Kurs gewesen. Es war eine Weltmacht ja im 18. Jahrhundert und man hatte ja extreme Möglichkeiten zu exportieren, weil man Seide und all das hatte. Und man konnte das sehr gut zum Beispiel den Engländern verkaufen. Und die Engländer haben ja, um diese Macht auszuhebeln, dann Opium reingeschmuggelt. Und dann gab es ja eine millionenfache Opium-Abhängigkeit in der ersten Hälfte des 19. Jahrhunderts. Und dann gab es ja mehrere Opium-Kriege. Und die sind immer für China schlecht ausgegangen, sodass China dann zu einem der ärmsten Länder überhaupt wurde innerhalb von wenigen Jahrzehnten. Und was jetzt hier, glaube ich, noch mal deutlich gemacht wird, wenn man von Opium spricht, man hat es ja nachher so ein bisschen zurückgezogen, aber ich meine, das Wort ist da mal gefallen, ist wirklich, das ist jetzt so eine neue Abhängigkeit, die kann uns dauerhaft um unseren Wohlstand bringen. Und man will, glaube ich, hier schon noch mal ermahnen, denn diese Geschichte ist das Präsente überhaupt in der chinesischen Identität. Noch mal deutlich machen, wir müssen jetzt aufpassen, dass das nicht wieder so wie beim Opiumkrieg damals wird.
Ja, also das ist eine sehr interessante, ja stimmt, da steckt ja auch so diese Kolonialisierung von außen und so weiter drin. Da wären sicher auch, also Indien haben wir auch schon besprochen, wie das da war, aber auch Australien jetzt, die haben ja auch Facebook da hart angenommen. Aber ich dachte auch so ein bisschen an Japan. In Japan lässt ja die Regierung so ganz bewusst irgendwie diesen Technologie-Sektor einfach alles erobern. Die Menschen sollen arbeiten und dann nicht weiter groß auffallen. Und du hast ja da Bildschirmzeiten, die sprengen ja jedes Maß. Also die haben ja unglaublich viel gespielt. Die Japaner geben bis heute zehnmal mehr für Mobile Games aus als Deutsche in U-Bahn. Alle haben ihre Smartphones da und so. Und da lässt die Regierung das einfach laufen und es erinnert so ein bisschen an die russische Strategie im Umgang mit Alkohol. Auch wenn nichts mehr im Supermarkt verfügbar ist, Alkohol muss da sein, um das Volk ruhig zu halten. Also da hat man auch so eine Art Obium fürs Volk, um den Spruch da nochmal zu bringen.
Ja, wir hören jetzt mal weiter. Wall Street Journal hat sich auch damit beschäftigt und hat uns mal ein bisschen aufgedröselt. Tencent ist ja ganz wichtig für Gaming. Und die haben eine erstaunliche Entwicklung hingelegt.
Tencent hat die Welt des Videogames mit einem der größten Namen in der Industrie, die League of Legends, gemacht. Aber bevor du dir das vorstellt, musst du zuerst verstehen, dass es keine Videogame-Kompanie war. Serkan Toto ist ein independenter Videogame-Industrie-Konsultant in Japan, und er hat seit.
Tencent hat sich also erst in diese Richtung entwickelt. Das ist gar nicht so bedeutsam gewesen, dieser gelbe Flieger.
Als League of Legend auch von denen, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Die sind damit investiert. Und das ist überhaupt das Erstaunliche, dass die so stark im Ausland investiert sind. Und da gibt es auch hier eine Idee, wie das jetzt mit Tencent weitergehen wird, wenn man im Inland mit Gaming nicht mehr so viel erreichen kann. Und das wird ja sehr interessant sein, während wir jetzt schon darüber gesprochen haben, es gibt diese Dual-Circulation-Geschichte, dass jetzt China sagt, wir machen das jetzt mal für uns und unsere Binnenwirtschaft ist groß genug. Aber die haben ja Konzerne. Und diese Konzerne, da stellt sich die Frage, wird es das ermöglichen, dieses chinesische System, dass die Konzerne außerhalb von China dann vielleicht sogar ihre Hauptgeschäfte machen, solange das Geld dann wieder irgendwie zurückfließt? Oder werden die sagen, nee, dann nicht? Also haben wir dann so eine Doppelstruktur. Und dann ist natürlich auch die Frage, inwieweit die KP weiterhin die Hand auf diese Konzerne hat. Denn wenn im Ausland der Konzern so wichtig ist, dann ist er vielleicht gar nicht mehr so abhängig von Peking. Und das wird also so ein Konflikt sein, den wir eigentlich hier schon gelöst haben. Also hier haben die Konzerne sich einfach ziemlich losgemacht von der staatlichen Souveränität. Jetzt versuchen wir, das zurückzuholen. Aber hier kann sein, dass es wieder so eine eigene Bestrebung gibt. Deswegen weiß ich gar nicht, ob das jetzt volkswirtschaftlich dann so sinnvoll ist, Daten sind in dieser Weise zu beschneiden. Das fragt man sich, ja.
Ja, also Hongkong wurde ja immer wieder als für China wichtig betont, weil das so der Finanzierungsspot für die Unternehmen ist. Aber einmal in Hongkong ansässig, bist halt auch so ein bisschen außen vor. Ja, wenn du jetzt ein Spieleunternehmen bist, das im Ausland gut verkauft, aber intern nicht mehr darf, bist du, glaube ich, irgendwann weg. Also ob dann, das ist ja auch alles ein virtuelles Business. Da ist ja echt entscheidend, wo machst du dein Laptop auf, um das weiterzuentwickeln. Da ist ja der Umzug relativ zügig geschehen und damit dann auch der Werttransfer. Also ob man das dann so halten kann. Wer weiß, aber mit WeChat und so ist ja das weiterhin krass verankert. So, im Plenum zumindest.
Was ich erstaunlich fand, ist, dass es einen Post gab in den sozialen Medien in China von Chen Li. Der ist Finanzdienstleister bei Suchhoff. Und dieser Analyst im Neuen Deutschland gab es dazu einen Artikel, der behauptet, dass man jetzt eigentlich vom US-amerikanischen Weg abrücken sollte. Jetzt kann man sich fragen, waren die da so richtig drauf? Aber zumindest sieht er das so. Und er empfiehlt in diesem Post, und der wurde wohl millionenfach rezipiert, den deutschen Weg einzuschlagen. Und da fragt man sich ein bisschen, was ist damit gemeint. Und zwar dieses Industrie 4.0 und auch so eine wohlfahrtsstaatliche Absicherung, wie wir sie hier haben. Das empfiehlt er jetzt China und sieht das auch so ein bisschen dann verwirklicht in diesem Modell, dass man sich jetzt darauf konzentriert, in der eigenen Wirtschaft stark zu sein. Beziehungsweise er sieht es auch darin, dass man jetzt stärker reguliert, dass man auch Geldstrafen fängt, dass man mehr Rechtsstaatlichkeit für die Wirtschaftsräume hat. Und die sehen das tatsächlich als eine Adaption des deutschen Wegs. Das finde ich auch nochmal sehr erstaunlich, dass man da...
Interessant, wie man immer wieder beobachtet wird, während man selber denkt, die Deutschen kriegen ja gar nichts hin.
Ja, ja, ja, ja. Und wahrscheinlich haben wir ja mit so einer Deutschland AG, die wir früher hatten, so einen Staatskapitalismus, der auch sehr reguliert war und eng an die Politik gebunden war. Und deswegen liegt es vielleicht nahe, da nochmal so einen Deutschlandbezug herzustellen. Und zeigt aber auch, dass wir dann da im Ausland sehr angesehen sind. Und dass die eher damit auch noch locken können, wenn man sagt, wir orientieren uns mal an dem deutschen Modell. Aber kommen wir nochmal zu dem Gaming zurück. Natürlich spielt Zensur eine große Rolle. Es gibt den YouTube-Kanal Every Game a Story von Elias, von den Rocket Beans. Und der hat ein Video jetzt gemacht zur Zensur in China. Und erstmal bringt er uns aber mal Zahlen, wie wichtig eigentlich die Gaming-Industrie ist.
Denn nirgendwo auf der Welt wird mit Videospielen so viel Geld verdient wie in China. Allein in diesem Jahr haben circa 328 Millionen Menschen in China am PC gespielt. Der chinesische PC-Markt wird damit in diesem Jahr für fast 14 Milliarden Dollar Umsatz sorgen. Zum Vergleich, der gesamte Gaming-Markt in den USA verzeichnete 2018 einen Umsatz von 35 Milliarden Dollar. Das ist fast die Hälfte nur mit dem PC. Wenn wir jetzt noch Smartphone-Gaming dazuzielen, wird es nur noch verrückt. Dann kommen nochmal 700 Millionen Menschen dazu und ein Umsatz von 32, 7 Milliarden Dollar.
Kurzum fast alle spielen. Konsolen waren, habe ich dann in dem Video erfahren von Elias, Konsolen waren eine Zeit lang verboten in China. Und dann gab es aber Internet-Cafés und da hat man dort gezockt. Und da begann es eigentlich mit diesem Free-to-play, dass das Spiel eigentlich nichts kostet, dass man aber zahlen muss, um irgendwelche Dinge zu machen. Und inzwischen ist das ja flächendeckend so. Und da ist man sich fast sicher, dass da aus China oder aus irgendeinem asiatischen Land jedenfalls das richtig losging. Also da hat man das eigentlich dann entwickelt und hier übernommen. Was wird aber jetzt zensiert? Und das ist jetzt ein bisschen obskur.
Beispielsweise jegliche Form von Necromantie nicht toleriert. Das bedeutet, dass selbst Skelette oder Blutpfützen komplett entfernt oder in abgeschwächter Form dargestellt werden müssen. Realistische Gewalt ist auch nicht erwünscht. Bei PUBG Mobile fallen abgeschossene Gegner in China, deshalb nicht einfach um, sondern winken zum Abschied. Ja, also das deckt sich nicht mit der Forschung. Das ist keine evidenzbasierte Politik, denn wie schon bei den Krimis ist das einfach nur sozusagen attraktiv zu sehen, weil es so weit weg von der eigenen Realität ist. Und es führt einen aber auch nicht dahinten. Man läuft dann nicht plötzlich auf die Straße und ist geweiltätig, nur weil man sich irgendwie ein digitales Blut oder so gewöhnt hat. Also das ist so ein ganz grob, aber das ist ja vielleicht auch dieser deutsche Weg. Die Killerspiel-Diskussion hat man ja in Deutschland genauso irre geführt.
Ja, diese irrsinnige Diskussion könnte man doch mit unserem Protagonisten von damals noch mal dahin bringen. Da können die noch mal eine kleine Karriere in China machen. Ja, es wird natürlich auch aus politischen Gründen zensiert. Auch da wird es absurd.
Selbst auf den ersten Blick harmlose Spiele wie Animal Crossing können Opfer dieser Zensur sein. Das Spiel wurde im letzten Jahr von der Protestbewegung in Hongkong genutzt, um prodemokratische Äußerungen zu verbreiten. Der Titel wurde daraufhin aus dem chinesischen Onlinehandel genommen. Es geht aber noch krasser. Den Kollegen von GamesIndustry erzählte ein Indie-Entwickler aus Hongkong, dass dieser die Farbe Gelb in seinem Spiel nicht benutzen kann. Die Vermutung liegt nahe, dass diese Entscheidung mit der Umbrella-Movement zusammenhängt. Eine weitere Protestbewegung in Hongkong, für die die Farbe Gelb als Symbol gilt. Also wenn man als Staat Krieg gegen die eigene Bevölkerung führt, dann sucht man sich am liebsten das Gaming-Thema und kommt dann mit so einem Blödsinn um die Ecke. Weil dann sind die Fronten geklärt.
Ich bin auch immer wieder erstaunt, dass man glaubt, mit so kultureller Zensur relativ viel zu erreichen. Also wenn man noch eines feststellen kann, dann waren es eigentlich immer diese popkulturellen Ausprägungen, die Begehrlichkeiten geweckt haben in der DDR, Rockmusik und, und, und. Also wir können das jetzt für…
Zensiert, zack, Top 1.
Ja, wir können das jetzt alles nachfragen. Es gibt ja auch, wir hatten das schon mal im Salon, diesen Kampf jetzt gegen die koreanische Popmusik, BTS. Das ist jetzt auch so etwas und ich würde da ganz die Finger vorn lassen, also wenn ich jetzt ein autoritäres Regime lenken müsste.
Ja, man versteht das einfach nicht.
Das ist nicht besonders klug und zu glauben, dass der Einfluss darüber so da ist, dass man glaube ich in anderer Form regulieren muss und dass da sicherlich auch Screening-Zeiten sind, die einfach zu hoch sind. Das ist mit Sicherheit so. Also ich glaube schon, dass es ein großes Problem gibt, dass sehr viele junge Leute zu viel Zeit vor dem Computer hängen, um irgendwelche Spiele zu spielen. Aber ich glaube, das ist nicht so.
Es ist das klassische Problem, dass die da zu viel davor hängen, ist ein soziales Problem. Dafür gibt es keine technische Lösung. Da muss man den harten Weg der Pädagogik gehen und ein anderes Angebot machen. Ansonsten einfach nur durch Reglementierung. Das führt zu so Widerständen. Also da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, was es nächstes Jahr für Blüten mit sich bringt.
Noch eine andere Möglichkeit, um Prozesse zu verlangsamen, ist jetzt folgender.
Das noch größere Problem ist aber die Bürokratie. Videospiele werden in China super strikt reguliert. So strikt, dass offizielle Freigabestellen sich irgendwann nicht mehr einig waren, wie konkret reguliert werden sollte. Diese Unstimmigkeiten sorgten 2018 für einen übergreifenden Freigabestopp. Für insgesamt neun Monate wurde kein neues Spiel für den chinesischen Markt zugelassen. Tencent, mittlerweile der größte Videospielpublisher der Welt, hat zum Zeitpunkt des Stops fast die Hälfte seines Wertes verloren. Das waren 200 Milliarden Dollar.
Es ist ein Kräftemessen, das hier stattfindet. Und die KP will hier ganz klar die Oberhand behalten. Was für ausländische Investoren jetzt ein Problem ist, denn man dachte, man hat doch da diesen riesen Wachstumsmarkt. Und gerade bei Tencent, da gab es doch die tollsten Versprechungen. Was also jetzt Goldman Sachs haben dann im Podcast auch mal gesagt, ja, man muss halt den Blick ein bisschen weiten. Ja, möglicherweise kann da dann Indien wieder von profitieren, wenn die nicht auch wieder strenger regulieren. Jedenfalls hat ja China nicht nur jetzt das Ansinnen, jungen Leuten die Spielfreude zu nehmen, sondern man möchte ja einen gemeinsamen Wohlstand erreichen. Das ist etwas, was Xi jetzt nochmal sehr, sehr häufig wiederholt hat. Das war von Anfang an für ihn ein wichtiges Thema, aber das wird jetzt doch sehr präsent und man macht jetzt auch schon so Musterbeispiele mal auf. Wie könnte das sein? Also es gibt beispielsweise die Provinz Zhejiang und dort möchte man bis 2025 gemeinsamen Wohlstand erreichen und hat da auch sehr ambitionierte Ziele. Da sagt man, da müssen dann 80 Prozent der Leute dort in dieser Provinz dem Mittelstand angehören. Das heißt also man verdient dann zwischen 13.000 und 65.000 Euro. Das ist das Ziel und dann versucht man das durch Regulierungen, aber auch durch neue Planungen zu erreichen, wie Stadtwirtschaft und so weiter aussehen soll. Plus Umverteilung, das ist ja ein großes Thema jetzt. Man will Geld von den Milliardären haben, von den Großkonzernen und noch sind es freiwillige Spenden und Alibaba und Co. haben schon Milliarden gespendet, weil die natürlich große Angst haben. Alibaba hat jetzt auch erst mal das alles begrüßt. Ja, das sei toll, dass die das so regulieren, weil die natürlich noch Jack Ma im vergangenen November vor Augen haben, was da passiert ist. Und jetzt will man also von den Superreichen erst mal über freiwillige Spenden und zwar richtig große Spenden eine Umverteilung schaffen, aber man geht auch davon aus, dass das nicht dabei bleiben wird, also dass man da vermutlich Vermögen extrem besteuern werden müssen, extrem besteuert werden, um so eine Umverteilung herzustellen. Denn die Ungleichheit ist ja rasant gewachsen in China. Also wir haben zwar so eine tolle Entwicklung, dass da viele aus der absoluten Armut herausgehoben wurden, aber die Ungleichheit ist eklatant und das sorgt natürlich dann dafür, dass man nicht dauerhaft sozialen Frieden haben kann.
Ja, das ist immer interessant, in diesen asiatischen Ländern. Man hat das in Südkorea auch mal angedroht. Es gibt ja so viele Reiche. Wir machen jetzt mal eine Herbschaftssteuer. Und plötzlich war dann Samsung bereit, die ganzen Schlupflöcher mal nicht mehr zu nutzen. Und dann gab es irgendwie eine Überweisung von 8, irgendwas Milliarden. Also doppelt so viel wie in Deutschland. Das Gesamtaufkommen, Herbschaftssteuer ist und so. Um sich da so ein bisschen den Kopf frei zu holen, während das Unternehmen da gerade von den 90-Jährigen auf die 70-Jährigen übertragen wird.
Ja, und man versucht auch hier Antitrust-Ideen mal einzubringen.
und Sicherheit-Sicherheit und sie werden auch minimalen Wahlen bezahlen.
Also das Problem, dass wir ja auch bei unseren E-Commerce-Plattformen haben, dass die da irgendwelche Regeln setzen, proprietäre Märkte aufbauen und dann auch nichts mehr machen.
Das Urteil von Apple gegen Epic ist ja da und alle mussten so ein bisschen orakelmäßig deuten, was da jetzt drin stand. Aber Apple hat dann einfach per Pressemitteilung bekannt gegeben, man muss jetzt nicht mehr zwingend alles über den App-Store und 30 Prozent an Apple, sondern da kann man jetzt auch mal so nebenbei. Was jetzt bedeutet, man kann bei Amazon demnächst Kindle-Bücher wahrscheinlich auch in der App kaufen, dann muss nicht erst in den Browser gehen, weil in der App würde das 30 Prozent heißen, im Browser ist es wieder nicht komplett Apple-Ökosystem, sondern Webseite, aber trotzdem auch auf dem Apple-Gerät, also da geht es drunter und drüber und Apple öffnet sich so ein bisschen.
Interessant. Jedenfalls werden also da einige Schritte getan und man kann es ja jetzt fragen, wie ist denn das jetzt? Kann man sich an China orientieren? Jedenfalls stellt sich diese Frage der Doppelgänger- Podcast. Vor ein paar Wochen haben die auch schon über einige Neuerungen in China gesprochen und die sagen folgendes.
Sie haben das zweitgrößte Problem Ungleichheit erkannt und versprechen da jetzt zu handeln. Mehr Verteilung, weniger Superreiche damit erreichen. Dann sollten sie den Konsum damit stärken. Deswegen glaube ich, es wird mehr Luxus und Autos abgesetzt werden in China. Wenn sie das gut machen, dann muss man jetzt erst schauen, wie sie die Ungleichheit bekämpfen wollen. Aber ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass wir, wenn wir in zehn Jahren objektiv zurückschauen, dass wir dann anerkennen müssen, dass China das bessere Wirtschaftssystem hat. Das ist unmöglich, das aufzuwiegen mit den Freiheitsproblemen, also dass du nicht Meinungsfreiheit, religiöse Freiheit etc. in dem Staat hast und unheimlich eingeschränkt bist. Ich möchte auch bisher zumindest immer bitte in der westlichen Demokratie geboren werden und nicht in China. Aber rein wirtschaftlich wird ein Teil der Outperformance, die China meiner Meinung auch weitermachen wird, unter anderem aus den Änderungen kommen, die sie jetzt machen, weil sie Plattformen besser regulieren. Das wird für den sozialen Frieden besser sein, es wird für die Ungleichverteilung von Ressourcen besser sein. Sie werden einen viel noch stärkeren internen oder inländischen Konsum haben und noch mehr Prosperität. Und das Volk wird in der Breite mehr an dem Wirtschaftswachstums teilnehmen als in den USA oder selbst in Deutschland.
Das sagt Philipp Klöckler, der jetzt kein China-Anhänger ist und Investor ist. Das glaube ich nicht.
Die Zufriedenheit hängt immer noch davon ab, wie weit sind deine Pendelwege, wo lebt deine Familie, wo lebst du, was ist deine Arbeitszeit und so weiter. Und da hat China so viel aufzuholen.
Klar, aber jetzt auf das Wirtschaftssystem betrachtet, also dass man tatsächlich doch eigentlich in China einen Staatskapitalismus der autoritären Art erleben kann. Und was wir doch jetzt gerade mit der EU sehen oder was dann auch Joe Biden macht, ist ja, dass man plötzlich sagt, ja gut, dieser Staatskapitalismus ist eigentlich keine schlechte Idee, denn laissez faire funktioniert eigentlich nicht. Und jetzt macht China das auf seine ganz eigene Weise, aber eigentlich haben wir doch schon eine Entwicklung dahin, dass jetzt mehr Staates, also die Rückkehr des Staates, die können wir doch glaube ich jetzt erleben. Da wird es auch sehr interessant, dass wir dann noch mal eine FDP in der Regierung haben, die genau das denn nie wollten. Aber das ist, glaube ich, eine allgemeine Entwicklung. Und die Frage für mich ist jetzt eigentlich, sind wir da in Europa schnell genug? Bleibt das bei solchen pathetischen Reden, wie von der Leyen sie immer mal wieder hält? Oder ist das wirklich so, dass wir in fünf, sechs Jahren da entsprechende Ergebnisse haben? Also dass man sagen kann, ja, wir haben da jetzt Kattelle zerschlagen. Ja, wir haben da jetzt eine Datenhoheit gewonnen. Wird das tatsächlich so sein, dass auch die Ungleichheit zurückgeht? Oder wird das am Ende China sehr gut schaffen und dann sagen sich die Leute da, oder vielleicht sagen sich das gar nicht, ja, wir haben zwar nicht jetzt alle Rechte und Freiheiten, aber zumindest wirtschaftlich hat das dann funktioniert und das würde ja schon reichen, um uns eine wirkliche Konkurrenz zu machen, bei der wir dann sehr alt aussehen.
Wer weiß, die Argumentation geht ja entlang eines Kriterienkatalogs, der die Güte einer Wirtschaft irgendwie ermisst. Ich würde sagen, wir sollten es scharf an der Zufriedenheit der Leute irgendwie ermessen und da kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, dass die Schildesen...
Wir sind ja in einem internationalen Gesamtzusammenhang kapitalistisch, also wir können ja nicht einfach sagen, wir sind jetzt zufrieden, also wahrscheinlich werden jetzt alle zufrieden, wenn sie 2000 Euro gratis so bekommen und dann ist gut oder was, aber wir müssen ja...
Also sein Argumentationsbasis war ja, jemand muss sich entscheiden, will ich jetzt in Europa leben oder in China und würde sich dann für China entscheiden.
Ja, er ja nicht, aber er sagt zumindest so, wie China das jetzt macht und wenn die das wirklich schaffen, die Ungleichheit effektiv zu bekämpfen und die Plattform zu regulieren, dann könnte sich das als ein gutes Wirtschaftssystem herausstellen. Wir hören mal noch eine Argumentation weiter.
Was würdest du jetzt machen, wenn du jetzt hier einen unserer baldigen Bundeskanzlerinnen beraten würdest? Würdest du sagen, wir müssen jetzt hier in den nächsten vier Jahren versuchen, uns unabhängig zu machen von den amerikanischen Plattformen?
Ich würde sagen, wir müssen mehr wie China denken. Natürlich nur, was Wirtschaftspolitik angeht, aber schau mal, diese Builds, die schützen Menschen vor Überschuldung. Die schützen irgendwie Marktteilnehmer vor Predatory Pricing von Plattformen oder falsch abreden Exklusivitätsvereinbarungen von mächtigen Plattformen. Sie sorgen dafür, dass Plattformen genauso viel Steuern bezahlen wie in Anführungsstrichen normale Businesses. Sie schützen Konsumenten und die Wohlfahrt und die Gleichverteilung. Ich glaube, das sind alles Sachen, also wenn wir weniger für die 1% wirtschaften würden und man muss immer überlegen, was sind jetzt gute Wege für Umverteilung. So entweder eine Vermögensabgabe oder gute Basis für die Erbschaft, um die Erbschaftszahle durchzusetzen, effektiv würde glaube ich helfen. Und ich glaube, das würde die Wirtschaft insgesamt kompetitiver machen.
Ja, mal sehen, wir können ja die Geschichte entscheiden lassen. Wir haben ja jedenfalls Joe Biden nach 100 Tagen im Amt vorm Kongress hier schon besprochen, wie er da stand und sagte, im Wettstreit gegen China können wir nur bestehen, wenn wir unsere Familienpolitik neu erfinden, das Arbeitnehmerpotenzial auch wirklich als Arbeitnehmerpotenzial behandelt und nicht nur als Konsumenten. Also so einen produktiven Beitrag erwarten, den aber auch fördern über ordentliche Kinderpolitik, Pflegepolitik und überhaupt deswegen diese ganzen Erfindungen. Das Element der amerikanischen Wirtschaft ist die Familie, daran sind die Eigentumsverhältnisse über das eigene Haus und eben die Motivation zu arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten geknüpft. In deren Sicht haben das ja die Chinesen auch probiert. Dort brechen aber jetzt diese Banken auseinander, es entsteht große Unsicherheit, die Leute reisen immer noch unglaublich viel, sind von ihren Familien getrennt, führen kein sehr zufriedenes Leben. Also in deren Sicht ist alles offen, aber ich sehe da Amerika eigentlich wandlungsfähiger. Am Ende würde ich sagen, diese große Angst von Friedrich Merz, der ja da immer wieder historischer spielen möchte bei diesen Fragen, ist es glaube ich doch ein Systemstreit zwischen schafft man es durch Regulierung von oben, dann braucht man aber eine Wissensgrundlage, die man wie jetzt gerade durch die Turbulenzen sieht man bei China, die wahrscheinlich doch nicht so vorhanden ist oder überlässt man es dem Strukturwandel, wenn man sich dann doch Amy-Klobisca-Antitrust-Appellen dann öffnet und sagt, das muss schon sein. Also diese Pflöcke müssen eingeschlagen sein.
Obwohl ich sagen würde, dass Klobisca von dem, was China jetzt gerade macht, gar nicht so weit entfernt ist.
Genau, aber sie kommen eben aus der anderen Richtung und da würde ich sagen, ist Amerika besser aufgestellt für Wirtschaftswachstum und Zufriedenheit zu sorgen. Also gerade jetzt die letzte Woche macht mich noch mal so skeptisch beim Blick auf China. Diese enormen Anstrengungen, die da jetzt laufen, wo man schon sieht, die werden auch nervös, die machen es ja nicht ohne Grund. Gleichzeitig funktioniert dieses Banken- und Beton-Business nicht mehr so richtig und in der Energie auch nicht. Also totale Energiekrise, so richtig ist Organisationsproblem in der Ansicht.
Die Frage ist, ob sich das dann wirklich einstellt, dass das kompetitivere Wirtschaften so entstehen kann. Also erstmal ist das absolut schlüssig, wie hier von den Doppelgängern argumentiert wird, dass man sagt, da wo sich nicht solche Kartelle, Monopole herauf bilden können und es so eine Reichtumskonzentration gibt, da kann es natürlich mehr Wettbewerb geben. Das ist definitiv so. Nur ist die Frage, ob das auch möglich ist, wenn so stark mitorganisiert wird und dann kann auch viel schief laufen. Also ob das dann immer nach dem Konzept der Massenlinie, wie wir sie mal vorgestellt haben, so funktioniert, ist fraglich. Warum können wir uns aber jetzt schlussendlich noch fragen, will eigentlich die KP da zum Beispiel gegen Alipay vorgehen und warum geht es jetzt gerade diesen ganzen Privatfinanzdienstleistern an den Kragen? Da hat BBC World Business Report eine Antwort für uns.
Weil die Städtebanken, wie ich es erwähnt habe, vorhin alle Kredite gewonnen haben. Und jetzt sehen wir diese non-Städte, diese privaten Unternehmen, die sehr schnell wachsen und sich natürlich öffentlich planen, dass diese Unternehmen Ant, die Haltung von Alipay und seinen anderen Unternehmen, fast ein Jahr vor dem Shanghai-
und Hongkong-Bestandteil ein Jahr vor dem Hongkong-Bestandteil einsteigen wird.
Mal gucken, das sah ja immer so aus, als wenn die da so interessiert, unsensibel und würden die Gefahren sehen. Aber wir sehen jetzt gerade am Bauen und dieser Bank, dass sie dann doch hinter ihren eigenen Ansprüchen einfach zurückstehen.
Ich fand nur sehr schön diese kleine Wendung, dass er sagt, ja, China hat dann gemerkt oder die KP hat gemerkt, ach, die wissen ja mehr über die Bürger als wir. Und wir wollen aber eigentlich alles wissen. Und das widerspricht natürlich diesem Überwachungswahn, der davor herrscht. Denn Xi weiß, was eigentlich Daten wert sind, das betont hier nochmal die Financial Times.
Ever since about 2013 it's been clear that Xi Jinping has wanted to do this. I mean, he said way back then, that whoever controls data has the upper hand.
Ja, ich meine, Snowden ist jetzt acht Jahre her. Aber wir können davon ausgehen, dass die NSA weiterhin macht, was sie machte, sowohl um zu wissen, was in der Bevölkerung vor sich geht, als auch um die Kompetenz im eigenen Personal zu haben. Also die Mathematiker werden zuerst mal von NSA angesprochen und dann erst vom freien Arbeitsmarkt. Und in deren Sicht würde ich sagen, ja, da läuft auf jeden Fall so ein verdeckter Krieg und da werden die Chinesen, gerade die Chinesen, also die chinesische Regierung auch sehr hinterher sein, dass sie diesen Vorsprung, den sie sich da erarbeitet haben, nicht fallen lassen. Man übersieht ja immer wieder da bei den Uiguren und so, wie sehr das dieses Projekt des Datensammelns und der synthetischen Gesellschaftspolitik ist und so. Da wird eigentlich zu wenig drauf geguckt. Da wird es auch Snowden schon wieder vergessen und so.
In der Tat. Und man könnte ja auch mal...
Acht Jahre ist das her.
Schauen, was ist da vergleichbar. Ich will mal noch einen Vergleich wagen mit diesen Kleinkrediten, die man da überall nehmen kann. Und jetzt haben wir auch diese ganzen Finanz-Apps auch von den Banken, die uns anbieten, naja, wenn du es hier gerade nicht leisten kannst, nimm doch schnell einen Kredit, einfach mit dem Handy drüber gezogen. Wir hören jetzt erstmal, wie bei dem Financial Times Podcast ein Werbespot von Alipay beschrieben wird.
Hier ist ein chinesisches TV-Commercial für Alipay.
Der Sohn erklärt dem Vater, wie man sich ganz einfach schon mal verschulden kann. Das kann man vielleicht dann im nächsten Monat zurückzahlen. Und dann hatte ich im Kino einen Werbespot der Sparkasse gesehen und habe ihn dann noch im Internet gefunden und möchte auch da mal einen Ausschnitt vorspielen. Wir müssen uns jetzt das folgendermaßen vorstellen. Ein Paar, Mann und Frau, wollen ausgehen. Er braucht noch zu lange im Bad. Sie wartet auf ihn. Und jetzt gibt es diese Dialogsituation. Und wann sie wollen vor allem. Also was dann am Ende nochmal in diesem Spot eingeblendet wird, ist, dass es da so ein Kreditsystem auch gibt, dass man da schnell sich verschulden kann. Diese Konsumkredite sind ja in den USA extrem verbreitet. Da haben die Leute im Durchschnitt, glaube ich, sechs Kreditkarten, also eine unglaubliche Zahl, schon in den Nullerjahren gehabt. Und das ist jetzt auch etwas, was hier kommt. Auch gibt es ja Finanz-Apps jetzt, um mit Aktien zu handeln, bei denen man sich auch verschulden kann, um mit Aktien handeln zu können. Also da sehen wir auch schon, wie geschwächt der Kapitalismus global ist. Das heißt, wir haben eigentlich keine natürliche Nachfrage mehr, sondern es fehlt Geld, aber die Wirtschaft will unbedingt, dass der Kapitalismus wächst. Also kauft man sich Zeit in Form von privaten Krediten. Es ist so interessant, dass wir diese Austeritätspolitik haben, diese Schuldengrenze, Bremse, Debatte. Und man sieht gar nicht, dass da nicht das Problem liegt beim Staat, sondern die Privathaushalte werden eigentlich mit all diesen Apps und Werbungen dazu angehalten, durch die Influencer, sich zu verschulden und sich unglücklich zu machen. Und dann, wenn die dann verschuldet sind, dann redet man ihnen ein, ja Geld, Schulden sind aber auch was Schlechtes. Und deswegen müssen wir jetzt hier von staatlicher Seite sparen. Und wir sehen da also eine ganz deutliche Parallele. Ich will einen allerletzten Clip zu den Regulierungen spielen. Und zwar gilt es auch für den Nachhilfesektor. Der ist riesig in China. Denn man muss ja so eine bestimmte Punktzahl erfüllen, um dann irgendwie fortzukommen im weiteren Beruf. Also es ist noch stärker als jetzt beim Abitur oder so. Und da versuchen natürlich dann Familien mit Nachhilfen, ihre Kinder fit zu machen für diesen Test. Und das ordnet jetzt Steffen Wurzel im Deutschlandfunk für uns ein.
Also die Staatsführung sagt sinngemäß, wir machen das, um Druck rauszunehmen aus diesem System. Lerndruck einerseits. Frau Jahn, Sie haben es ja beschrieben. Der ist enorm in ganz Asien, aber eben auch hier in der Volksrepublik China. Und dann gibt es noch einen weiteren Punkt, der oft übersehen wird. Da geht es natürlich auch darum, den finanziellen, den wirtschaftlichen Druck auf die Eltern zu verringern. Viele Eltern sagen, wir dürfen jetzt zwar zwei oder sogar drei Kinder inzwischen in die Welt setzen, aber wir können nicht für drei Kinder so eine teure Nachhilfe auf die Beine stellen.
Extreme Kosten produziert das. Und jetzt hat China einfach gesagt, ne, es gibt jetzt keine private Nachhilfe mehr. Ihr dürft jetzt diese Kurse nicht mehr buchen, beziehungsweise diese Anbieter, das sind natürlich auch große Plattformen, haben jetzt einfach den Saft abgedreht bekommen. Und jetzt gibt es nicht mehr diese Form der privaten Nachhilfe. Die ist ab sofort verboten, wodurch natürlich diese Aktien extrem den Keller gegangen sind. Das heißt, man sagt jetzt, sie sollen es in eine Schule machen und es soll nicht mehr diese Vorteile geben, dass wer viel Geld hat, entsprechende Nachhilfen frequentieren kann. Und dann haben diese Kinder immer viel mehr Chancen als andere. Also man will auch da eine Gleichheit schaffen, wenngleich es natürlich schon Schlupflöcher gibt, wie das wieder ausgehebelt werden kann, indem man dann nicht mehr eine Mathe-Nachhilfe anbietet auf dieser Plattform, sondern zum Beispiel eine Logik-Hilfe. Und der Schwarzmarkt könnte dann auch bald blühen. Aber das ist jetzt auf jeden Fall ein Schritt, wie man versucht, so etwas wie eine Bildungsgleichheit herzustellen. Aber es hapert da eigentlich an so vielen Stellen in China, dass man sich fast fragen kann, ob das jetzt der richtige Ansatz war, hier mal zu beginnen.
Das sind ja eigentlich also diese Nachhilfen in asiatischen Raumen, auch in Südkorea und Japan. Du hast ja sechs Stunden Schule, kommst dann irgendwie 14 Uhr nach Hause und hast dann nochmal bis 19 Uhr durchgehend Unterricht in diesen privaten Schulen. Was machen die jetzt mit ihrer freien Zeit? Also selbst wenn man das jetzt in den grauen Marken verdrängt oder in so einem Schwarzmarkt, muss ich erst mal neu organisieren. Sehr viele Jugendliche haben ja dann einfach sehr viel Zeit jetzt, die sie dann nicht mehr in der Schule oder mit Schulkram verbringen. Gleichzeitig wird ihnen Videospielen weggenommen.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, das können sie auch nicht machen.
Vielleicht lesen sie das, oder wird das jetzt die Reiserepublik? Davon ist auch mal nicht auszugehen. Also in der Ansicht ist das schon verrückt. Ja, ich bin ein bisschen skeptisch. In China passt vieles nicht mehr so richtig. Sonst hat man immer draufgeguckt, nachzusehen. Gibt doch irgendwie Sinn. Aber jetzt gerade zerfällt das alles ein bisschen.
Andererseits ist Evergrande vielleicht eine kleine Angelegenheit. Also jetzt interessant hier für Leute, die an der Börse spekulieren. Aber es kann auch sein, dass das relativ gut wieder läuft.
Ja, da hängen schon viele familiäre Schicksale dran.
Man muss immer von 1, 3 Milliarden Menschen ausgehen.
Genau. Und 90 Prozent haben mindestens ein Haus. Sehr viele davon über ihn finanziert, über Evergrande. Und eben auch mit diesem sehr viele hängen jetzt in der Luft, weil sie es schon bezahlt haben, aber erst in drei Jahren bekommen. Jetzt wissen sie nicht weiter. Da entsteht ja auch so ein gewisser Panikdruck einfach. Eine Biografiegestaltung. Klar, die werden sich nicht groß organisieren, aber es sind dann einfach viele mit dem gleichen Schicksal. Also irgendeine Form von Schicksalsgemeinschaft wird sich schon bilden. Also ich bin mal sehr gespannt. China wird immer interessanter, würde ich sagen. Auch wenn man jetzt so langsam Befürchtung hat.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es so einen gleitenden Aufstieg weiter gibt bis 2050 und dann hat man das erreicht, sondern das wird noch sehr turbulent werden.
Bei Corona, die kommen ja aus Corona nicht raus. Wir haben jetzt Szenen in Australien und China, immer gleich Lockdowns. Ich meine, China importiert ja jetzt auch keine RNA-Impfstoffe und so. Die wollen ja dann einfach aus eigener Kraft. Das dauert ja auch noch ewig, so was zu machen. Also es ist schon brenzlig da. Aber wir sind ja weit weg hier in Europa, im sicheren Hafen. Das Wetter ist ja auch noch gut. Kleiner Corona-Winter noch, Pandemie der Ungeimpften.
Wir lassen ja jetzt die Pandemie noch mal Revue passieren im Salon mit Adam Tuss. Aber nur aus der wirtschaftlichen Perspektive. Also Adam Tuss sagt uns genau, was ist da eigentlich vorgefallen? Wann hat die FED was gemacht und wieso? Und wie hängt das mit uns zusammen oder auch mit den Entwicklungsländern? Also das ist zum Teil sehr funktionalistisch, aber hochinteressant. Ist vollkommen weg von dem Wirtschaftsdiskurs, wie er so gepflegt wird.
Das erwarte ich auch, ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist sehr erstaunlich. Und er räumt da mit vielen Mythen auf und sagt uns eigentlich auch, Geld ist vorhanden. Und das wurde jetzt auch von den entscheidenden Stellen erkannt. Also das ist sehr, sehr erstaunlich. Also ich hab schon weggebingt, das Buch.
Ah ja, sehr gut. Ich hab's noch vor mir. Ich lese immer jetzt, ich achte darauf, dann frisch im Salon mit frischer Lektüre zu sein. Ich werde es auch unter der Maximie lesen, dass wir jetzt einen neuen Bundeskanzler bekommen. Und Joe Biden hat ja noch einige auch überrascht mit seinem, ich hab übrigens einen 2 Billionen Pandemiehilfe, 3 Billionen Infrastruktur und einen 6 Billionen Wirtschaftsförderungsprogramm. Das wird ja immer größer. Und trotzdem würde ich sagen, noch recht lockere Diskussionen aktuell auch über das Debt-Sealing. Das werden sie ja wohl alles irgendwie wieder wegorganisieren, wie immer. Also unter der Ansicht, ja, wird das, glaube ich, eine gute Lektüre im Salon. Ich freue mich sowieso. Der Salon wächst ja wirklich stetig. Jetzt, glaube ich, so 2.800 Zuhörer. Ja, und es gibt ihn wirklich nur hinter der Paywall. Heute hat Klaus nochmal gefragt, ob er deine Besprechung der taiwanesischen Dorothee Bear nochmal irgendwo verlinken kann. Und da habe ich gesagt, nein, leider nicht. Es ist tatsächlich nur hinter der Paywall. Er lebt da selbst in Taiwan. Mal gucken, ob wir da für solche Fälle nochmal so ein... Aber es steckt jetzt erstmal nicht in Steady drin, dass man so Sachen dann mal fleckt, als kann jetzt verlinkt werden oder so. Das kann nur die Newsletterindustrie immer mal was so rausgeben. Gut.
Ja, und ich habe für unsere Abonnentinnen und Abonnenten noch einen interessanten Text gelesen. Ich beschäftige mich ja immer mal wieder gerne mit der Psychoanalyse. Und da gibt es immer eine Freud-Vorlesung, einmal im Jahr. In Wien findet die eigentlich statt, aber jetzt durch Pandemie war das nicht möglich. Und da war Jacqueline Rose. Und die spricht, wie eigentlich fast immer bei dieser Freud-Vorlesung, das üblich ist, über den Todes-Trieb bei Freud. Und bindet das natürlich an das Corona-Jahr an. Auch deshalb, weil die Lieblingstochter von Freud an der spanischen Krippe gestorben ist. Und zwar sehr spät, also als man eigentlich glaubte, die Krippe schon überwunden zu haben. Und da sind so viele interessante Gedanken noch mal dabei. Also ich dachte erst, naja, ist das jetzt so ein bisschen, aber man muss halt was über Corona machen. Aber es ist dann doch sehr erhellend. Und glaube ich auch für uns gut, das uns noch mal zu vergegenwärtigen.
Ich bin gespannt. Du triffst bei mir auf einen kritischen Psychoanalyse-Beobachter.
Es gibt ja heute nur noch kritische Psychoanalyse-Beobachter. Es gibt jetzt wirklich ein ganz winziger Kreis, der noch an der Psychoanalyse...
Ich meine, es ist die Praxis, also die psychologische Praxis, Psychotherapeutenpraxis, immer noch in erheblichem Maße Psychoanalyse.
Was?
Ja, ja, du findest nur ganz...
Aber das ist doch ganz selten.
Es gibt noch sehr viele... Also klar, der Nachwuchs...
Aber hier ist auch noch Geld, wo man sich eine Psychoanalyse leistet.
Du hast halt hier noch so das Westend-Publikum, das dann noch mehr wie nur zehn Stunden.
Ne, also eine Psychoanalyse, sagst du mir. Einer, der sich auskommt. Das macht man mehrere Jahre.
Also das ist hier immer noch virulent, um mal das richtige Wort zu benutzen. Verändert sich aber so langsam. Aber wie gesagt, ich komme halt aus Bielefeld.
Da ist man nicht bei der Psychoanalyse, definitiv nicht.
Ne, da ist man da falsch. Gut, ansonsten Containerschifffahrt. Einfach krasse Zahlen. Ich war ein bisschen überrascht, aber es ist wirklich, derzeit ist einiges durcheinander in der Welt, sagen wir es mal so. Es geht wirklich drunter und drüber. Den Rest suche ich noch raus, aber das Angebot ist wieder super. Also September war ein guter Lesemonat. Vielleicht nehme ich mir auch noch mal diese 150 Seiten Sloterdijk. Ich habe mich noch nicht ganz durchgerungen, aber Sloterdijk hat ja auch noch mal Reflexionen zur Corona. Ein Corona-Tagebuch in Dialogform. Mal gucken, eigentlich interessiert mich super.
Der Staat streift seine Samtanschuhe ab.
Richtig, der Staat streift seine Samtanschuhe ab.
Er hat wahrscheinlich Angst, dass der Staat zu groß ist. Er ist ja jemand, der möchte jetzt nicht hier den Staatskapitalismus wie...
Mal gucken, Sloterdijk wird auch häufig auf Überschriften reduziert. Und dann ist es so AfD-Ecken und irgendwie...
Sein Text übergebende und nehmende Hand ist schon sehr neoliberal.
Also mal gucken, mal gucken.
Aber er ist immer interessant. Ich finde auch, dass das immer sehr produktiv ist, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen. Inspiratives Lesen.
Man muss ja nicht immer all in gehen mit dem Autor, sondern man nimmt dann die Gelegenheit.
Und er ist ein Formulierungskünstler.
Eben. Und da bin ich sehr traurig, dass man ihn nur noch selten sieht, dass er im Fernsehen nicht mehr zu hören ist. Und dass es da jetzt auch so Generationenwechsel wohin zu prechten mit Lanz im Podcast gibt. Also irgendwie haben wir auch ein Nachwuchsproblem, würde ich mal sagen. Bei Philosophen, es kann einfach nicht Markus Gabriel die Lösung sein.
Nein.
Gut, mit diesem aufmunternden Gedanken verabschieden wir uns in den Salon nächste Woche.
Genau.
Haut rein und genießt noch den Altweiber-Sommer. Hier in Frankfurt sieht es gerade super aus.